on est un des cabinets les plus reconnus
dans un domaine en france qui s'appelle
la supply chain dans la soupe la chaîne
c'est très à la mode en ce moment avec
les crises successives pour faire venir
les produits des usines s'arrêtent parce
que les supply chain ne marche pas donc
on intervient du coup dans le monde de
la logistique des flux
d'approvisionnement des flux de
production
on est très reconnue par ceux qui
interviennent dans ce domaine
on a un cabinet français actionnaire
français on paye nos impôts en france on
et voilà on sait que pas le cas de tous
les cabinets jeu je tiens à le souligner
on existe depuis 2004
on est une on est environ 70 personnes
actuellement
donc notre
notre histoire vis-à-vis de l'état
puisque c'est la question qui nous est
posée aujourd'hui c'est zéro euro de
chiffre d'affaires avec l'état jusqu'en
nous avons par je pense notre notoriété
et est appelé
au tout début de la crise des masques
par la cellule de crise au ministère de
la santé qui cherche à se renforcer dans
le domaine de la logistique comme un des
cabinets notoire sur la place on est
venu un rendez vous on a fait une
proposition commerciale de 50000 euros
qui a convenu tout de suite et ils nous
ont demandé de l'ampl un confinement
de démarrer la mission le plus vite
possible parce qu'il s'agissait de
savoir comment le flux d'un pro des
masques qu'ils allaient débarquer très
vite d'asie on ne savait pas où les
stocker on ne savait pas comment opérer
le flux on sale et penserait pas comment
on allait le distribuer vers l'ensemble
des établissements de soin comment le
répartir donc en fait on nous a confié
une mission qui ne correspond à une
mission de schémas directeurs exactement
comme nos clients privés nous les
demandent sauf que c'était dans un délai
extrêmement court et en plein
confinement
alors on avait une chance c'est que
beaucoup de nos autres clients avait
tout arrêté donc on avait du personnel
disponible beaucoup de personnel
disponible on a fait appel sur nos trois
bureaux de paris lyon et nantes à qui
voulait monter à paris et venir
quotidiennement au ministère de la santé
à la cellule de crise dans la salle
bibliothèque simone veil si je me
rappelle bien pour travailler de longues
heures et est monté l'ensemble des
outils des processus aider à passer les
commandes en appui à la cellule de crise
sous l'autorité du général de chasse a
qu à cette époque là
et
bah la mission la mission donnant
satisfaction s'est enchaîné ensuite avec
les médicaments les médicaments de
réanimation les équipements de
protection
après l'été nous sommes passés à une
phase de transmission de notre savoir
faire donc il ya toute une phase qui
s'est appelée consortium pour pour
pérenniser finalement ce qui avait été
fait les outils les tableaux de bord etc
auprès des agents de l'état et on
pensait avoir fini d'ailleurs on a on a
fini à peu près au mois de novembre 2020
et nos clients habituels ayant repris
leurs activités nous étions plutôt
content de pouvoir retourner travailler
pour nous pour nos clients je vous le
cache pas nos équipes je tiens à nouveau
aller saluer elle était assez épuisé
plusieurs ont dû offre à attraper le
coït durant la période puisque
effectivement et prenez les transports
en plein confinement et c'est avec avec
des autorisations de déplacement
il se trouve que à peu près il ya un an
jour pour jour la cellule de crise
accent nous appellent à nouveau en
disant écoutez vous avez donné vous avez
fait entièrement satisfaction donné
satisfaction dans la période des masques
des équipements de protection et des
médicaments il se trouve qu'on va
déclencher maintenant la partie vaccin
il ya tout à faire toute la logistique
est à construire on ne sait pas où
commandes et les congélateurs dans
lesquels rapport m kaiser on sait pas où
est ce qu'on va stocker les vaccins sait
pas quand est ce qui vous arrive et il
va y avoir les ehpad à livrer il faut
constamment n'a pas de base de données
des ehpad on connaît pas leur adresse on
n'a pas la liaison entre les officines
et les ehpad donc
tout ça il ya des équipes très limitée
chez spf il faut apporter des outils des
méthodes construire sa est construite eu
constituer les schémas les schémas
logistiques voilà quelles ont été nos
missions qui ont donc représenté un
chiffre d'affaires significatif pour
nous en 2020 d'autant plus qu'il était
plus bas que d'habitude donc j'ai qui
représentait 1 25 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires et on a dépassé on dépassera
cette année largement les 10 millions
alors deux raisons
effectivement les 10 millions d'euros on
les dépasse largement parce que je pense
qu'il ya 30 35 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires qui représentait par le
travail qui est fait autour des vaccins
et comme nos équipes étaient très
tendues et qu'on était pas capable de
répondre à toute la demande et on est
toujours tendue est toujours en
difficulté aujourd'hui pour répondre à
la demande on a été chercher des sous
traitants ou cotraitants
pour pour nous renforcer renforcer nos
équipes vu l'intensité de la
sollicitation
ça vous après je peux rentrer plus dans
le détail de toutes les activités mais
je vous ai donné je pense brossé un
premier tableau et je me tiens à
disposition son ado tu as d'autres
questions merci
on va terminer avec monsieur bouteille
pur jus d'oseille france furent
donc jll france madame la rapporteure
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
donc j ll france est un groupe de
conseil spécialisée dans l'immobilier
d'entreprise avec une palette très large
de métier environ un millier de
collaborateurs en france on fait
d'ailleurs cette année nos 50 ans en
france
je crois que c'était pour ça que vous me
demandiez de venir au début mais
finalement pas
et donc nous avons des métiers de la
transaction des métiers du conseil des
métiers de ce qu'on appelle design build
c'est à dire une activité de
contracteurs général pour l'aménagement
des bureaux donc une palette large de
métiers autour de l'immobilier qui
touche aussi des fonctions de conseil
dans les différentes classes d'actifs y
compris dans la logistique
nous avons un chiffre d'affaires en
france de l'ordre de 400 millions
d'euros jeudi de l'ordre parce que c'est
425 en 2019 s'est un peu moins de 2
c'est autour de 350 en 2020 avec une
proportion assez faible et maintenant
nos interactions avec l'état
puisqu'elles représentent 2 8% en 2010 9
et 2 % de notre chiffre d'affaires
seulement 2020
dans le cadre de la crise sanitaire nous
avons été sollicités pour quatre
missions bien précises
toutes sont aujourd'hui terminés nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui deux missions en
cours avec l'état
la première
se
remonte à
c'est mars
à mars à avril 2020 où nous avons
apporté un support opérationnel pour la
distribution des masques
donc on se situe en période de
confinement et nous avons dépêché une
équipe pour
donc il y avait sept
lieues de consignation nous avons
dépêché une personne dans chacun de ces
lieux deux personnes en centrale et
quatre personnes auprès de la cellule de
crise
l'idée était de fiabiliser les stocks 1
vous souvenez évidemment qu'on était en
pénurie à ce moment là et donc une
gestion précise dans un système peu rodé
était importante pour
envoyer les stocks là au sein des
établissements de santé qui en avaient
le plus besoin pour que cette
distribution se fasse de la manière la
plus efficace possible et nous avons
apporté un support très opérationnelles
dans ce cadre là pendant deux mois pour
assurer la bonne remontée d'informations
entre les consignataires et la cellule
de crise pour que la cellule de crise
puissent prendre les bonnes décisions
à l'issue de cette période nous avons
été mandatés pour une deuxième mission
puisque le ministère de la santé des
solidarités a
souhaité à raison passer d'un chef de
schémas logistiques qui était
essentiellement lié à
ce qu'on appelle enfin qui était lié par
la disponibilité finalement des stocks
un schéma logistique plus classique qui
va dépendre de la demande des
différentes entités de santé qui en
exprimeront le besoin et dans ce cadre
là il ya plusieurs schémas logistiques
qui ont été désignés par le ministère et
sur lequel on nous a demandé de vérifier
la
technicité et la faisabilité
opérationnelle de chacun de ces schémas
c'est une petite mission qui a duré un
mois avec seulement deux personnes et
pour un montant de 60 mille euros ttc si
je reprends le
à la suite de cela certaines de nos
recommandations
touché au tour de l'ain segmentation en
fait des clients pour avoir un schéma
logistique optimale et dans ce cadre-là
a été décidé de mettre en oeuvre
finalement trois
types je dirais de schémas logistiques
pour les équipements de protection
individuelle dont font partie les
masques 1 destinée alors il ya pas mal
d'acronymes et je suis pas toujours
exactement le fait mais 1 1 qui était
gérée par les répartiteurs
essentiellement pour les clients comme
les pharmacies ça c'était quelque chose
qui était déjà en place et qui a
continué
quelque chose d'irréel gérés directement
par spf pour les j'ai acheté donc les
gros hôpitaux et puis un consortium qui
a été mis en place pour avec rza unis
achat et la poste pour gérer les
approvisionnements de ce qu'on appelle
les em les oeufs sms donc les
établissements
voilà merci qui demandait une autre au
type de logistique et
là nous avons été sollicités pour la
mise en oeuvre opérationnelle
voilà 2 2 ce troisième schéma et puis
ensuite à l'issue de cette donc là on
insisté notamment sur le déplacement
d'une partie du stock stratégique de spf
vers le consortium pour justement
réussir à fournir cette troisième
catégorie de clients et donc là il faut
bien gérer les quantités le type de
prise de commandes le type de livraison
en fonction c'est différent en
logistique quand vous commandez par
palettes ou quand comme vous commandez
avec des quantités un peu plus peu plus
petit et tout ça ça s'étudie et enfin
nous avons été sollicités dans le cadre
de la distribution des vaccins pour
comme le disait mon collègue mettre en
place la logistique sous contrainte à la
fois par le le délai qu'elle représente
est évidemment des contraintes
logistiques très fort puisque à l'époque
c'était pfizer - 72 degrés est de la
même manière qu'on avait fait pour les
masquer on a dépêché dans certains des
consignataires un certain nombre de
personnes pour assurer une remontée
d'informations
fiables et donc une distribution
efficace et à propos dans un moment de
crise donc voilà les quatre missions sur
lesquels nous sommes intervenus les
chiffres qui ont été remontés
au correspondent à peu près on peut en
parler il ya quelques
voilà je terminerai en faisant écho à ce
que disait on à mes collègues
le
[Musique]
donc d'une part il y avait une grande
fierté comme vous l'avez compris l'état
n'est pas un client j'irai structurels
en tout cas significatif
je veux redire ici la fierté que les
équipes ont eu d'avoir eu l'opportunité
finalement de pouvoir travailler sur ces
dossiers là à un moment où tout le monde
était à la maison on découvrait ce que
c'était qu'un confinement avoir le
courage de lever la main et de dire ok
moi j'ai envie d'y aller parce que je me
sens investi d'une mission c'était
quelque chose de fort chez nous en tout
cas en interne et je veux redire aussi
ici que dans nos valeurs l'éthique est
une des valeurs clés est primordial que
nous
que nous développons jll chaque employé
chez jll signe à son arrivée un code
d'éthique d'accord qui a pour but de
d'éviter les conflits d'intérêts qui a
pour but aussi d'éviter l'utilisation de
l'argent issu du terrorisme ou d'aidé
qu'est ce qu'on appelle les kawa ici et
que chacun de nos personnels et formés
chaque année pour s'assurer qu'il se
souvient ce qu'il a signé à l'arrivée
quand donc ça c'est que c'est quelque
chose je dirais d'important et dans le
cadre de la préparation de ce rendez
vous c'est pas quelque chose qu'on a
institutionnalisé
mais nous avons aussi vérifier que nous
n'avons pas d'aix fonctionnaires parmi
nos minots 1000 collaborateurs
c'est peut-être une idée on le fera
peut-être de manière systématique mais
puisque c'était une des questions c'est
quelque chose qu'on a vérifié pour les
besoins d'aujourd'hui
merci on va passer maintenant aux
questions donc madame la rapporteure
tout d'abord et vous répondrais selon
votre niveau de auquel vous êtes
concerné puis ensuite on passera à nos
collègues
merci monsieur le président je sais pas
comment on va procéder parce
qu'effectivement trois intervenants sont
intervenus les uns derrière les autres
d'en voir jouer c'est d'abord de d'abord
bienvenue au sénat si c'est votre
première fois donc c'est non donc
bienvenue
j'ai d'abord d'aider des questions
concernant jll et accenture
puisque l'un comme l'autre vous êtes
enfin gl elle est basée aux états unis
accenture est basé en irlande et j'ai
deux questions
est-ce que cela a des conséquences sur
le droit applicable aux traitements et
aux données au traitement et la
conservation des données par exemple on
regarde au regard du cloud américain ça
c'est la première question est la
deuxième question est ce que cela a des
conséquences sur les impôts payés en
france par vos sociétés
accenture et jdl
accenture france est une société
française depuis 45 ans on paye nos
impôts ici fait partie d'un réseau et
d'un groupe international mais accenture
france est une société française qui
paye ses impôts sur le territoire
français tous les tous les dossiers tous
les dossiers qu'on traite avec le
service public passe dans le code des
marchés publics et donc respecte tout à
fait les règles qui sont qui viennent de
ces marchés là
je fais là une réponse similaire ah
pardon vous enlevez le micro donc nous
ça fait cinquante ans que nous sommes en
france que nous payons nos impôts en
france que nos employés sont tous
exclusivement de soumis au droit
français et la question que vous posez
très justement sur le le là j'ai l'âge
rpd et la gestion des données est une
question que l'on a de tous nos clients
privés aussi et nous sommes évidemment
organisé pour enfin toutes les données
européennes sont stockés en europe et
est en france en l'occurrence donc il ya
il ya enfin voilà le la question de la
gestion des données que se pose le
l'état est tout aussi sensible pour
l'ensemble des autres et donc nous avons
dû mettre en place évidemment les
procédures pour que la gestion des
données soit je sois localisés dans les
pays où nous les traitons
d'écouté on va continuer à poser des
questions je vais commencer par monsieur
olivier girard d'accenture c'est donc
vous nous avait expliqué que la plupart
de vos prestations porte sur
l'accompagnement informatique si j'ai
bien compris donc d'accord donc est ce
que l'on pourrait savoir sur combien de
systèmes d'information êtes vous
intervenu
donc qu'est-ce que vous pouvez les
nommés à la commission devant la
commission denquête
s'agissant de l'application tous antico
ville est elle dans votre champ
d'intervention est ce qu'il est possible
que vous nous présenter votre
intervention sur les autres dispositifs
informatiques notamment survolent sipa
sanitaires les fichiers de vaccination
est un système d'information appeler sii
logistique
et donc le dernière qu'elle soutient
quelles sont vos relations avec la
direction interministérielle du
numérique la d8
pour le pardon décidément pour le pour
la première question combien de système
on vous répondra précisément dans la
note écrite par ce qu il peut y en avoir
un certain nombre dans le temps le cadre
de la gestion de la crise nous n'avons
pas construit de systèmes nous avons
participé c'est une équipe qui étaient
entre cinq et dix personnes depuis le
début jusqu'à aujourd'hui qui
participent à des travaux qui sont en
amont de la construction du système
c'est-à-dire des spécifications des
plantes thèse des plans d'interfaçage
donc on n'a pas touché on n'a pas
développé aux applications que vous
citez un peu connu voyez tous sentis
covin notamment et celle du pass
sanitaires non plus en revanche on a
construit des spécifications qui permet
de faire parler des systèmes ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure dans le propos
liminaire de les faire parler avec des
systèmes européens donc on n'a pas
touché à ce qu'on appelle du code dans
le jargon dans le cadre de cette de
cette mission là hélas d'inhumer et
aussi 1 1
un organisme de l'état avec lequel nous
travaillons également bien sûr
écoutez je vais continuer sauf s'ils
n'ont pas et j'ai continué par par par
monsieur laurent pénard sitwell donc
donc nous on a bien compris que vous
étiez vous spécialiser dans la chaîne
logistique notamment pour les masques et
les vaccins mais si je me trompe tout
est fait moi j'ai une question tout
savais que je serais posé à tout le
monde vous comme d'autres personnes ou
structures que nous allons auditionner
emploi et vous plus performant que
l'état dans l'organisation logistique
c'est une question on est plus
performant
en fait toute entreprise aujourd'hui
toute organisation fait appel à du
conseil pas que l'état aujourd'hui des
spécialistes
industrie des spécialistes industriels
je pense qu amazon fait appel à du
conseil
pas à site web mais décathlon
fait appel à des consultants comme nous
je dire c'est des spéciales
non mais je donc ils ont des
spécialistes de la logistique en tout
cas je ne sais pas moi je ne sais pas
répondre pourquoi l'état n'a pas de
spécialiste de la logistique je ne sais
pas c'est pas dans mon rôle de juger
quoi que ce soit sur les décisions de
l'état de fait
ce qu'on a constaté c'est que les agents
de l'état qui étaient affectés aux
missions on a travaillé avec des agents
de l'état qui était compétent qui
étaient peu nombreux sur ces sujets là
et qu'ils étaient ravis d'avoir autour
d'eux des collègues de travail durant
toute cette période qui leur disaient
comment comment faire au mieux comment
améliorer les solutions comment les
dépanner
à certains moments où il s'agissait de
trouver comment l'avion d'air france qui
va décoller de la chine pourra décoller
passé des choses ça me paraît pas
irréaliste que l'état français ne sache
pas opérer des soaps la chaîne mondiale
voilà
que s'il y avait des spécialistes comme
ça à faire en permanence dans l'état et
dans les services de l'état je me dirais
mais à quoi sert-il
tout simplement
en tout cas nous on a dû on a bien droit
on a beaucoup de mal à aller recruter à
les former nos spécialistes je peux je
peux vous le diront je crois que était
et est aussi abordée lequel la question
de comment recruter comment garder des
compétences de ce type là oui c'est des
cds - jeu des jeunes et des moins jeunes
collaborateurs qui veulent des projets
attrayant qui sont sur des systèmes
complexes qui ont des connaissances de
méthode et effectivement c'est parce
qu'ils vont travailler dans beaucoup
d'environnement qui vont être compétent
en fait
j'ai voilà je ne peux pas vous en dire
un peu plus sur les émissions de l'état
dans ce domaine merci monsieur stéphane
sautarel pour la première question nos
collègues oui merci monsieur le
président moi j'avais une question
essentiellement pour monsieur hainard
est boudée parce que je m'interroge en
fait sur la manière dont la commande a
été passée
puisque pour l'un vous avez évoqué en
fait ce que j'appellerais des commandes
en cascade c'est à dire suite à une
première commande d'autres commandes de
regard d'une satisfaction ou d'un besoin
qui existaient mais du coup quel a été
le vecteur de la commande publique et
pour l'autre vous avez souvent évoqué le
fait on a été sollicité mais et or nous
normalement dans la commande publique il
ya une
un appel d'offres est une consultation
il ya une réponse qui est apportée et
donc je voulais juste m'assurer de la
manière dans
le contrat public avait été produit
[Musique]
alors vous allez répondre le tour de
rôle autour de la tour de roover
simplement de gauche à droite ça vous
gêne je veux bien un jeu bien commencé
effectivement comme si j'avais décrit
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur la
première commande
je pense que c'est le contexte d'urgence
et de crise qui a fait cette cascade de
commandes et santé publique france en
2000 en 2021 est passé après en appel
d'offres et nous verrons après pendu à
cet appel d'offres au mois d'avril mai
et nous avons remporté cet appel d'offre
conjointement avec bearingpoint et jll
en sous traitant
mais ceci s'adresse en fait à nos
prestations à partir depuis l'été
dernier donc depuis le 15 juillet nous
sommes dans le cadre de cet appel
d'offres pas de démission que couvrait
cet appel d'offres d'appui à santé
publique france
est-ce que
ça couvre ma réponse couvre une réponse
à votre question
oui ça ça signifie donc que jusqu alors
il n'y avait pas de marchés publics et
où on peut l'expliquer par l'urgence
mais c'est un élément qui est important
pour notre commission de connaître ces
étapes là et essayer divers tente
d'autres mondes ça peut s'expliquer par
le montant des marchés aussi face à
la concurrence soul man qui peut peut
être passé sous sa coupe candidat qui
est pas formalisée de la même manière
tout à fait
bon monsieur girard quand vous nous avez
dit que vous aviez vous recours aux
moeurs à l'accord cadre des hits épais
et puis à lui ap est ce qu'il ya
d'autres éléments non séparent ces deux
véhicules contractuels la con on est
intervenu
en ce qui nous concerne c'est parce que
nous avons fait l'acquisition en 2019
donc conseil en supply chain qui est
très réputé dans le domaine que nous
avons émergé lors de la première mission
en tant que sous traitant sur la
première mission de masques et à partir
de là nous avons été identifiées donc
qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya eu un besoin
tels que décrits dans chacune des quatre
missions c'est là où nous avons été
sollicités systématiquement comme sous
traitants
je reviendrai vers vous pour être sûr
genou si vous l'avez été comme sous
traitants dans les pensées complète si
vous l'avez été en tant qu'entité de
votre entreprise vous avez
nécessairement répondu à un appel
d'offres
de ce que je dans l'état de mes
connaissances il me semble qu'il ya donc
il ya interne
urgence impérieuse ou donc sur ses
missions la de mémoire en tout cas dans
l'état je reviendrai vers vous pour être
sûr y'a pas il n'y a pas eu d'appel de
récits serez tous à paris voilà
exactement ce que nathalie goulet
oui monsieur le président je remercie
monsieur gérard j'allais vous pose
évidemment la même question que la
présidente à celle ci compte tenu du
siège de votre entreprise et de sa
situation et du fait que vous soyez
président pour la france et le
luxembourg ce qui attire chez certains
d'entre nous le nombre de réflexes
voilà donc vengé bien compris que vous
payez vos impôts en france
c'est très très bien j'allais vous
demandez est-ce que c'est ce sont tous
les impôts est ce que est ce que par
exemple politique de dividende est aussi
nationale et comment est-ce qu'elle
fonctionne est ce qu'il ya une est-ce
que vous reverser une partie
des revenus à une à une société mère qui
serait par exemple au luxembourg ou
ailleurs donc la totalité de la phase
que vous pourriez nous donner un peu la
structure fiscale de l'entreprise ou est
ce qu'elle est simplement
franco-française la deuxième chose vous
avez une partie de l'activité qui
s'exerce dans le lobby si j'ai bien lu
non alors j'ai mal lu donc en revanche
je crois que c'est monsieur boudet qui a
parlé de segmentation des clients ou est
ce que c'est vous monsieur gérard c'est
vous est ce que vous pouvez me dire ce
que ça veut dire parce que j'ai
absolument pas compris
alors je vais répondre en premier donc
je veux que le jura je voudrais répondre
ah oui alors la question de la question
très simple un accenture france paye des
impôts en france mais aussi les belges à
pâques et luxembourg choix dans le
périmètre que j'ai le privilège de 2,10
g de diriger pardon donc on vous fera
des compléments par écrit si nécessaire
mais c'est tout à fait simple et voilà
accenture france fait les revenus en
france à des contrats français avec des
clients français et des ressources
française et puis et paye ses impôts ici
et madame pour répondre à votre question
sur la segmentation des clients un
schéma logistique dépend de la fréquence
de vos commandes détail moyenne que vous
commandez et de vos capacités de
stockage avoue encore quand vous prenez
un amazon vous passer une commande
aujourd'hui et vous est livré dans deux
heures dans d'autres schémas vous vous
allez par exemple dans un magasin est
donc un autre schéma logistique qui
s'applique dans le cadre ici il a été
identifié que certains clients dans la
d22
qui participait dans le chaînage des
équipements de protection individuelle
avait des schémas logistiques différents
les pharmacies par exemple qui en
général commande le matin je crois et
rend quelque chose l'après midi les j'ai
acheté les gros hôpitaux qui elles
peuvent commander par exemple par
palettes ou des petits hôpitaux qui vont
avoir des besoins de quelques cartons
par exemple et donc les besoins
logistiques étant différent pour chacun
de ces acteurs pour de manière à avoir
une qualité de service et un coup
adéquat qui correspondent aux besoins
des clients il vaut mieux les divers les
diversifiés car si vous appliquez un
schéma logistique unique à tout le monde
soit vous n'aurez pas la bonne qualité
de service soit vous aurez des coûts
trop élevés donc c'est ça un peu le but
des recommandations si vous voulez
qu'ils ont contribué à avoir un schéma
logistique différenciées en fonction des
différents segments de clients
voilà je ne sais pas si ça non
merci pour ces précisions nicole dure
longtemps
merci monsieur le président où merci
messieurs pour vos différentes
interventions donc j'aurai deux
questions auprès de monsieur bénard et
une auprès de goode et donc les projets
de transformation que vous avez menées
sur les chaînes d'approvisionnement
les différents groupes grands groupes
industriels sont ils différents des
projets de la transformation de l'action
publique de l'état et si oui quelles
sont les principales différences et
l'autre question c'est donc un cabinet
de conseil est il plus influent lors de
la phase de conception d'une politique
publique comme ici une encre parlement
ou lors de sa phase de mise en oeuvre
déploiement exécution contrôle donc
auprès du gouvernement et des services
de l'état
et je dirais c'est la temporalité des
choses qui peut faire d une entreprise
qui va nous consulter parce qu elle l
euro réfléchit à sa manière d'adresser
ses marchés ses clients comme comme dit
précédemment
va se donner un peu de temps va
travailler avec ces directions
commerciales son marketing va prendre le
temps de d'exprimer un besoin ce qui
peut amener peut-être à changer la
manière de décider de ses transports par
exemple à changer des modalités pour
passer de transport routier ou maritime
plutôt qu'avion enfin là il peut y avoir
ce genre de choses décidé d'ouvrir des
nouveaux entrepôts ou d'enfermer de se
redéployer en général cdd schéma qui
sont dans une certaine longueur
il ya forcément des sites des sites et
des effectifs à redéployer et c'est donc
la phase de réflexion prend du temps en
général il faut que tout le monde soit
bien d'accord et puis qu'on déclenche
une transformation après il faut opérer
cette transformation est là faut
accompagner les équipes ça peut être des
ménages et d'aménager des sites changer
la manière dont on planifie l'activité
cédée projet qui se déroule sur
plusieurs années très souvent ce qu'on a
constaté même avec les entreprises
privées ces derniers temps c'est que ce
temps c'est dans cet intervalle de temps
considérablement fondu parce qu'ils ont
été obligés de redéployer des logistique
extrêmement rapidement parce que des
marchés s'était fermé des
approvisionnements c'était fermé et donc
une grande partie des sollicitations
qu'on a en ce moment sont totalement
liés à sa son jeu doit redéployer mes
ressources pour essayer de servir un
certain nombre de marchés il ya beaucoup
de similitudes finalement avec ce qu'on
a vécu là durant la crise puisque en
quelques semaines on apprenait que
astrazeneca qui devait arriver de
manière très massives finalement
n'arrivent pas du tout de manière
massive donc on avait fait un premier
schéma visant à dire toutes les
officines pourront avoir tant de flacons
tout le monde pourra commander deux ou
trois flacons par semaine et puis y
compris les médecins etc en fait on
apprend une semaine avant que c'est
peut-être un tiers ou un quart des
volumes qui arrive que fait-on et donc
là il ya plusieurs scénarios qui ont été
proposées
à la cellule la cellule de crise pour
dire va soit on dit à tous les médecins
vous commandez pas plus d'un flacon soit
on laisse ce toutes les commandes pas
voilà donc là il ya une adaptation sur
un délai très court par rapport à une
pénurie qui nécessitent des calculs
savoir combien de personnes on va servir
on était en liaison avec les ars leur
demandant d'opérer aussi des décisions
complexes avec les différents
établissements de santé donc en fait des
raisonnements qu'on a l'habitude de
faire sur plusieurs mois là il fallait
les faire quelques fois en quelques
jours c'est pour ça que des comités de
pilotage quotidien qu'on avait
s'éternisait bien plus tard que
habituellement on finissait des fois à
22 heures pour sortir un nouveau
scénario qui serait soumis à la cellule
le lendemain
j'ai pas répondu à toutes vos questions
mais peut-être sur un sur cet aspect là
je peux poser ma question mme thibout
dit oui monsieur donc vous vous avez une
expérience professionnelle à l'étranger
notamment en allemagne et en russie donc
quel ce quelle est selon vous donc les
principales différences en fait
d'interaction entre le public et le
privé en matière de politiques publiques
en fonction des pays
je suis vraiment incapable de répondre à
cette question puisque comme je vous le
dis nos interactions en france sont
assez limitées et en allemagne là où
vous faites référence j'étais dans une
autre fonction le le hasard veut que
j'étais patron de la supply chain de
danone à l'époque d'accord donc rien à
voir avec l'immobilier et ont réussi
j'étais pour jll mais on ne travaillait
pas avec l'êta donc je suis vraiment
incapable de vous répondre par contre je
veux bien rebondir sur le point
précédent et peut être complétée je
pense que vous allez demander
où est ce qu'un cabinet de conseil a
plus d'influencé sur
la partie conception sur la partie mise
en oeuvre c'est sans aucun doute sur la
partie conception d'accord et toutes les
missions en tout cas que j'ai décrite et
je crois mes collègues aussi sont
uniquement des et de la mise en oeuvre
opérationnelle au jour là dans tous ces
cas là il y avait une cellule de crise
qui prenait des décisions il y avait des
exécutants et donc l'apport des conseils
en tout cas de jll dans ce cadre là
c'était vraiment d'apporter de
l'exercent de l' expertise et des
besoins humains sur des décisions qui
étaient prises par l'état
nathalie goulet un petit complément
minuscule sur est ce qu est ce qu est ce
parce que quand vous êtes arrivé vous
avez vous avez vous nous avez dit
d'ailleurs qu'il y avait des failles
dans les dispositifs et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'on a eu recours à ces
cabinets est-ce que vous avez suscité
des vocations à l'intérieur des
administrations dans lesquels vous avez
travaillé
est ce que par hasard on a créé un
département de façon non pas à absorber
vos connaissances mais en tous les cas à
former des gens à l'intérieur des
administrations ce qui permettrait
éventuellement de prévenir un certain
nombre de difficultés à l'avenir ou es
ce que vous avez le sentiment que le
rôle
leurs cours le recours à des cabinets
extérieurs a constitué un tel
soulagement qui va être une procédure
qui va perdurer dans le temps ce que
c'est quand même important quand il ya
des failles comme ça qu'on essaye de
zéro est ce que quand on a quand même
des fonctionnaires 100 milliards des
administrations que le monde entier nous
envie est-ce que vous avez suscité des
vocations pour combler les trous dans le
dispositif alors dans la mesure où nous
sommes en fort recrutement j'espère
qu'on a suscité des vocations et on sera
ravis d'accueillir les talents phi phi
faire ta
c'est face à la question ouais
c'est exactement le contraire
la seule chose que je rajouterais c'est
que
puisque là on parle de missions qui sont
passés en temps de crise et je suis
aussi chef d'entreprise je n'essaye pas
d'être équipé pour faire face à toutes
les crises possible ça me donnerait une
base de coûts qui seraient tout
simplement inacceptable par rapport à
mon activité et donc pour répondre à
votre question il ya certainement enfin
des éléments à prendre en compte
conseiller le gouvernement de s'équiper
pour faire face à toutes les crises y
compris celle d'une ampleur du coc vide
dans tous les cas de figure c'est pas
certainement quelque chose qui qui qui
qui serait économiquement viable à mon
avis
merci et que je peux je peux compléter
si vous voulez parce qu'il ya un mais au
projet une expérience positive de ça
effectivement dans la dans la période
j'ai évoqué un moment donné que on a
commencé à transférer du savoir faire
mais il n'y a pas eu que ça en fait il y
aller aujourd'hui vous avez des
centrales d'achat qui
interviennent au carrefour justement des
besoins hospitaliers je pensais unis
achat ou
reza
c'était plutôt des centrales d'achat qui
consolidait des besoins mais n'avait pas
réellement de logistique la logistique
était laissée aux établissements de
soins je pense que la crise a leur a
fait prendre conscience du rôle
particulier que vous pouvez jouer c'est
ces établissements et qui ont commencé à
se structurer donc aujourd'hui ils sont
effectivement en train d'évoluer je
pense vers beaucoup plus une capacité à
adresser comment je peux être un tiers
intermédiaire entre les différents
établissements de soins et les
fournisseurs les laboratoires etc et
avoir cette capacité et du coup on
monter en compétences on
recherchait à accroître leurs
compétences dans ce domaine
ce qui sera certainement pas à l'avenir
un quelque chose de très positif pour la
capacité de réaction parce que je pense
par exemple si la crise des masques se
reproduisait demain il serait il sera
tout à fait en situation réagir
merci
nicole durand a demandé la parole pour
un petit complément rapide et on prendra
tout de suite derrière la question de
patrice joly merci monsieur le président
donc qu'est ce qui pourrait faire qu'un
cabinet de conseil s'intéresse mois à la
gestion de la des politiques publiques
merci j'aimerais dire merci messieurs
pour vos interventions ma question sera
relativement simple
l'intervention de cabinet conseil est
d'autant plus pertinente qu au sein de
l'institution d'administration de
l'organisme qui a recours il y a déjà un
minimum d'expertisé qui me conduit à ce
que les cahiers des charges comme défini
de manière la plus pertinente possible
et de manière à ce qu ensuite pendant de
la mission et
et comment se déroule on est
effectivement un véritable
accompagnement est ce que vous avez eu
le sentiment de disposer en face de vous
d'interlocuteurs suffisamment comment
compétent sur les matières sur
lesquelles vous êtes intervenu merci ces
deux questions messieurs qui répond
je veux je veux bien prendre la question
merci oui la réponse est oui je pense
que pour que les choses s'enchaînent
parce que ça a été très bien décrit à ma
droite la gauche le temps réel était le
temps de cette crise et donc il y avait
bien eu un une conjugaison des
expertises les expertises de
l'environnement de là santé en france et
des expertises judiciaires ma droite à
ma gauche logistique et dans mon cas
plus technologique et c'est cette
addition là qui a fait qu' on n'a plus
fonctionné dans ce temps réel là donc
oui je pense qu'il ya eut bien une
addition d' expertise six mondes
expertise pour écouter les expertises
j'ai bien compris qu'elle avait
complémentarité s'était pas tout à fait
le sens de ma question c'est est ce que
vous avez trouvé à l'intérieur
effectivement des interlocuteurs qui
avaient un minimum de connaissances sur
votre expertise pour pouvoir en tirer le
meilleur parti
oui je vais peut-être pas bien répondu
mais c'est ce que je voulais dire oui
tout à fait et oui
vous souhaitez compléter messieurs
vous
non enfin bon le gt pas moi en contact
évidemment direct mais le retour et
finalement les résultats font vraiment
pencher là mais je trouve que vous
soulevez un point qui est très très
juste un conseil il faut aussi le gérer
le manager d'accord et pour ça il faut
avoir
voilà effectivement ce niveau de
compétences en interne pour donc c'était
tout à fait voilà à propos - le retour
des équipes étaient très encore une fois
beaucoup découvrez les interactions avec
la sphère publique était vraiment
impressionné à la fois par le deal le
niveau des gens est ce que c'est un
niveau de compétence exact je sais pas
vous dire parce que j'étais pas en
contact direct mais des retours très
positifs
sur la question de m duranton
conseillère oui effectivement j'ai noté
le terme influence alors je me sens très
mal à l'aise avec ce terme
parce que je vois pas que en dehors
d'une la seule influence qui était notée
de notre part tous les soirs c'était
quand vous dites l'influencent des
cabinets sur la sphère publique car
c'était votre question
je sais pas répondre à cette question
s'intéressent moins non quand on répond
quand on répond à des sollicitations
cherche pas forcément
influencé je dirais que je mets ça c'est
moi ma posture de cabinet plus
opérationnel et vous reveniez auparavant
sur une question assez intéressante qui
avait posé également madame de l'entente
sur la question de l' influence
développer un peu ce que vous avez
commencé à dire oui oui non mais j'ai
effectivement j'avais j'avais noté ce
mot clé parce que effectivement
s'il ya s'il ya effectivement un regret
qu'on pourra conserver nous peut-être
au-delà de cette crise c'est de se dire
est ce que on a essaimé des savoir-faire
et effectivement c'est un retour
d'expérience très important à avoir nous
jeu je sais qu'il ya un certain nombre
de permanents dans les différentes
instances qu'on a pu conseiller avec
lesquels on a opéré qui sont toujours là
il y en a un certain nombre qui ont
changé de poste
des fois je dirais un peu
malheureusement parce que il ya une
autre une nouvelle personne qui est
arrivé et on a on l'a formé à nouveau on
l'accompagné et c est ça en pleine crise
c'est vrai que ça c'était ce n'était pas
forcément simple
merci alors messieurs moi j'ai trois
questions pour vous je vous demanderais
s'il vous plaît d'y répondre
successivement la première c'est avez
vous effectué des prestations gratuites
pendant la crise sanitaire si c'est le
cas mais pour quelles missions et
combien de consultants avez vous
mobiliser toujours si c'est le cas c'est
mission se sont-elles prolongée par la
facturation de prestations
complémentaires à titre onéreux
voilà pour le premier bloc de questions
il a deux la dernière question c'est
[Musique]
je souhaite que vous ne puissiez nous
décrire un peu précisément les
conditions dans lesquelles vous avez pu
accéder à la cellule interministérielle
de crise
on commence par le pro bono monsieur
bénard
pas de pro bono je dirais que
on a en a constitué des équipes avec des
niveaux de séniorité très différents et
on a
toujours tâché d'appliquer un taux
journalier moyen qu'ils soient de 20 à
30% inférieurs à ce qu'on fait avec les
entreprises privées voilà ce qui fait
qu'on s'est retrouvé à un peu plus de
1000 euros alors que notre taux habituel
est plutôt à 1300 et 1400 au niveau des
entreprises privées
après on a fait beaucoup d'heures
supplémentaires est bon ça
c'était
voilà ça faisait partie du don du don
que les collaborateurs étaient tout à
fait amené à fermer dès jeudi dans
toutes les toutes nos prestations fait
l'objet de bons de commande successifs
comme on l'a dit et côté effectivement
en fonction du du temple du temps passé
par les équipes il votre accès à la
cellule interministérielle de crise
un coup de fil un coup de fil comme je
vous le disais
les procédures de sécurité particulières
pardon c'est ce qu'il y avait des
procédures de sécurité particulières
dans quel cadre pour accéder à la
cellule de crise à vous lire pour aller
dans les locaux
faut que je vérifie parce que moi j'ai
été personnellement chez santé publique
france donc plutôt dans la deuxième
partie nos interventions au ministère de
la santé je ne faut que je demande c'est
lé
monsieur jr
sur votre première question précisément
sur l'enchaînement prestations gratuites
puis prestations payantes non pas
puisque ici encore une fois on a été
invités à répondre à des demandes et on
a fait des devis dans le cadet des
objets dont je parlais tout à l'heure
accenture fait du pro bono par ailleurs
quasi essentiellement pour le monde
associatif et je vous répondrai plus
précisément par écrit sur sa sur la
question de la cellule dont vous parlez
j'avoue que je ne sais pas je prendrai
le temps de me répondre par écrit sur
cette question très précise je vous ai
un peu pareil pas de pro bono chez nous
et
comme je voulais dire nous avions des
personnes dépêchées pour assurer la
bonne fluidité des informations
mais je sais pas exactement dans quelles
conditions ça c'est fait puisque moi je
n'étais pas bon je vous répondrai par
écrit là-dessus
même le reporter
oui merci monsieur président une
question à vous trois si vous permettez
monsieur la première c'est une seule
question d'ailleurs est-ce que vous
utilisez les données transmises par
l'état français pour répondre aux
commandes d'autres clients notamment
pour réaliser un benchmark avec d'autres
pays ça c'est ma première question à
chacun d'entre vous et si je peux me
permettre de poursuivre
particulièrement à monsieur girard
accenture est ce que l'état pourrait
continuer d'utiliser le pas salutaire si
aujourd'hui vous décidiez de vous
retirer du système
d'information correspondant
voilà je pense que c'est une question
qui peut intéresser beaucoup de nos
concitoyens et nos concitoyens au delà
de cette commission denquête et puis une
dernière question aussi un
bout d'essai la dernière commande qui a
été passée par l'état votre entreprise
elle date de décembre 2020
donc est ce qu on pourrait savoir
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas intervenu
depuis
et puis
historiquement vous êtes spécialisé dans
le conseil en immobilier si j'ai bien
compris et de quelle manière et doux
devenu avec fierté le lait noter un
cabinet généraliste capable
d'accompagner l'état dans la gestion de
la crise sanitaire je remercie
on sait par monsieur bénard
l'utilisation des données cet essaim
votre question tous nos contrats sont
dans des cadres confidentialité totale
je sais que dans le cadre de du
ministère de la santé la et de spf tous
les documents en question les serveurs
de l'administration
on a systématiquement laisser toutes les
données dans le cadre dans le cadre
public donc après voilà je je dirais si
c'est pour utiliser de faire du
benchmark
interpays nous on n'est pas très
concernés parce qu'on est très français
et je vois pas bien je vois pas bien ce
que ça drôle ça signifie que vous
n'utilisez pas les données que vous avez
recueillis dans le cas des commandes de
l'état pour nourrir des bases de données
qui permettent de construire après une
réflexion interdite l'air non non c'est
interdit
ah oui par notre le prix et les contrats
puis de toute façon tous nos clients
nous l'interdisent aussi me pose cette
question là parce que
quand beaucoup car que ce soit l'état ou
des collectivités d'ailleurs quand on
pose des questions à des conseils en
stratégie ils ont recours à des études
de comparaison extérieur wenche marque
en bon français qui sont manifestement
nourris par leurs expériences qui l'ont
d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs c'est ce que
c'est la commande du client c'est
essayer un peu le fonds de commerce du
conseil en stratégie qui intervient donc
vous ce n est pas votre corps malade en
tout cas dans ce cadre là c'était
strictement
interdite entre en général être les
entreprises privées on a un devoir de
confidentialité on signe des clauses de
confidentialité
quand une durée donc ça pour ça que
votre question sur les benchmark
internationaux de certains confrères
quand on en voit certains effectivement
on les regarde avec un oeil amusé parce
que sinon ça peut être que des données
très périmé alors on peut nous on
pourrait pas on pourrait utiliser des
données de nos clients mais une fois le
contrat de confidentialité clos donc
c'est à dire trois quatre ans après
avoir travaillé avec eux ou alors que
les données soient publiques soit
devenue publique parce que eux-mêmes les
ai publiées dans des dents des études ou
dans des revues donc
c'est rarement pertinents et ce point de
vue le jura donc sur la question de la
pérennisation de l'application
passe-passe sanitaires je prendrai le
temps de vous répondre par écrit
sérieusement mais je suis à peu près sûr
que si demain accenture s'en va sur ces
sujets là la vie continue bien pour
passer sanitaire donc je suis je suis
confiant là dessus sait on l'a évoqué un
peu avant ça fait partie de notre
travail ne peut-être notre activité que
de transférer les connaissances la
mission est terminée le travail était
terminée quand les connaissances sont
sont transmis c'est un jalon essentiel
il y avait par ailleurs comme dans
toutes les situations de crise vous
savez on construit souvent des systèmes
à côté des systèmes parce qu'on est dans
l'urgence et et un de nos sujets de
préoccupation et en os livrables dans
cette danse et 20 derniers mois étaient
autour de la pérennisation de toutes les
briques logicielles qui ont été
construits oui ou non il ya un dossier
spécifique sur ce sujet là qu'est ce qui
peut être conservé et qu'est-ce qui peut
rajouter la valeur demain à l'ensemble
du système d'information santé
sur les données vous concernant alors
c'est la même chose on sait tous nos
contrats sont absolument confidentielles
et on personne fait ça dans la dans la
profession il peut y avoir des benchmark
sur des modes de fonctionnement
c'est-à-dire comment tel ou tel pays à
gérer la crise sanitaire certains l'ont
fait de façon beaucoup plus
décentralisée c'est un certain en fait
de façon plus régionale et c'est pas des
benchmark qui utilise des données de
flux de consommation cd benchmark de
fonctionnement c'est tout à fait
différent et donc en toi en tout cas
pour ce sujet là absolument pas
qu'il y avait trois questions sur les
données
encore une fois nos missions étaient
très opérationnelles sont des gens dans
l'est
stockage de consignation qui font
remonter des informations comme je
voulais dit nous on signe tous une
charte de déontologie direct d'une part
je vois pas tellement qu'elle donnait
dans un cadre tellement opérationnels
sont exploitables mais en plus comme je
voulais dit nous signons tous une charte
de déontologie
et avons les mêmes sujets de
confidentialité tel que décrit par mes
collègues
donc la réponse est non absolument nous
il n'y a aucune information
auquel nous avons pu accéder dans le
cadre de l'exécution de nos missions de
nos quatre missions avec l'état que nous
pourrions réutilisés pour faire un
benchmark quel qu'il soit
la deuxième question portait je crois
sur comment est ce qu un cabinet de
conseil en immobilier peut devenir tout
d'un coup aussi généralistes
le
l'évolution de nos métiers nous a amenés
à être de plus en plus en amont dans la
demande de nos clients dans les bureaux
par exemple qui est quelque chose qu'on
qu'on peut lire le changement des modes
de travail le télétravail nous a obligés
à réinventer nos métiers et ça fait un
moment qu'on développe une practice dans
cette partie là et je répondrai
spécifiquement sur la logistique pour
aider les entreprises à définir le rôle
du bureau pour eux donc des réflexions
plus en amont que simplement trouver un
endroit
physique un prix de marché
d'accord donc on essaye de faire évoluer
tous nos métiers pour coller plus aux
besoins de nos clients et donc être plus
en amont dans leur prise de décision en
logistique ça se traduit par notre
capacité et ça nous a conduits ça m'a
conduit à acheter un cabinet de conseil
en supply chain en 2019
qui
véritable fleuron pour aider nos entre
nos clients à créer des réseaux
logistiques à comprendre la quantité
d'automatisation qui doivent avoir dans
leurs entrepôts donc réglé si vous
voulez leur problème amont avant même
qu'il ait décidé de prendre un entrepôt
à tel ou tel endroit donc c'est dans ce
cadre là précisément pour la supply
chain que nous avons une expertise
particulière qui a été mis à
contribution dans le cadre de ses quatre
missions je vous vois fronçait les
sourcils
d'un pardon je reformule oui vous êtes
un cabinet est spécialisé en immobilier
mais vous avez acheté une compétence
extérieur avant la crise sanitaire sur
la supply chain oui et c'est elle que
vous avez mises à contribution tafer et
est ce que nous faisons en supply chain
nous le faisons dans toutes les autres
classes d'actifs je vous ai donné les
parts dans l'exemple des bureaux genre
on peut parler du retail des hôtels et
et de tout le reste est une véritable
stratégie d'entreprise et l'avait
vraiment et visionnaire pardon vous êtes
un visionnaire et et ont tous les
instants plus
est la dernière question là
notre dernière mission consistait à dans
la distribution des vaccins
à c'était une mission qui a duré quatre
mois on nous a demandé d'assister à
l'établissement des plans de transport
s'est fait valider les solutions de
transport pour les dépositaires s'est
fait valider les processus logistiques
c'est fait l'état n'a plus besoin de
nous donc on nous a demandé de enfin
donc il ya plus lieu aujourd'hui de
continuer la mission elle est effectuée
mais nous nous tenons à la disposition
si quelqu'un besoin de nous évidemment
voilà pour ces auditions n'hésitez pas à
lire les articles de la rédaction sur
notre site jour de mairesses et elle
s'affiche c'est publicsenat.fr notre
journaliste elena berkaoui revient sur
les moments forts de cette audition avec
ce titre les cabinets de conseil sur le
grill de la commission denquête c'est la
fin de cette émission merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi très bonne suite des
programmes sur public sénat
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
[Musique]
l'actualité parlementaire et politique
continue sur publicsenat.fr
dans il était une fois nous vous
emmenons dans les coulisses des grandes
batailles parlementaires celles qui ont
écrit l'histoire celle qui ont fait les
grandes heures du sénat
c'était il ya quarante ans la france
décidé d'en finir avec la peine capitale
nous sommes le mercredi 30 septembre
1981 le projet de loi portant abolition
de la peine de mort présenté par le
garde des sceaux robert badinter est
adopté par les sénateurs
ont beaucoup à l'époque c'est une
immense surprise un sénat de droite
vient d'adopter en première lecture un
acte fondateur de la gauche au pouvoir
comment pourquoi s'est-il passé pendant
ces trois jours de débats publics et de
discussions discrètes c'est l'histoire
que nous allons vous raconter
il était une loi quand le sénat écrit
l'histoire ce soir à 22h sur public
sénat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'âme de m
les éolien ici temps je serai berre ce n
est absolument pas question
il faut que ce soit le conseil municipal
qui délibère on a des craintes notamment
un département de la somme de voir
doubler le nombre d'éoliennes
porter
ce genre d'amendements mais à terre
toute stratégie énergétique française
généralement ça se passe bien quand ça a
été conçu avec les élus pour le
territoire et pour les habitants alors
vous êtes à montdidier catrall yens
kubrick les seuls public de france le
vent vous voyez bien ici bien à vau
l'eau et nous permet vraiment
d'alimenter de courir 50 % de nos
besoins
ces noms d'action demain 19h sur public
sénat à mon avis
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur bonjour je viens pour
faire ma dose de rappel il ya des rendez
vous à ne pas manquer pour continuer à
vous protéger
penser dès maintenant à votre dose de
rappel
incroyable il ya encore quelques mois on
assiste aujourd'hui un retour en grâce
de l'énergie nucléaire dont les
réacteurs deviennent petite analyse d'un
discours et d'un buzz militants cette
semaine dans hashtag
#f1 18h sur public sénat
[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver pour sa dernière émission de
l'année nous sommes ensemble pendant une
heure et demie pour décrypter
l'actualité politique parlementaire et
l'actualité dans nos régions dans une
demi-heure notre invité ce sera jean
louis debré sa vision de l'actualité
nous la donnera et puis il nous parlera
de sa pièce de théâtre sur ces femmes
qui ont réveillé la france dans le club
des territoires on fera le bilan de
l'année justement retour sur trois temps
forts les travaux du sénat sur les
violences sexuelles les régionales et
puis la primaire de la droite et pour
commencer nous sommes avec le sénateur
rémy cardon bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin vous
êtes élu de la somme c'est le premier
département éolien de france est
justement on va parler de ce sujet avec
vous puisque notre journaliste j'ai
rendra bien réaliser un reportage sur
les éoliennes il viendra nous en parler
mais d'abord en regardant semblait
repères de l'actualité de ce vendredi 17
décembre
un nouveau conseil de défense se tient
cet après-midi le gouvernement qui
s'apprête à annoncer de nouvelles
mesures pour lutter contre la vague de
kovy de flora sauvage
face à la propagation rapide du variant
omicron en france plusieurs hypothèses
sont sur la table si des mesures
strictes comme un confinement où un
couvre-feu sont écartés le gouvernement
étudie l'idée de raccourcir le délai
entre la deuxième et la troisième dose
de vaccination actuellement fixé à 5
mois car les projections des
épidémiologistes sont inquiétantes
autres hypothèses étudiées le
renforcement des contrôles aux
frontières à partir de demain les
voyageurs en provenance du royaume uni
devront se munir d'un test antigénique
ou pcr de moins de 24 heures présenté un
motif impérieux à l'entrée du territoire
et ils subiront un isolement de sept
jours qui pourra prendre fin après un
test négatif au bout de 48 heures réunis
à bruxelles hier les chefs de l'état et
de gouvernement des vingt-sept ont
souligné l'importance d'une approche
coordonnée sur le pass and i ter en
europe nous n'envisageons pas de mettre
des tests au sein de l'union européenne
parce que nous sommes attachés au bon
fonctionnement de notre espace commun et
parce qu'à partir du moment où tel ou
tel variant est dans un des pays de
l'union européenne très vite il se
diffuse dans les autres enfin pour
lutter contre la propagation du variant
et mikron qui pourrait être dominant en
europe d'ici à mi janvier l'exécutif ne
devrait pas aller plus loin que de
simples recommandations pour les
regroupements familiaux comme un appel à
se faire tester et vacciner massivement
aux états unis joe biden met en garde
les non-vaccinés leur premier en hiver
de maladies graves et de morts le
président américain estime que la rapide
circulation du variant omikron rend la
vaccination nécessaire valérie pécresse
déplore le manque de sincérité des
manuels macron lors de son intervention
mercredi soir sur tf1 la candidate de la
droite était l'invité hier soir du 20h
de france 2 en écoute
j'attendais de cette émission de la
sincérité et puis des solutions pour la
france et je n'ai rien eu de tout cela
voilà ni l'un ni l'autre quand on va
deux heures à la télévision à quatre
mois d'une élection présidentielle et
qu'on dit trois fois je ne suis pas
candidat on n'est pas sincère l'a pas
dit je ne suis pas candidat si la lgv a
dit comme ça c'est ce que ça si c'était
la question il a été posé quatre fois
elle a 4 x 4 fois il n'a pas répondu
donc il y avait un manque de sincérité
moi ce que j'ai vu aujourd'hui
j'avais envie c'était le site de
l'émission qu'on me dise où aller la
france est en fait j'ai entendu parler
que des manuels matheron eric zemmour on
veut restaurer l'esprit de la vème
république pas un usage important du
référendum dans un entretien ce matin au
parisien aujourd'hui en france il dit
également ne pas en vouloir aux
musulmans et se battre contre
l'islamisation de notre pays il veut
interdire le voile partout et veut des
mosquées discrète dit il comme le sont
les synagogues les temples protestants
deux hommes mis en examen pour violences
volontaires après l'agression de
militants antiracistes justement lors du
meeting d'eric zemmour in ya dix jours à
villepinte les deux hommes sont membres
du groupuscule d'ultra droite zouaves
paris dont gérald darmanin a engagé la
procédure de dissolution
la compagne de cédric jubilaire est
sorti libre de sa garde à vue elle n'a
pas été mise en examen était entendu
pour recel de cadavres un nom après la
disparition de delphine jus millar le
gouvernement renforce les mesures pour
lutter contre les violences dans les
stades et renforcer la sécurité alors
que les incidents se multiplient en
ligue 1 depuis le début de la saison
gaspard femmes
il y à un mois dès les premières minutes
du match lyon marseille le joueur
dimitri payet est touché par une
bouteille d'eau plein alors qu'il
s'apprêtait à tirer un corner face à ces
incidents à répétition dans les stades
de ligue 1 le gouvernement sort son
carton rouge hier le ministre de
l'intérieur et la ministre des sports
ont réuni les dirigeants du football
français pour annoncer différentes
mesures tout match sera définitivement
arrêtée en cas d'arbitrage au joueur
touché par un projectile
si un incident se produit le sort du
match devra désormais être décidée dans
un délai maximum de trente minutes le
gouvernement envisage également de
mettre en place une amende anti
fumigènes dont le montant et le champ
d'action ne sont pas encore définis et
le règlement disciplinaire sera aussi
réformé pour le principal syndicat des
footballeurs professionnels lui nfp les
mesures sont adaptées et sont une
réponse forte à une situation alarmante
et puis bonne nouvelle si vous prenez le
train pour ce premier week-end de
vacances la cgt cheminots et sud rail
ont levé leurs appels à l'aide pour les
tgv de l' axe sud est avec un petit
bémol toutefois pour cette journée de
vendredi la levée de la grève et trop
tardive il y aura donc des perturbations
seulement la moitié des trains
circuleront et puis autre autre bonne
nouvelle pour les défenseurs des langues
régionales cette fois le picard peut
désormais être enseignée à l'école comme
c'est déjà le cas pour le basque le
breton ou le corse la circulaire a été
publiée hier par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale
c'est donc rémy chardon qui nous
accompagne durant sa devenir bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nos sénateurs
socialistes de la somme on va parler
avec vous dans quelques instants de la
question des éoliennes mais d'abord dans
l'actualité un mot de la dernière info
qu'on vient d'entendre puisque vous êtes
picard le picard qui est donc ça y est
enseigné qui peut être enseignée dans
les écoles publiques on imagine que
c'est une nouvelle pour vous à une
excellente nouvelle et puis j'avais
soutenu la démarche est mon prédécesseur
christian manable avait eu de vrais
depuis des années sur le sujet donc
fiers que ça arrive maintenant et puis
je suis impatient d'aller faire un tour
dans ces écoles justement on imagine
pour renforcer mon picard
qualité c'est évidemment encore et
toujours la crise annie terriens conseil
de défense qui se tient cet après midi
est ce que pour vous il faut de
nouvelles mesures de restriction alors
qu'on entame les vacances scolaires
qu'on est à lapproche défaite mais que
le variant omikron inquiète moi j'ai
surtout l'impression que le gouvernement
il semble faire et on est en réalité il
fait semblant c'est à dire qui on est
toujours dans la réaction et non dans le
l'anticipation on réagit toujours à la
dernière minute les vacances arrivent à
grands pas c'est ce soir pour certains
donc voila voila j'ai l'impression que
le gouvernement réagit toujours à la
dernière minute et c'est bien dommage
puisque il ya quand même des vies qui
sont derrière il ya des gens qui peuvent
eux se faire contaminer est en réalité
si on parle on va un peu plus loin dans
le raisonnement ce qui a été fait sur la
loi c'est dur c'est pareil c'est la
réaction après plusieurs manifestations
après plusieurs demandes du personnel
soignant donc c'est on a l'impression
que en fait mais emmanuel macron ne
gouverne pas il réagit aux difficultés
segalot légalement 4 sur la vaccination
obligatoire on sait que vous les
socialistes ça fait des mois que vous
appelez la vaccination obligatoire le
chef de l'état est là où vers la porte
mercredi soir lors de son intervention
est ce que là aussi pour vous ça arrive
trop tard bah oui en q2 temps perdu j'ai
envie de vous dire parce que aujourd'hui
puisqu'il est en train de faire c'est de
vouloir accélérer la vaccination mais en
réalité il faut que cette mesure soit
universelle pour que tout le monde soit
sensibilisée et qui est pas de deux
personnes qui soient plus touchés que
d'autres en réalité ce qu'on ressent
nous sur le terrain c'est que il ya
encore un travail de sensibilisation
même si pour aller dans le sens des
manuels mâcon quand même c'est qu'il ya
une forte demande sur les demandes de
rendez vous ouais universelle jusqu'au
est-ce qu'il faut rendre la vaccination
obligatoire pour les enfants pour les 5
11 par exemple alors en réalité
aujourd'hui non puisque n'allait pas
obligatoire pour les adultes mais en
mots ce que je ressens c'est que
pour les adultes il faut aussi qu'elle
soit pour les enfants les enfants c'est
particulier il faut rester sur la base
du volontariat bajeux ça se discute je
pense que ça se discute avec des
scientifiques vous avez motion ou un
bleu sénateur je suis pas spécialisé
dans les questions santé et je ne suis
pas médecin donc je me permettrai pas de
faire de commentaires sur le sujet mais
elle est on va parler d'un sujet que
vous connaissez bien c'est la question
des éoliennes puisque c'est un sujet qui
concerne de près notre département le
premier département éolien de france et
c'est chez vous que notre journaliste
jérôme rabier a choisi de tourner son
reportage éoliennes vents contraires
pour les mères il sera diffusé demain
soir à 19h sur notre antenne et je veux
me rabier vient de rejoindre pour en
parler
bonjour jérôme bonjour organe géré merci
d'être avec nous c'est vous qui avez
réalisé ce reportage un alien vents
contraires pour les mères et jérôme ce
développement de l'éolien dans la somme
on va commencer par là il n'est pas sans
susciter de la contestation oui les
contestations politiques d'abord on a
beaucoup entendu le président de la
région haute france xavier bertrand qui
a pris la tête un des partisans d'un
moratoire au moins dans cette région et
le conseil départemental de la somme
dirigée par la droite a également voté
cette année en faveur d'un moratoire
pour le département côté habitants aussi
il ya un certain ras-le-bol éolien de
plus en plus de projets sont contestés
des dizaines d'associations anti
éoliennes se sont montés pour ce premier
extrait je vous propose de regarder
christophe grisard il est à la tête
d'une association anti éoliennes dans
l'est du département où il a vu pousser
beaucoup d'éoliennes ces dernières
années
les promoteurs quand ils démarchent une
commune quand ils démarchent les
agriculteurs bon évidemment le nerf de
la guerre c'est l'argent ils vont leur
proposer beaucoup d'argent mais surtout
les promoteurs généralement ne mentent
pas mais disent pas toute la vérité
ici il ya huit ans et à ces cinq là qui
ont été acceptés et c'est tout mais
voilà et donc tout le monde était
content les communautés très contente
sauf qu'à présent hormis 8 ici ils ont
leur 1009 là bas ils ont remis six là
bas là il ya un projet de huit encore
ils ont mis neuf lama là juste en
arrière plan il y en a je sais pas
combien et on continue d'en mettre dans
st dans certains endroits il ya une
véritable saturation des villages ou peu
importe la direction dans laquelle on
regarde vous voyez des éoliennes dans le
champ de vision et jérôme lundi votre
documentaire il s'appelle éoliennes
vents contraires pour les mairies
justement quelle est la place des élus
locaux dont l'implantation de ces
éoliennes les maires ils n'ont pas le
pouvoir d'autoriser ou d'interdire un
projet éolien le sénat a tenté un
récemment de donner un pouvoir de v omer
dans le projet de loi climat dans le
projet de loi 3ds mais ni le
gouvernement ni la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale n'en veulent ça
n'a donc pas été retenue en dernière
lecture dans notre documentaire on voit
des mers désarmés face à des promoteurs
éoliens car en matière d'éolien basse et
létal représentant de l'état la
préfecture qui décide et quand il ya un
recours c'est la cour d'appel qui décide
en dernier ressort mais il ya aussi des
endroits où ça se passe bien ou en tout
cas du mieux possible rémy car dont on
vous a accompagnés dans le nord-est du
département la communauté de communes de
la haute somme aux ministres des années
2000 quand les promoteurs sont arrivés
ont promis monts et merveilles au mr
malabar ils sont organisés ils ont posé
leurs conditions ils ont procédé à des
appels d'offres pour éviter la
saturation regarder
on a voulu que que celui qui allait
travailler sur le secteur
soit un acteur économique aussi du
terrain je fasse travailler des
entreprises locales
qui fasse vivre aussi nos associations
si un projet quelque part on a discuté
et on faisait avant sept projets
ensemble
donc à la fin c'était beaucoup plus
facile tandis que maintenant c'est
l'individualisme un peu qui revient aux
maires des communes
donc elle veut développer un parcours
le voisin il va peut-être pas être très
content voilà s'il va pas consulté son
voisin c'est un peu ça le problème ce
qu'évoque jean marie blondel c'est la
fin des aides d eux les zones de
développement éolien qui existait
jusqu'en 2013 elles ont été supprimés
depuis il ya plus de cartographie de là
où on peut implanter des éoliennes ou
non même si le gouvernement a récemment
relancé cette question de la
cartographier a demandé aux préfectures
de travailler sur le sujet les maires
ils sont véritablement pris en tenaille
entre d'un côté des habitants de plus en
plus réticents et d'autre part à la
manne financière que l'éolien peut
représenter pour les collectivités car
oui implanter des éoliennes sur son
territoire ça rapporte et plutôt
beaucoup pour une éolienne c'est environ
20000 euros par an de retombées fiscales
réparti entre les différents niveaux de
collectivités locales et cet argent mais
il est réinvesti pour des projets locaux
à destination des habitants au moment où
les finances des collectivités locales
elles sont plutôt limitées way justement
les miens cardon c'est un vrai dilemme
pour les mères cette question de les
éoliennes oui alors ce qui ce qu'on
oublie de parler quand même parce que de
résumer le débat pour ou contre les
éoliennes c'est un peu le danger c'est
ce que bertrand avait lancé lors des
régionales moi je pense qu'il faut avoir
une vision d'ensemble c'est à dire que
comment on construit un mix énergétique
français c'est aussi en tout cas de
l'éolien doit prendre sa part on se
donne dans cette diversification et il
ya eu la question de la souveraineté
énergétique de notre pays et la question
de la décarbonation de notre énergie
donc oui l'éolien est effectivement est
peut-être en atouts et parfois il est
controversé parce que ça a été fait je
dirais pas très proprement vis-à-vis des
habitants et les élus donc l'enjeu c'est
le mix énergétique français est donc
dans ce mix énergétique français il ya
de l'éolien qu'il faut propulsé dans la
somme on est des très bons élèves parce
qu'on a un huitième du parc national on
a mille cent éoliennes il me semble ce
qui veut dire que on a pris notre part
dans ces lycées notre hôte selon vous
est-ce que 3 est ce qu'un a trop dans la
somme et pas assez ailleurs est-ce qu'il
faut bien
c'est d'ailleurs après trop dans la pas
trop dans la salle paul bailly 6 en
certains endroits il ya des zones enfin
montagne fayel ca pacité sa part été
cités c'est plutôt sur le le sud-ouest
de la somme est quand même 130 5
éoliennes sur un rayon de 6 km la vrille
et quand même un manque de respect pour
celles et ceux qui habitent donc mais
les promoteurs ils vont démarcher les
mairies et finalement la l'heure
actuelle basse et les promoteurs ils
peuvent s'installer où ils veulent avec
ou sans l'accord des maires et du coup
bas l'harmonisation elle n'existe pas
encore sur le territoire oui c'est ce
que je veux dans les nombreuses
discussions parce que ça fait plusieurs
mois que je travaille depuis les
régionales sur le sujet c'est qu'il
manque un une cartographie clair alors
ça commence à se faire avec les services
de l'état et la région mais un document
sur lequel on a les zones concentré dès
les zones un peu moins concentré en
éolien mais aujourd'hui ce que je
ressens c'est le l'envi de de construire
ce ministère des tic encore une fois
maintenant les la question financière
vous en avez parlé c'est quand même un
vrai levier économique pour une commune
aujourd'hui qu'est le levier pour une
commune aujourd'hui il n'y a pas des
leviers dynamique aujourd'hui on n'a
plus la taxe d'habitation pour ça donc
tu les médias que les maires ils vont
devoir ils vont se retrouve être obligé
quelques
septennat qui se posent la question sur
lequel je vais pouvoir faire des projets
avec ça et sans sage j'ai moins de marge
de manoeuvre donc faut aussi les
comprendre en réalité mais encore une
fois ça doit pas être le seul objectif
l'objectif de l'implantation d'une
éolienne s'est renforcé notre mix
énergétique et ses des retombées
financières intéressantes certes mais
c'est pas que ça ait le droit de veto
qui avait été votée ici au sénat est ce
qu'il aurait complètement freiner le
développement éolien dans certains
territoires comme la somme alors bas si
la preuve est oui effectivement il y
aurait eu des genoux ça pousserait pas
aussi facilement que ces dernières
années dans ce que dit monsieur bombe
blonde elle sait que derrière il ya les
questions un peu chaque commune de son
éolienne donc et je pense que ça aurait
politisé encore plus le débat sur un
droit de veto c'est pour ou contre c'est
pareil c'est une espèce de référendum
donc ce n'est pas une bonne chose
jérôme le rappelle dans son sillage a
dit que le droit de veto n'a ainsi pas
la concertation à la raison pour vous je
te fais faut plus miser sur la
concertation il faut miser sur une
génération et il ya des promoteurs qui
travaille énormément sur dans les
bouchons un travail dans les écoles ils
font un travail auprès des habitants ils
font des réunions publiques qui font
voilà toute une une explication sur du
long terme parce que c'est des projets
qui durent longtemps sa valeur moyenne
ces six ans je crois donc vous voyez que
qu'on s'est construit avec les habitants
avec les élus normalement ça fonctionne
bien et vous avez vous avez passé un
exemple et j'ai remis un autre exemple
vous évoquez dans votre reportage les
éoliennes un autre modèle l'éolien
municipal oui et ça la plupart du temps
ce sont des promoteurs privés 1 qui
développe les projets mais il ya aussi
une commune en france montdidier elle
est dans la somme vous la connaissez
bien rémy chardon qui a fait le choix il
ya plus de dix ans d'installer des
éoliennes sur son territoire je vous
propose de regarder cet extrait avec la
mère catherine quignon vous êtes à
montdidier vous êtes au pied d'une
éolienne vous en avez quatre au total on
est sur le moulin à cheval donc 80 yens
public les seuls public de france dans
une commune de 6500 habitants le vent
vous voyez bien ici vient à vau l'eau et
nous permet vraiment d'alimenter de
couvrir 50 % de nos besoins
commune de 6500 habitants comme la nôtre
il faut pour couvrir les besoins des
industries des commerces de l'hôpital et
des habitants entre 4 et 5 mégawatts
donc dès qu'on en injecte plus que cela
c'est renvoyé sur les autres communes
avoisinantes et ce qui est renvoyé sur
le réseau national va forcément ça
rapporte de l'argent à la commune qui
investit dans la transition énergétique
beaucoup de choses qui sont faites à
montdidier un panneau solaire chaudière
bois pour l'hôpital réseau de chaleur
municipal il ya eu six de l'argent qui a
reversé directement aux habitants là
pour noël chaque foyer fiscal peut
recevoir 50 euros de bons d'achat
dépensé dans les commerces locaux de
montdidier ça permet de faire vivre
aussi l'économie locale oui c'est un
gérant me le rappeler c'est la seule
commune en france monde iv à avoir de
léognan municipal comment vous expliquez
que ce modèle reste cantonné à
montdidier et qu'il ne se répande pas
plus bas c'est bien dommage alors c'est
catherine qui n'ont que je connais très
bien qui est socialiste avec qui on a
mené de nombreux combats je pense
qu'effectivement ça ça donne un exemple
aujourd'hui pour construire le mix
énergétique je pense que dans ce cas
j'espère que tu enlèves présidentielle
on aura un débat sur le mix énergétique
français parce que au vu de
vieillissement de nos parts que non pas
que éolien mais aussi nucléaire il ya un
enjeu majeur et je pense qu'on peut
relancer parce que c'est le bon format
entre les communes de 5000 et 20 mille
habitants on peut relancer notre mix
énergétique est l'exemple de montdidier
et le bon après c'est vrai que c'est un
investissement conséquent mais ça paye
ça paye pour les habitants et ça paye
pour le territoire
évidemment évoqués dans le reportage de
jérôme sur les inquiétudes autour de la
protection des sites de la protection du
patrimoine avec l'implantation de ces
éoliennes vous les entendez c'est un
calcul oui bah je pour le coup j'ai fait
le tour aussi de certains endroits dans
la somme où il ya des tensions j'ai
rencontré des associations anti éoliens
mais ce que je ressens il ya aussi un
vrai sujet sur la nuisance sonore je
pense que pour le coup l'état ne met pas
les moyens avec la dréal pour
analyser de près parce qu'aujourd'hui et
qu'une version qui gère ça dans toute la
région se faire sauf erreur de ma part
donc ce qui veut dire que c'est rarement
fait et là dessus je pense qu'il ya
voilà il ya quelque chose à faire sur
les nuisances sonores parce que sur
certains endroits ça peut poser des
problèmes et puis aussi sur le balisage
lumineux ou en tout cas moi j'essaie de
réfléchir aussi pour légiférer sur le
sujet parce que je pense qu'il faut
lumière verte qui va vers le haut et pas
de meilleur latéral parce que parfois ça
fait en vraiment une gueule à nous y
voilà des éoliennes dans le territoire
de la somme tout à fait et le reportage
de jérôme votre reportage jérôme
éoliennes vents contraires pour les
moeurs et donc à regarder demain sur
notre antenne demain 19h sur l'antenne
de public sénat évidemment vous êtes
dedans rémy chardon merci sur le coup
elle est on va voir l'actualité dans nos
régions grâce à nos partenaires de la
presse quotidienne régionale on va là
clermont ferrand retrouver julien bonne
foi bonjour julien rédacteur en chef
adjoint au journal la montagne et julien
avec vous on va revenir sur ce drame qui
avait frappé le puy de dôme il ya un an
trois gendarmes qui avaient été abattus
par un forcené
tout à fait simple et cyril rémy et
arnaud il avait 21 37 et 45 ans il était
gendarme robert dans le puy de dome ils
ont été abattus par un forcené il ya un
an
jour pour jour quasiment la rédaction de
la montagne a publié une série
d'articles cette semaine sur ce drame
terrible qui a marqué toute la région et
le dernière épisode aujourd'hui est un
immense cri de colère celui des familles
oriane ces familles des défunts qui
voulait une reconstitution que la
justice a refusé car elle a classé la
sphère après le suicide de l'auteur
c'est du droit mais cela peut paraître
froid est difficile à comprendre écoutez
ce matin ce sont les parents de rémi
dupuis qui nous parle on a perdu un fils
vous imaginez déjà ce que cela
représente mais dans ces circonstances
cet atroce c'est abominable et le temps
ne fait rien ils ne dorment plus ses
parents depuis un an il y à un poison
qui nous ronge ce sont les doutes on est
confronté à la grande muette plus le
temps passe et plus le doute s'insinue
on a l'impression qu'on nous cache des
choses c'est la colère c'est
l'incompréhension la veuve du lieutenant
cyril morale résument d'un côté on nous
dit que ce sont des héros mais on n'a
aucune explication alors ce fait divers
a également eu une conséquence une
réforme des 395 peloton de surveillance
et d'intervention de la gendarmerie en
france les fameux psig ils vont être
doté désormais par phases de fusils
d'assaut de casque avec des vizirs
balistiques et de jumelles à vision
nocturne et surtout ils n'intégreront
plus jeune gendarme adjoint volontaire
c'était le cas d'arnaud mavel qui avait
21 ans et qui a été tué dans la nuit du
22 au 23 décembre il ya un an rennie
cardon est ce que c'est une bonne
réponse politique après ce drame a déjà
la meilleure réponse politique c'est
d'être avec les familles qui ont subi
ces actes douloureux puisqu'il ya la
disparition de leurs proches derrière
après je pense que le problème est bien
profond puisqu'on là on s'attaque quand
même à des gardiens de la paix ont sans
saccades et des gens qui s'engagent pour
défendre la fin la france et puis
essayer d'organiser au mieux la vie le
vivre ensemble et pour le coup c'est je
pense que c'est vraiment dommageable et
dramatique que y ait des faits divers de
ce genre et la réponse n est pas
forcément malheureusement je pense qu'il
faut une réponse plus globale il faut
renforcer les moyens certes dans pour
nos policiers et nos gendarmes mais en
l'occurrence jeu il ya une vraie
réflexion dans la
comment on en arrive là comment comment
on fait pour anticiper et pas subir mais
est ce que je veux dire c'est et ça pour
le coup il ya les moyens il ya la
pédagogie et il ya aussi peut-être des
choses à revoir la police de proximité
pète un complément pour assurer et
repérer s'il ya des des personnes qui
pourraient mettre un trouble à l'ordre
public et julien on va parler avec vous
du sujet qui fait la une de la montagne
ce matin c'est la promesse du 30 mai
oui la une dans le dans le cantal la
montagne vous emmène dans le train de
vie ce matin enfin on l'espère oriane je
vous explique au mois d'octobre dernier
le premier ministre jean castex a
annoncé devant tous les maires du
département qu'un train de nuit ferait
son retour entre paris aurillac avant la
fin de son passage à matignon mais ce
retour du train de nuit et à aurillac ne
figure pas dans la carte de france 4,8
et cette semaine le ministre délégué aux
transports jean baptiste djebbari alors
notre rédaction a contacté le ministère
cette semaine qui n'a pas encore répondu
et les élus de terrain s'inquiètent il
reste donc quatre mois pour tenir la
promesse du premier ministre et en
attendant que la puissance publique
accorde ses violons nos journalistes
sont allés à rodez qui a toujours
conservé sa ligne nocturne avec paris
rémi caron pour dire franchement ne
souffrons dans nos territoires de lignes
de chemin de fer obsolète c'est un sujet
d'engagement de la montagne et du groupe
centre france nous avons des drames de
train qui date d'un autre âge il n'y a
pas de wi fi des retards récurrents
quand va-t-on prendre en compte cette
france de la diagonale du vide en
matière de transport oublié par tous les
gouvernements depuis à peu près 40 ans
j'adore votre question je suis un usager
du train la ligne amiens paris voyez ce
que je veux dire cette fine qui est
aussi en grande difficulté ou iliad
énormément il ya énormément
d'investissement à mettre en oeuvre pour
la montagne jeu c'est vrai que c'est
dommageable si je disais tout à l'heure
c'est le gouvernement qui semble le
faire mais en réalité fait semblant d
impression puisque la carte elle a été
oubliée par le ministre des transports
encore une fois je pense que là dessus
j'espère encore une fois que on va
travailler sujet parce que c'est sur les
petits nids de ferroviaire est une fille
revient tout court ou les houles et le
train à grande vitesse ou les le tas les
trains de nuit je pense sincèrement
qu'il me faudrait investir on peut pas
dire aux gens le il faut limiter les gaz
à effet de serre et en même temps
ne pas investir dans le ferroviaire mois
le ferroviaire à l'avenir pour moi est
d'ailleurs dans mon département j'ai
toujours dit que on était en sueur les
petites lignes ferroviaires c'est bien
dommage que on est on est pas assez
renforcer ces petites mines et là pour
le coup pour la montagne c'est pareil ça
peut renforcer une attractivité locales
et économique et c'est bien dommage
c'est vraiment bien dommage j'espère que
il y aura des investissements et
j'espère que la carte va être rectifié
par le ministre des transports a dit
dimanche qu'il allait investir qu'il
fallait investir justement sur cette
ligne ferroviaire qui ont été trop
longtemps délaissé saba dans mon sens le
gouvernement prend mal de ces pour vos
paris on réagit toujours un peu
tardivement alors c'est vrai que sur un
quinquennat de cinq ans c'est difficile
de juger le gouvernement sur le sujet on
va pas non plus leur mais encore une
fois je pense sincèrement que depuis
cinq ans il rien n'a été fait en fait en
réalité on est à la fin du quinquennat
et on réagit à la dernière minute alors
que sincèrement c'est un enjeu majeur
pour un territoire moi je le ressens
pour un bien amiens on est situé entre
lille et paris est en réalité on
bénéficie pas de cette localisation
intéressante et pour la montagne c'est
pareil
d'ailleurs la montagne s'engage
évidemment beaucoup sur ce sujet et
c'était important d'en parler ce matin
avec vous julien bonne foi on revoit la
une de la montagne dans son édition des
campagnes la promesse du train de nuit
c'était là une merci beaucoup nul bien
bonne foi et bonne fête à l'année
prochaine à l'échelon du bruit sur la
bonne fête merci on va terminer
évidemment parlant de la présidentielle
rémy chardon et en battant la fumée
blanche de christiane taubira qui
devrait s'exprimer d'ici la fin de la
matinée est ce que vous le souhaitez
qu'elle soit candidate à la
présidentielle je souhaite qu'elle
participe à la primaire de la gauche
parce que elle a une voix à porter et
j'espère que l'on pourra en occuper
l'espace médiatique sur nos thématiques
sur le mois de janvier j'espère que
cette primaire aura aura lieu et et elle
peut contribuer à mettre aussi un
dernier coup de pression à monsieur
jadot et monsieur roussel bien monsieur
mélenchon et pour vous c'est christiane
taubira rentrer dans le match ça peut
changer les choses parce que pour le
moment vous l'avez entendu c'est fin de
non recevoir de la part de fabien
roussel jean luc mélenchon yannick jadot
oui il peut changer les choses je pense
que ça peut leur faire comprendre que
attention on risque de voir pas avoir de
ne pas avoir une petite primaire nous
primaire avec christiane taubira arnaud
montebourg anne hidalgo et puis
peut-être pierre larrouturou guillaume
lacroix pour le prg et c'était donc non
c'est pas une petite prière qui peut
arriver pour la gauche sans que ça veut
dire que c'est anne hidalgo crescent
auber arnaud montebourg peu importe
qu'il n'y ait pas fabien roussel jean
luc mélenchon et yannick jadot cette
primaire aura de la valeur s'offre à
elles leur âge j'espère j'espère que
malheureusement je peux pas dire
moi-même le swiss et qu'elle
a les communistes on
ne peut pas ouvrir les portes et les
fenêtres et puis j'ai cherché par la
main s'ils veulent pas venir s'il veut
pas construire quelque chose avec nous
c'est bien dommage parce que c'est quand
on regarde et tous les sondages
généralement c'est au plus de 70% des
électeurs de gauche qui attendent cette
primaire qui attendent qu'on qu'on parle
de nos thématiques et là pour le coup
c'est or c'est le rouge monsieur roussel
monsieur jadot et monsieur mélenchon
disent non à ces 70 % d'électeurs de
gauche voilà je je je peux paraître un
peu dur sur le sur ses propos mais
encore encore une fois je pense que
l'heure est grave on a un eric ciotti
qui finit quand même qu'il la ligne
majoritaire au premier tour puisqu'elle
arrive en tête aux premières de la
droite on a le l'extrême droite qui
autour de 35% et pendant ce temps là la
gauche on est à sept candidats à se
regarder le nombril enfin c'est ça pas
de sens est-ce que c'est pas trop tard
c'est un peu l'argument de jean luc
mélenchon sait on est à quatre mois de
la présidentielle c'est trop tard pour
faire une primaire les autres candidats
sont déjà dans la course et nous on veut
organiser notre primaire à ce qu'ils
n'ont pas raison c'est pas trop tard
puisque justement ne les différents
candidats ont déjà commencé leur
campagne donc de passer par la case
primaire enfin jean fin janvier moi je
ne vois pas au contraire ça on va
occuper le paysage médiatique sur le
janvier on va sensibiliser les électeurs
de gauche et ils vont être rassurés 20
entre eux quand on sort d'une primaire
généralement il ya une dynamique qui
peut se créer et quand on arrive à 16 ou
17 % à la fin du mois de janvier et
qu'on est dans les challengers pour le
second tour balle par rapport à une
situation on est à 4 8% enfin c'est la
tranche pour 2,2 hidalgo à mélenchon ou
peu importe ces voix là je pense que
l'amérique avait des différentes non
merci merci beaucoup rémy chardon d'être
venu nous voir ce matin et vous allez
maintenant laissez votre place à notre
prochaine invitée c'est jean-louis
devrait qui va nous rejoindre sur son
plateau merci beaucoup
un petit regret
[Musique]
est notre invité politique ce matin
c'est jean louis debré bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos ancien ministre
ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par fabrice
veysseyre au nom du groupe ebra les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
bonjour fabrice aurieng bonjour jean
louis debré bonjour les gens lui devrait
je vous ai présenté comme ancien
ministre et ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel on connaît bien sûr
l'homme politique que vous êtes mais
aujourd'hui nous recevons aussi sur ce
plateau le comédien jean louis debré
vous êtes sur les planches avec une
pièce ces femmes qui ont réveillé la
france avant de parler de la pièce
pourquoi ce choix d'être sur les
planches
parce que
j'ai envie de le faire partager de
transmettre de manière parfois
humoristique notre histoire l'histoire
de la république et que dans cette pièce
le jouer avec valérie bochenek et avec
une pianiste
bien on parle de qui on parle de ce
combat de ces femmes qui avaient compris
la république et la république s'est
naturellement marianne mais c'est
liberté égalité fraternité
il n'y a pas de liberté sans égalité et
il n'y a pas de fraterniser sans égalité
que ça soit la première bachelière la
première médecin la première avocate
tout avait ce combat en tête et
ça me plaît de communiqué hier soir il y
avait une classe entière qui est venu et
après quoi je parlais avec les jeunes
apprenons notre histoire de la
république c'est une autre façon de
faire de la politique jean louis debré
pardon c'est une autre façon de faire de
la politique pour vous pour moi c'est la
politique je la regarde avec 10 ans et
avec détachement je m'y intéresse mais
parfois je ne comprends plus totalement
les équations de la politique on va y
venir mais comment vous avez choisi ces
femmes
deux façons d'avoir des grandes voix
comme jean je sens comme colette
[Musique]
comme simone veil les voix qui ont donné
des directions et puis des pionnières
l'histoire est écrite par des hommes qui
connaît la première ma chaudière qui
s'est battu battu pour avoir le droit de
passer le baccalauréat première médecin
première mais ça
quand
on regarde pas ce que tu ça s'éteint à
lui que j'avais écrit avec des mots les
rimes riches nec et on les allées aux
archives quand vous avez
le journal les messins qui dit beaupré
pour faire une carrière médicale une
fois qu'une femme passe une carie
médicale il faut qu'elle perde sa
qualité de femme parce que de par
l'aspect psychologique la femme médecin
est un être
un monstre ça veut dire que la place
qu'elle mérite dans l'histoire
aujourd'hui je pense que trop souvent
on ne raconte que l'histoire des hommes
la république celle que nous partageons
que nous aimons que j'aime elle a été le
fruit d'hommes et de femmes
qui ont encore une fois ont voulu que
les règles de l'égalité s'applique quand
je parle
de la première femme musulmans et
musulmanes non d'un gouvernement de la
république qui se souvient et qui se
souvient de ce que alors elle a dit
c'était en 1959 sa pleine la fisa si de
kara et elle a été élevée par les
instituteurs de la république et elle
dit à quoi à ses frères et soeurs
algérienne à l'époque et bien
enlever le voile c'est le signe de la
liberté
ça ne veut pas dire que vous renoncez à
votre religion mais soyez égales aux
hommes alors il ya une femme qui
aimerait bien rentrer dans l'histoire
première présidente de la république
c'est vrai vous connaissez bien est-ce
que d'abord elle a eu raison de
commencer son premier discours à peine
son élection annoncée par le fait
qu'elle était une femme et que sa
famille politique avait choisi une femme
pour la première fois vous voulez
absolument me faire revenir et thierry
vous savez
moi qui essayent de m'échapper de la
politique
vient
d'abord un je m'en garderais bien de
faire le moindre pronostic pour
l'instant j'ai vous avez rappelé que
j'ai fait la politique je me souviens
que en février 1995
personne n'aurait parié sur la victoire
de jacques chirac je me souviens que
giscard d'estaing quatre mois avant le
renouvellement de son mandat personne
n'imaginait qu'il pourrait être battu
par françois mitterrand nicolas sarkozy
samoa avant la fin son mandat personne
imaginez qu'ils ne puissent pas faire un
deuxième mandat pour vous tout est
possible dans cette élection je pense
que tout est possible et le fait que ce
soit une femme qui
je connais les journalistes politiques
très bien et si je viens pas la question
on pose la question
moi qui voulais parler du théâtre et de
ces femmes qui rit la france mais vous
voulez dire que pécresse va réveiller la
france c'est ça
je pense que
il ya quelque chose ces appareils est
très intéressant aujourd'hui
c'est il ya très peu de périodes dans
notre histoire politique ou la société
politique n'a pas construit de
personnages évident on ne pouvait
contester mitterrand mais il a dominé la
gauche on pouvait compter c'est giscard
mais là dominé à droite on pouvait
compter c'est chirac mais il a dominé y
avait pas besoin de faire de primaire il
s'imposait
or aujourd'hui plus personne ne s'impose
et
c'est révélateur de
ces simulateurs de
notre bouche au jeu l'expliquent dans
dans ce livre sur l'humour
aujourd'hui le site à la politique est
devenue un véritable métier du spectacle
lors que l'on ne cherche pas à créer une
espérance a créé avant un discours pour
cette petite phrase pourrait être due
pour que vous repreniez ces petites
phrases et donc on a asséché le discours
politique et
deuxièmement se trouve pardon parce que
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur pour seul il
quand elle peut guérir sur les archives
le niveau de culture d un politique
quand vous aviez un débat entre jaurès
et clemenceau quel futur quand vous
aviez des discours de jaurès mais disco
de clemenceau d'arrêt si brillant vous
êtes impressionné quand vous regardez et
vous lisez aujourd'hui lé discours
c'est ce et technocratique c'est à dire
que jadis
les parlementaires n'étaient pas entouré
de collaborateurs il improvisait il
avait des convictions il avait une
volonté aujourd'hui on ne trouve plus
cela mais c'est spécifique aux
politiques ou c'est le syndrome d'un
affaiblissement de l'école aujourd'hui
en france normalement je suis pas
compétent je constate simplement
une uniformisation des dix courses je
prends j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur les
professions de foi il y a trente ans la
profession de foi du députés ou des
sénateurs était très intéressante c'est
lui qui l'a rédigé et donc on voyait la
personnalité de du candidat aujourd'hui
c'est une partie qui on voit les
professions de foi tout fait et on
prenait du lot-et-garonne à l'heure en
passant par l'allié et la somme s'ils
sont les mêmes il rajoute leur nom en
bas
s'il ya il n'y a plus cet enrichissement
de la diversité et donc
je regarde ça avec intérêt ce que je
constate c'est que
le chemin parcouru par valérie pécresse
a été un chemin qui a donné de l'espoir
à la droite après je critique pas le
résultat est là pour une fois est arrivé
alors que à gauche et à droite tu ça
c'était l'émission a rassemblé et a
redonné l'espoir est ce qu'elle peut
compter sur vous pas quoi est ce qu'elle
peut compter sur vous mais moi je ne
suis qu'un citoyen de loire non je ne
suis qu'un citoyen je voterai
je connais bien aux questions fait je
sais pas je pense que laissons nos
citoyens nos concitoyens libre pas
besoin de deux je ne suis plus rien je
ne représente rien je joue au théâtre
j'ai une autre carrière je ferai
peut-être du cinéma dans lequel compte
quelque j'écris j'écris des livres
mais voilà je veux sortir j'ai toute ma
vie j'avais
qu'une angoisse
être un ancien être un ancien magistrat
alors j'ai quitté la magistrature être
un ancien parlementaire
l'ancien parlementaire tu es toujours au
parlement j'avais qu'une obsession c'est
le caissier la politique avant que le me
quittes
je me suis mis à écrire des livres quel
bonheur d'avoir un autre contact tous
les soirs au théâtre
après la pièce eh bien je suis à la
sortie je parle avec les gens ce qu'ils
vous disent les gens il parle alors il
parle de la pièce il dirige et drôle en
scène on a beaucoup ri mais très
rapidement
comme vous parce que l'on peut pas me
regarder mais sans penser immédiatement
à la politique c'est un réflexe
conditionné si j'arrive je croise pas
une politique je préférais coup parler
de bicyclettes de marche à pied de
théâtre mais peu importe est donc très
rapidement pour et il me parle alors ce
qui est ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas de
leur donner mon avis parce que je n'ai
aucun c'est de recueillir leurs
sentiments et
aujourd'hui il ya plusieurs phénomènes
que je ressens une sur nostalgie du
passé
à du temps de 7 sur la sagi
aucune identification
d'affections comme on pouvait le marquer
à l'égard du général de gaulle de
mitterrand de chirac non une résignation
et cette nostalgie vous la partagez avec
vos spectateurs
nostalgie on l'a sur la cible je pense
que
qu'est-ce qui me disent même les gens
qui sont pas
favorables
avec chirac au moins il nous est mais au
moins il nous aimait il était de chez
nous
je reste à ce que je viens de dire que
peintre aux journalistes
simplement il ya ce sentiment
d'ailleurs si liés au développement de
l'antiparlementarisme et de l'abstention
et la classe politique et
ils ont un peu de distance jeu sur 7 sur
nostalgie parce que c'est intéressant de
cette sur nostalgie dont vous nous
parlez est ce que pour vous ça peut
expliquer la montée d'eric zemmour qui
fait lui campagne sur la france d'avant
et sur cette nostalgie du passé ils
veulent je sais pas répond quelle
campagne ip mais moi j'ai un sentiment
moi je parlerais de lui mieux je me
porterai
il faut pas en parler pour vous je ne
représente pas tous présents passe ici
mais
vous savez
la démocratie à la république elle a
besoin de fonctionner avec des partis
républicains une gauche républicaine on
n'est pas content de la gauche le
week-end on va valoir réplique n est
donc la responsabilité c'est que à
gauche et à droite républicaine on est
des hommes ou des femmes qui portent
l'étendard aujourd'hui
à droite non
je pense qu'on pourparlers ont été lus
en créant une espérance mitterrand a été
élu sur les 110 propositions
parce qu' elle étai lisions peu importe
de savoir si les appliquer ou pas
appliquées après mais l'élection il
portait une espérance chirac c'est
l'ascenseur social
or on a le sentiment aujourd'hui que
pour les politiques la politique ce
n'est pas de régler les problèmes c'est
de faire taire ceux qui les posent
vous restez quand même quand on vous
écoute bien vous restez partisans du
bipartisme une droite une gauche et
pourtant quand on revient cinq ans en
arrière il me semble que jean louis
debré avait dit qu'il voterait emmanuel
macron partisans du en même temps oui
mais je vous avais très bonne mémoire
mais
j'ai
une très grande déception et c'est pour
ça que je suis très sceptique
aujourd'hui
jeudi je suis très sceptique mais nous
avons encore quatre mois interrogé mois
dans quatre mois je dirais mais pour
l'instant je me concentre sur le théâtre
sur ces femmes qui ont aimé la france
jette quand même sur sur la politique
alors on a compris que je n'ai pas parlé
je
suis très au cirad juste on va on va les
jeux c'est un jeu un taudis dix fois
ecoutez jean louis debré zone et
il réussit ce qu'ils cherchent c'est que
depuis quelques jours on balance toutes
ces petites phrases mois
m'engager dans une campagne électorale
je m'engage sur une espérance sans
quelqu'un tu as apporté non pas sur des
petites phrases absolument assassine
méchante qui n'ont qu'un sens et qui
sont pour moi inutile et on rabaisse sa
politique moi je souhaite que les gens
me donnent de l'espérance et je suis
prêt à suivre à écouter à comprendre des
gens qui disent voilà la france que l'on
veut construire voilà le contrat social
qui qui doit être le nôtre ces petites
phrases vous réduisez la politique à
un ping pong de petites phrases
pas que mais juste un mot sur ce qu'il a
dit
en 1995
chaque chirac entrait à l'elysée et
pourtant et pourtant toutes ces belles
proclamations de villepin qui restèrent
lettre morte toutes ces belles promesses
furent oubliés la droite
la droite comme d'habitude se soumettait
aux injonctions de la gauche des médias
des juges la droite comme d'habitude
trahissait ses électeurs aussitôt qu'il
l'avait mise sur le pavois valérie
pécresse rappelle sans cesse
valérie pécresse rappelle sans cesse
que son entrée en politique est
intimement lié à la personne de jacques
chirac elle serait faire sans cesse à
lui croyons là sur parole elle agira
comme son mentor elle prend mettra tout
et ne tient à rien
c'est votre axe ce n'est pas vrai ce
n'est pas votre droite mais moi je ne
suis pas à droite je suis vous lis est
votre réaction à ce que je trouve que
c'est
faux
dangereux et en plus pour lui absurde
parce que si il se met à dos tous les
électorats il va finir en dessous de
zéro jean louis debré et les héros qui
attaquent le conseil constitutionnel est
évidemment on voudrait votre réaction en
tant qu'ancien président du conseil
constitionnel à propos de son plan pour
lutter contre l'immigration il dit on ne
peut l'appliquer ctions se débarrasse
des contraintes juridiques de la cndh et
du conseil constitutionnel en 2016 il
disait déjà et régler mon co michel
debré avait conçu le conseil
constitutionnel juste pour surveiller le
parlement et non pour se transformer en
cour suprême plusieurs tués là il m'a
attaqué ma attaqué parce que j'avais
fait la qpc mais bon
je lui accorde à ce qu'il dit
aujourd'hui aucun intérêt car il veut et
y arrive il veut qu'on reprenne ses
propos comme ils nous proposent rien en
réalité de précis aucune espérance et
qui l'aidant dans la haine dans
l'excessif serra seul veut pas dire
qu'ils ne posent pas aussi de vraies
questions notamment sur la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale mais c'est pas en
bon on ne sera pas contre l'immigration
illégale en supprimant tout et envers le
quoi en revenant qu'à période de la
révolution on la laisse tribunaux
populaires on a
un sérieux sur sa renault théâtre
fallait un mot alors sur le tête même si
on en a beaucoup parlé mais juste sur le
tête parce qu'il ya beaucoup de jeunes
qui viennent voir cette pièce qui
viennent vous voir beaucoup d'écoliers
beaucoup de les gens qu'est ce qu'ils
ont vu mais pourquoi parce que
nos jeunes on leur apprend lui 16 14 on
ne leur apprend pas l'histoire de la
république et l'histoire des idées de la
république et cette pièce que je veux
drôle et on a un jeu de ping-pong avec
valérie moche nec c'est pour dire assez
assez jeune il n'y a pas que l'histoire
de la monarchie de l' empire il ya
l'histoire des idées comment aujourd'hui
des hommes et des femmes qui sont pas
des extrémistes
ont pu faire progresser dans notre pays
le sentiment d'égalité mais du coup
pardon je reviens la question tout à la
messe qui a pas une feuille de l'école
là dessus
si oui
je pense qu'on devrait
enseigner
plus d'histoire des idées de la
république de la république pour faire
naître chez nos jeunes le sentiment que
la république leur appartient la
république c'est pas la chose de
quelques hommes politiques c'est la
chose du peuple il faut faire vivre la
république vous avez à titre personnel à
titre politique a company is toute cette
vème république connaissait sur le bout
des doigts
vous évoquez l'abstention tout à l'heure
vous et vous qu'est l'espérance est ce
que cette république n'a pas besoin
d'être relancé le débat de la sixième
république n'est pas revenu dans le land
sujets politiques du moment est ce que
cette république n'est pas en panne je
pense que
il faudrait commencer par revenir sur un
certain nombre de réformes qui ont abîmé
la république thème république et comme
lesquels lesquels je pense que le
quinquennat est une absurdité tout le
monde y a voulu réaliser la mode voulue
par pompidou repris par me serrant dans
ses 110 propositions
ceux tenus par giscard une fois qu'ils
avaient fini 7 ans et après reprenez
repris par jose pas adoptée par chirac
tout le monde au nom de l'idée à la mode
on se rend compte que pour réformer pour
modifier pour conduire un pays il faut
de la durée deuxièmement revenons sur la
concomitance entre l'élection
présidentielle élection des députés la
régime de la vème république est un
régime qui pouvait être si avait
concordance ans et majorité
présidentielle s'ils n'y avaient pas
concordance d'alternance parlementaire
revenons aussi ça je le dis parce que
j'ai vécu ça sur la possibilité pour un
député ou pour un sénateur d'être maire
d'une ville peut-être pas cumulé trop de
fonctions comme président de commune
mais où présente comme une département a
une connexion entre nationale et locale
qu'une ponction
exécutif local vous permet d'avoir être
enraciné d'être à l'écouté quand j'étais
député et maire d'evreux tous les tous
les samedis ou dimanches j'étais sur les
marchés à hébreu je faisais le tour des
commerçants j'écoutais
transhumants revenons à la session
unique
aujourd'hui on s'y laisse tout le temps
c'est absurde
ça pourrait peut-être faire des lois
moins longue car une des
caractéristiques c'est pas beaucoup plus
de lois mais c'est des lois de plus en
plus longues et dans la fabrication des
lois revenons à ce qu'elle était un
principe essentiel de la république
c'est que les affirmations politiques
vont dans l'exposé des motifs et qu'on
fait des lois avec peu de dispositions
mais des dispositions précises donc
revenons un certain nombre de réformes
qui ont dit nature et la vème république
après je pense que on pourrait revoir un
peu le fonctionnement du parlement
notamment dans l'intercession où on peut
imaginer dans l'intercession juste une
séance des questions d'actualité en plus
je pense que un rôle du parlement et de
plus en plus d'être un contrôle
permanent de l'administration or on les
commissions exerce ce contrôle
d'ailleurs quand j'étais présent à
l'assemblée j'ai fait que le président
de la commission ne soit pas la
coloration politique du rapporteur mais
le rendu le rendu de ces commission
denquête elle n'est pas clair de même
lorsqu'on commence le budget il devrait
y avoir un débat officiel bien précis
sur l'exécution du budget précédent pour
qu'on montre bien ni on ferait passer à
tribune ministre par ministre on vous a
voté ce crédit est ce qu'il a été
exécuté vous avez voté cette loi est ce
que les décrets d'application sortie
colle donc il devrait y avoir pendant un
mois
ou qu'un jour avant la discussion
budgétaire une vraie confrontation entre
les députés les sénateurs et l'exécution
du budget précédent vous voyez vous avez
encore beaucoup d'idées pour la france
en lui devrait on était ravi de les
entendre ce matin merci beaucoup et
inaltérable et justement j'invite nos
téléspectateurs à aller au théâtre de la
gaîté montparnasse et jusqu'à fin mars
prolonger jusqu'à fin mars et après mois
de mars nous faisons une tournée en
province où vous voyez ça nouveau métier
ces femmes qui ont réveillé la france et
votre pièce de théâtre et puis votre
livre également quand les politiques
nous faisait rire c'est à lire et
j'invite également nos téléspectateurs à
le dire merci jean louis debré merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin merci fabrice on passe au pied aux
clubs des territoires
la mutuelle nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires
angie acteurs engagés dans la transition
zéro carbone des régions vous présente
le club des territoires
[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale il est
des divisions locales vous présente le
club des territoires avec nous pour ce
dernier club de la
politique et parlementaire on jouera
avec toi général denis fauque bonjour
frédéric avec nous content évidemment
qui est revenu avec nous et pour cette
dernière de l'année on fera le bilan de
la saison nous avons retenu trois temps
forts un politique un parlementaire et
un sur l'actualité des régions on
parlera des travaux du sénat sur les
violences sexuelles on parlera des
régionales et puis on reviendra sur la
primaire de la droite et on fera
également la rétrospective de l'année à
travers nos titres de presse quotidienne
régionale ce sera avec vous quand en
tout à l'heure mais d'abord on va
regarder l'actualité d'aujourd'hui dans
nos régions
et l'actualité du côté de mulhouse on
retrouve laurent bodin bonjour laurent
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en rien
un éditorialiste au journal l'alsace
laurent et l'info du jour pour vous
c'est l'ouverture à la circulation d'un
nouvel axe autoroutier
oui oh rien de ça se fasse à strasbourg
le gc au grand contournement ouest de
strasbourg est désormais ouvert à la
circulation depuis ce matin ce vieux
serpent de mer alsacien objet de tant de
polémiques durant des décennies a pour
but de désengorger le trafic de l'a35
autoroutes gratuites mais ne
d'étranglement car à la saturation en
fait des déplacements dans
l'agglomération strasbourgeoise s'ajoute
le fait que la 35 est l'axé principal du
trafic routier entre les pays bas au
nord et l'italie au sud jusqu'à présent
ce sont 160 mille véhicules qui
circulent en moyenne chaque jour à
strasbourg sur l'a35 alors cette
nouvelle autoroute de 24 km a été
inauguré par le premier ministre jean
castex samedi dernier mais le projet
continue encore de faire polémique les
associations environnementales ont
retardé sa réalisation depuis des
décennies combattants une autoroute qui
traverse effectivement une forêt et
dessine une gigantesque on taille dans
une collines les opposants contournement
ont perdu leur combat mais estime que
ces vingt années de luttes ont fait
avancer la cause environnementale dans
l'agglomération strasbourgeoise est
permis notamment l'élection de plusieurs
maires écologistes à commencer par jeune
bach et lyon à strasbourg c'est par
souci environnemental d'ailleurs que la
vitesse sur l'a 35 l'autoroute gratuites
existantes est désormais réduite à 70 km
heure elle est également interdite aux
poids lourds en transit et l'autre
polémique laurent c'est le tarif de ce
contournement autoroutier payant oui
vinci à un récit 561 millions d'euros
pour construire les 24 km ayant le
montage financier il prévoit grâce aux
péages évidemment de dégâts j'ai un taux
de rentabilité annuelle de 9,72 % pour
élevés auxquels sont habitués les
sociétés d'autoroutes française mais un
taux qui a été vertement critiqués
d'ailleurs par le sénat et par
l'autorité de régulation des transports
l'an dernier la nouvelle autoroute a355
comprend trois sections une au sud
gratuite les deux autres au nord sont
payantes avec des tarifs différents
selon trois plages horaires différents
heures de pointe matin et soir airs
médiane la journée et heures creuses la
nuit comme cela d'ailleurs se pratique
partout au pardon déjà ailleurs en
france en particulier en région
parisienne les tarifs de péage devons
pour une voiture particulière de 1 euro
10 en heures creuses pour un demi trajet
à 5 euros pour traverser complète en
heure de pointe et tous les camions le
tarif maximum est de 16 euros 60 ttc en
fait le coût d'utilisation suscite aussi
la polémique en raison la gratuité des
autoroutes en alsace habituellement car
excepté dans le secteur de saverne au
nord l'alsace peut être traversé jusqu'à
présent du nord au sud la plupart du
temps sur autoroute gratuite c'est
d'ailleurs le cas en allemagne c'est
aussi cette gratuité traditionnel de
l'autoroute qui fait que la collectivité
européenne d'alsace fruit de la fusion
des deux départements alsaciens défend
le principe d'une écotaxe sur les poids
lourds en transit cette écotaxe existe
en allemagne provoqua un report du
trafic routier vers l'alsace toujours
sur ce même axe amsterdam milan en fait
l'écho taxe dont le principe a été
validé par le parlement pour l'alsace
voilà vraiment le prochain enjeu routier
en alsace de ces prochaines années merci
beaucoup laurent bodin on regarde la une
de l'alsace aujourd'hui consacré à la
crise sanitaire le pic n'est pas atteint
dans les hôpitaux à la science et à la
une de votre journal merci beaucoup
laurent beaudoin d'avoir été
vous étes trés belle fête à vous
également les puisque c'est la dernière
de l'année on va revenir sur cette année
sur les temps forts qui ont marqué cette
année on en a choisi trois contents on a
choisi trois on va commencer par le
temps forts parlementaire compte 1 ce
qui s'est passé au sénat et vous avez
choisi de nous parler de ce débat qui a
lieu sur les violences sexuelles c'est
des débats qui font écho bien évidemment
à un débat de société qui est très fort
depuis le mois de janvier exactement on
a vu une concomitance on peut le dire
entre ce qui s'est passé au parlement et
le débat dans la société civile et c'est
assez rare pour être notée mais c'est
bien un texte d'origine sénatoriale et
de la centriste annick billon qui a été
définitivement adoptée le 15 avril
dernier il vise à créer un seuil de non
consentement un interdit clair dans la
société sur les relations sexuelles
entre mineurs et adultes c'est une mixte
est toujours pas dans la loi en fait le
texte avait fait plusieurs allers
retours entre l'assemblée nationale et
le sénat est donc enrichi à chaque fois
au fil de la navette les députés ont
ainsi rajouter une criminalisation de
l'inceste un texte important qui crée
également une prescription glissant
c'est à dire que le délai est rallongé
si l'auteur viol ou agressent par la
suite un autre enfant c'est très
important un texte sur le gouvernement a
fait on peut le dire une volte face au
fur et à mesure de l'examen c'est à dire
que et bien au début il y était pas trop
favorable et puis finalement il s'est
rangé dans le camp des des pros en cours
d'examen car ce texte il a résonné
vraiment fortement avec l'actualité
comme le livre on s'en souvient de
camille kouchner elle se fit ce livre la
familia grande et où elle accuse son
beau-père d'un cesse sur son frère
jumeau adolescents et plus généralement
on l'a vu au parlement lors des
auditions ce thème des violences
sexuelles ça a été marquant au sénat
avec des auditions d'anciennes top model
de l'agencé élite ou encore les travaux
sur les femmes en milieu rural qui sont
doublement pénalisés car rayonner des
structures des douches ou encore le
témoignage de valérie bako qui a raconté
dans un entretien un vrai bouleversant
cette année bien son sa trajectoire de
femmes battues et la façon dont elle a
été vraiment abandonnés par les
institutions que soit la gendarmerie le
maire de sa commune également et donc on
le voit il ya une libération de la
parole on peut le dire et ce thème de la
lutte contre les violences sexuelles qui
a marqué l'année politique et avec une
résonance particulière on le voit donc
au sénat
débat on s'en souvient des débats un peu
compliqué parfois c'est assez difficile
de légiférer sur chattem armand oui
enfin c'est difficile sauf que on voit
bien que ça a été rappelé par qantas et
que la société aujourd'hui le devance
comme c'est souvent le cas sur ces
sujets de société le le politique et je
pense qu un sondeur record me fait dire
i pour nous le confirmer
donc la société est en avance mais ce
qui est intéressant là en l'occurrence
dans la procédure parlementaire c'est
que c'est à l'initiative du sénat et
d'ailleurs ce qui est très surprenant
c'est que cette notion de non
consentement n'est pas existé avant
parce que elle finalement le bon sens
fait que d'une certaine manière on peut
considérer que c'était quelque chose
quelque part une nécessité pour protéger
notamment les plus jeunes en
l'occurrence ce qui est intéressant
aussi c'est que le gouvernement
manifestement s'est ralliée à la
position du sénat au cours de
discussions parlementaires ce qui prouve
que d'une certaine manière le sénat l'a
était quasiment en phase avec la société
face à l'exécutif qui était beaucoup
plus prudent oui c'est le chef de l'état
lui-même qui dans une interview à donner
le go si on peut dire puisque eric
dupond moretti était en séance en train
de dire qu'il attendait de voir comment
la chancellerie pouvait travailler sur
ce thème le chef de l'état prend la
parole et on voit le ministre de la
justice garde des sceaux qui est
quasiment le lendemain j'ai un soutenir
du coup la proposition de loi la société
est en avance sur ces sujets par rapport
à clairement oui à une vraie prise de
conscience sur ces sujets un signe qui
veut montre que c'est une prise de
conscience massive le clivage de genre
le fait que par le passé c'était plus
les femmes qui avaient qui était très
comment dire mobilisés sur ce sujet a
fait place maintenant un mouvement
massif homme femme sans aucune
différence même si un clivage
générationnel ce sont les plus jeunes
qui me mobilise le plus ce terme il ya
aussi l'idée que la justice n'est pas
assez sévère d'une manière générale et
donc dans ce cadre là quand on y est
rare cheese ou lisse qu'une série de
type de violence sur les violences
sexuelles qui sont perçues comme les
plus sévères sur lesquels il ya 700 il
ya ce sentiment d'impunité pour les
violeurs et pour les agresseurs et plus
l'opinion publique il faut le dire on
l'a vu vous citiez la sphère duhamel est
absolument intraitable on vient de
publier une enquête ifop fiducial pour
par image et ce radio lettre mensuelle
des personnalités nicolas hulot sans
juger des différentes affaires perd 30
points perd 30 points là on ne perd pas
30 points d'un mois à l'autre comme cela
le précédent record si je puis dire
c'était la chute de dominique strauss
kahn en juin 2011 on a une opinion qui
est intraitable qui veut qu'on
sanctionne des coupables et surtout la
montée et c'est un phénomène massif qui
ne juge pas connivence sexuelle la
protection des victimes mais parmi les
temps forts de cette année concernant
l'actualité dans nos régions mais on a
choisi de parler des régionales avec les
régionales est né au mois de juin
dernier et on a eu une carte de france
et bien acquis non pas du tout
exactement c'était un peu un fait
politique en soi la prime au sortant a
joué à plein on voit au lendemain du
second tour les mêmes équilibres en
france métropolitaine fin juin 2021 à
droite on voit ainsi les barons
régionaux conforter xavier bertrand dans
les hautes france valérie pécresse en
ile de france laurent wauquiez en
auvergne rhône-alpes une étape pour les
prétendants avant d'aller vers
l'élection présidentielle mais on en
reparlera à gauche le scrutin eh bien il
sort le ps de sa torpeur avec une
victoire symbolique celle de carole
delga que vous voyez à l'image réunis
avec 57% des voix c'est la présidente de
région la mieux réélu de quoi réveiller
aussi un les ambitions du parti
socialiste parce que olivier faure il
semblait à ce moment là prêt à s'effacer
derrière une autre candidature de gauche
mais avec les bons scores de juin on
voit que le ps dit désormais avoir une
responsabilité de rassembler l'ensemble
de la gauche et des écologistes dixit
olivier faur donc deux 2 autres
enseignements politiques le rn qui rate
une marche avant 2022 marine le pen
s'était même retrouvé à exhorter ses
électeurs dans l'entre-deux-tours façon
un peu véhémente on s'en souvient les
appelant à des confiner leurs idées et à
redresser ce résultat du premier tour
les avait presque un peu engueulé
dernier enseignement c'est le manque
d'implantation toujours de lrm au niveau
local on l'avait déjà vu aussi pendant
les élections municipales et même les
membres du gouvernement ils ont fait de
mauvais score par exemple marc fesneau
et qu'on a vu arriver en quatrième
position le monde parle même d'une
défaite symbolique la région centre val
de loire était donnée gagnante un
dernier mot pour mentionner quand même
la très faible participation à ces
élections la veille seulement 33 à 34 %
de participation premier et second tours
près de 60 % au second tour en 2015 on
le rappelle près il cette faible
participation c'était l'enjeu majeur
finalement
ces élections régionales ah oui pour moi
c'est vraiment l'enseignement majeur cet
exil électorale 32-30 remis aux français
qu'ils sont qui ne sont pas allés voter
alors ça ça signe un cycle
abstentionniste jamais vu sous la vème
un public record de cette élection
records de toutes les élections
intermédiaires du quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron on avait fait avec l'ifop une
enquête pour les pour les régions de
france sur les motivations de
l'abstention on voyait qu auprès de
l'ensemble des français il y avait un
sentiment d'inutilité du vote voté pour
cette élection de l'année rien changé à
la différence de l'accord ce qu'on avait
interrogé pour une fois on était sorti
je sais que c'est une question qui nous
intéresse pas du tout mais
connaisseur mais c'est vrai que les
sondages malheureusement ce se concentre
sur la france continentale et pas
seulement sur l'ensemble du pays et
c'est vrai que au sein de l'assemblée
corse pour les corses et comme il y
avait une vraie visibilité de cette
assemblée régionale et de son action
s'était pas du tout une motiver une
motivation d'abstention et des corses
avaient voté beaucoup plus gaudermen en
tout cas c'est bon aloi le phénomène
majeur quentin très bien résumé quand
même également cette élection a signé la
segmentation du champ politique en 2h en
politique locale où les forces
traditionnelles psr sont en position de
force un champ politique national où
c'est en marche et le rn qui semblait à
l'époque semblait dominer beaucoup de
choses ont changé depuis
cette différence entre une élection
locale une élection nationale vote oui
alors ça c'est vrai c'est un point
pourtant on avait vu déjà aux élections
municipales aussi avec un taux
d'abstention qui était encore plus fort
que celui des des régionales
des bombes tout a été dit c'est à dire
que la stabilité en effet des exécutifs
qui ont été reconduits
l'inca ce principe et du parti
majoritaire en cinq ans à réussir à
transformer finalement son succès
national en succès territoriales le les
déceptions pour le rassemblement
national et ça je crois que c'est très
important parce que en l'occurrence eu
qu'à marquer aussi cette élection est ce
qu'il marque l'abstention c'est que les
classes populaires ou une partie des
classes moyennes qui peuvent voter pour
le rassemblement national ne se sont pas
mobilisés pour aller voter pour les
candidats du rassemblement national
alors qu'il faut se souvenir qu'un
certain nombre d'études les mettais mes
télé les listes du rassemblement
national en tête voire vainqueur dans un
certain nombre de régions notamment en
provence alpes côte d'azur donc ça c'est
un enseignement qui est important qui
traduit d'une certaine manière la crise
du politique savons aussi que peut-être
à l'exception en effet notable de la
corse comme l'a rappelé frédéric dabi
c'est que les les régions ne se sont pas
non plus imposer comme des acteurs
politiques qui sont des acteurs
politiques de proximité qui permettent
finalement aux électrices et aux
électeurs de comprendre quelles sont
vraiment les enjeux tels les enjeux
régionaux quelles sont les compétences
régionales quelles sont les missions des
régions ça je ne suis pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui ça soit quelque chose qui
soit très équitablement partagé dans
l'opinion publique donc finalement c'est
aussi l'échec de ses très grandes
régions que l'on avait construite en
minant en 2001 sous le quinquennat de de
françois de françois hollande ce qui
montre car mais aussi c'est que je crois
que c'est important c'est que il ya une
crise du politique dans la relation au
pouvoir national ça c'est clair on le
voit lorsqu'on regarde les études
qualitatives en matière d'image mais il
ya aussi malgré tout et c'est un signal
qu'il faut prendre en compte une crise
du politique sur le sur le local c'est à
dire que on a tendance à considérer que
finalement les les françaises et les
françaises et des distingue le local du
national le fait quand même de ne pas
s'engager de ne pas aller voter ça veut
dire quelque chose sur j'allais dire là
le lien un peu distendues qui peut
exister entre les collectivités et leurs
administrés oui je partage complètement
ce que vient de dire ah non c'est vrai
qu'il s'est passé aussi à fenain
absentionnistes très fort aux élections
municipales alors très indexé sur le
covin mais c'est vrai que d'une manière
générale on est depuis le cycle
2005-2007 participation massive à un
référendum un texte compliqué le
référendum du 29 mai 2007 participation
massive à l'élection présidentielle lui
avait des candidats de rupture une
nouvelle ère pour beaucoup de français
voire un enthousiasme depuis à chaque
élection élections régionales de 2015
excepté poste attentats on a moins voté
qu'à l'élection précédente et nous
sommes à moins de quatre mois des
élections présidentielles est ce que le
record entre guillemets du 22 du 21
avril 2002 à savoir 28 29 % d'abstention
va être si je puis dire battue ça serait
un vrai risque et ça ferait du parti
abstentionniste le premier parti de
france un mot sur la gauche puisque
quentin le soulignait à juste ce titre
on a l'impression qu'il ya eu un
tournant chez les socialistes lors de
ces régionales ainsi ils ont conservé
leur région carole delga la présidente
de région cette année était la mieux
élue sont même gagner des régions dans
les outre-mer est ce que l'absence
d'union aujourd'hui
vision à gauche tiennent leur origine
dans ces régionales et du fait que cette
poussée des socialistes et cette
faiblesse des écologistes et bien on y
vient fort a dit ben non c'est pas aux
écologistes d'être le candidat les
candidats à la présidentielle peut-être
que ces élections ont en effet conforté
le choix du ps de présenter un candidat
ou une candidate à l'élection
présidentielle c'est aussi naturel
contenu de système politique qu
présentent des candidats l'effacement ou
l'affaiblissement du parti communiste
français vient également de son absence
à cette présidentielle en 2012 et en
2017 alors quand même ça moi était une
victoire du ps qu'une victoire des
sortants le ps rares exemples en
ile-de-france avait espoir de peut-être
arrivé en tête à gauche il ne l'a pas
fait c'est vrai que c'est un peu comme
le schéma des élections municipales
quand le parti socialiste était sortant
il emporté assez nettement au municipal
seule la ville de poitiers est la ville
où un maire ps a été battu par une liste
europe écologie les verts en revanche
quand il n'était pas sortant quand la
gauche jouer la gagne jamais le ps est
arrivé en tête c'est ça aussi qui qui
explique aussi ce que ce climat de
fracturation à gauche mais la crise de
la gauche ce n'est pas qu'un problème de
division jeunes sujets souvent cet
exemple 1981 la gauche désunie cinq
candidats françois mitterrand gagne les
174 une gauche parfaitement uni règle un
candidat unique françois mitterrand y
perd non quand la difficulté de la
gauche c'est que aujourd'hui il n'y a
aucune offre politique à gauche aucune
formation politique à gauche qui soit
hégémonique mais parce que justement ce
que rappelle frédéric dabi cet important
c'est à dire que la victoire de la
gauche c'est souvent construites à
partir du moment où vous avez un parti
qui est dominant ça a été le cas du
parti socialiste qui a dominé la gauche
quand même pendant 40 ans et qui réussit
c'est finalement à créer les conditions
de son unité autour de son parti et
d'une personnalité bien évidemment à
l'intérieur de ce parti ça a été le cas
aux 80 ça a été le cas maman en 97
lorsque lionel jospin devient premier
ministre ça a été le cas avec le
françois hollande également en 2012 là
manifestement aujourd'hui le parti
socialiste n'a pas réussi à résoudre le
problème 2 son marasme de 2017
on a entendu les écologistes massés nous
ne sommes devant à gauche
après
pour les verts s'étaient pas suffisant
si vous voulez pour être dominant il
faut avoir un groupe parlementaire il
faut avoir beaucoup plus d'élus locaux
qui nous ont quitté les verts dominent
dans un certain nombre de grandes
métropoles mais leur implantation
territoriale n'est pas la même par
exemple que celle du ps qu'il a pour le
coup a une véritable implantation
territoriale donc on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui considérer que le poids des
verts étaient suffisants en la matière
pour créer les conditions de ce
rassemblement autour d'une personnalité
incontestable les derniers temps fort
pour cette année c'est un enfant de
moins de 21 ans et l'organisation d'une
primaire chez les républicains primaires
fermées d'ailleurs il fallait pas
l'appeler primaire étaient interdits
jusqu'au mais en plus les l'air partait
de loin quand on fait le bilan de cette
année à droite en mars xavier bertrand
annonce sa candidature soutenue alors eh
bien par des personnes qui sont aussi un
dans le quartier un caillou dans la
chaussure dlr et on l'entend et que lui
il va aller jusqu'au bout d'ailleurs
qu'il soit soutenu par à sa famille
politique ou non en mai c'est la main
tendue de jean castex à renaud muselier
en vue des élections régionales en
provence alpes côte d'azur qui provoque
un petit séisme à droite dans le jdd on
le voit un jean castex parle même d'une
union qui va bien au delà d'accord
d'appareil c'est un exemple de la
recomposition politique des propos qui
ulcère chez les as l'air qui essaye de
construire l'image plutôt d'un parti
d'opposition aux valeurs aux idées
différentes de la macro ni cela donne
ces réunions qu'on a vu rue de vaugirard
très houleuse avec derrière la question
des alliances est aussi des
interrogations sur la place du parti sur
l'échiquier politique les élections
régionales sont finalement un motif de
réjouissance ans l'adie pour les as
l'air qui conserve en métropole tout
leur région une fois cette échéance
passée tout s'accélère des candidats se
font connaître petit à petit au fil de
l'été valérie pécresse le 22 juillet
dans le figaro michel barnier sur tf1 le
26 août eric ciotti deux jours plus tard
devant ses soutiens dans les
alpes-maritimes et finalement le 11
octobre et xavier bertrand rentrer dans
l'est rang et accepte de participer au
congrès s'en suivront donc les quatre
débats télévisés avec de bonnes
audiences la victoire de valérie
pécresse dans un parti qui reprend du
poil de la bête ce sont au total 148
1862 adhérents à jour de cotisation qui
votent début décembre au congrès alors
que quelques mois plus tôt un fin
septembre quand il fallait arrêter les
conditions du scrutin il n'était alors
que ce soit que 79 milles des chiffres
qui réjouissent donc les cadres aient
l'air même si on est loin des 4 millions
de votants de la primaire de 2016 enfin
une dernière raison de se réjouir oriane
ce sont les sondages avec une photo de
famille réussie après le vote valérie
pécresse gagne en popularité
à l'image du baromètre au doxa bon j'ai
choisi celui là j'aurais pu en choisir
où elles gagnent 12 points d'opinions
favorables derrière ce sont tous les
cellulaires qui trépignent et welt y
croire
est-ce que 2021 on peut dire que sa
marque le retour de la droite
républicaine
en tout cas sur le champ politique
national c'est vrai que localement ça a
été dit par nos bd si on a bien vu
comment la droite a très bien tenu comme
elle a tenu aux élections municipales
malgré la perte de marseille et de
bordeaux c'est vrai que l'on peut dire
dans ce chapeau christian jacob parce
que le cheminement le chemin était qu'un
extrêmement escarpé c'est bertrand ça a
été bien dit qui par tous et qui
surprend tout le monde qui fait une très
bonne entrée en campagne et dans les
enquêtes d'opinion le seul à pouvoir
dans un second tour mon camp choisi
d'accéder au second tour battre emmanuel
macron et puis cette primaire qui n'en
était pas une avec quand même un un
environnement médiatique qui a ressemblé
à la primaire de 2016 avec moins de
monde quand même et quatre grands débats
et finalement surtout tout se passe
comme si la droite avait appris de de la
victoire de françois fillon qui avait
été très mal gérée il disparaît quinze
jours en vacances il à ses lieutenants
se débrouiller sur des mesures
extrêmement segment tandis qu'ils me
vais choquer les français des
remboursements pour la sécu cinq cent
mille fonctionnaires de moi là on a eu
ni une droite extrêmement hui et
s'arrête dans les enquêtes d'opinion la
droite est quand même outsider c'est
quand même jamais arrivé sous la vème
république à quatre mois du vote mais
elle est avec voyez pécresse en
situation peut-être d'apparaître pour
elle comme la remonte imac rond et
l'intrus et une capacité
instrumentalisée pour parler français
qui ne veulent pas que le président
actuel fasse un second mandat maintenant
tout commence je rappelle qu'en décembre
2016 françois fillon a parlé c'est
toujours comme en position de force mais
en tout cas la droite n'est pas tombé
dans ses vieux démons à savoir la
division et des chieurs ce qui constitue
toujours pour le peuple de droite un
véritable traumatisme mais je crois
qu'en séance est un peu trempé après
2007 en pensant que la droite
républicaine
finalement été dans le même état que le
ps moi je ne crois pas fondamentalement
d'abord il ya une réalité c'est que le
score de françois fillon au premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle est un
score qui continuent de
quand même les circonstances tout à fait
exceptionnelles de cette campagne de
cette campagne resterai en france aussi
y aura de très peu finalement la
qualification au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle dont le socle
de la droite républicaine est solide et
il a démontré qu'il était solide durant
toutes les élections intermédiaires à
l'exception des élections européennes
bien évidemment mais comme les élections
locales les élections municipales et les
élections régionales dont on vient de
parler donc il y a un besoin
manifestement qui s'exprime de droite
républicaine dans de larges segments de
l'opinion publique ça c'est une réalité
ensuite c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
indéniablement il y à une réussite de ce
10e disons de ceux de ce procès de cette
procédure de mode de désignation
parce que ce qu'a réussi à éviter le ski
ont ils réussi à éviter les républiques
c'est évidemment de ne pas pouvoir
mettre en place des conditions de
rassemblement comme ça a été le cas en
2010 est là en l'occurrence clairement
gia une droite qui est aujourd'hui unis
et qui est prête à en découdre avec
emmanuel macron le dernier aspect c'est
que je pense en effet que aujourd'hui la
situation est à à changé depuis quinze
jours on sent bien depuis trois semaines
la possibilité disons d'une alternative
qui n'était pas du tout évidente il ya
encore trois semaines devient possible
donc les règles j'allais dire de la
campagne sont en train de bouger et et
valérie pécresse de ce point de vue là
et quand même plus que nous de cider je
pense qu'elle est en train de malgré
tout devenir une quand une concurrente
très sérieuses et on le voit d'ailleurs
dans la façon dont aujourd'hui la macro
ni est en train de de cibler
spécifiquement valérie pécresse dans
cette campagne c'est pas qu'un effet
primaire seul en vo c'est une vraie
question on se souvient d'un françois
fillon qui gagne 9 points entre l'avant
et l'après primaire 9 points
d'intentions de vote il est à 29 % c'est
pour ça que je rappelle que sa chute
dans les enquêtes d'opinion est
antérieure au pays de caux pénélope
gates c'est le cas également de françois
hollande en 2011 mais droit est ce que
ça défile au primaire va être si je puis
dire
confortés c'est vrai que à l'instar d'un
match c'est vrai qu'elle s'inscrit en
rupture avec emma dacron sur beaucoup
d'aspects un homme une femme quelqu'un
qui n'est pas élu local 20 pécresse qui
est enraciné en y 2 o l'ile-de-france
tech 1 qui dixit la candidate heller a
cramé la caisse elle qui a fait beaucoup
d'économies dans le cadre de sa région
elle installe un match et puis elle a
quand même une difficulté il faut le
dire c'est qu'elle a mené une guerre sur
deux fronts faire revenir c'est cet
électorat de droite un électeur filant
sur cinq qui est toujours très ancrée
schéma de macron parce que il à réformer
parce qu'il a tenu ses promesses parce
qu'il n'a pas trahi comme a pu trahir en
termes de perception nicolas sarkozy et
puis de se lancer aussi dans un deuxième
front c'est à dire cette primaire de
droite extrême sauvage entre marine le
pen et riddes et moi et faire revenir un
électorat de droite qui à qui elle va
essayer de faire passer le message
suivant marine le pen n'est pas crédible
pour battait même mails macron eric
zemmour est un venin vote tribunicien
protestataires qu'il sert à rien donc
aller sur deux fronts c'est pas facile
dans le cadre d'une élection
présidentielle deux premiers tours où la
première stratégie c'est d'abord
rassembler son camp uniquement pour
pour continuer ce que dit frédéric cette
base cette base dont vous parlez la base
de droit de nantes a bénéficié françois
fillon est ce qu elle existe encore
aujourd'hui est ce qu elle s'effrite un
peu de leur manifester
il doit les tiens ma confie si on
regarde si on regarde a certainement
d'études d'opinion on voit qu'il ya
quand même une attractivité de l'offre
politique d'eric zemmour vis-à-vis d'une
partie de l'électorat de françois fillon
notamment un car manifestement de
l'électorat françois fillon serait tenté
ou encore été tenté il ya quelques
semaines par le vote en faveur d'eric
zemmour ça c'est une c'est une réalité
mais ce qui est aussi c'est qu'il faut
se mettre je dis bien voir quelle est la
psychologie collective d'une partie de
l'électorat de la droite républicaine
aujourd'hui une grande partie de cet
électorat de la droite républicaine
considère qui s'est fait voler sa
victoire en 2017 et ça c'est un élément
qui va jouer forte le moment venu
lorsque le vote va se cristalliser pour
le pour valérie pécresse le grand défi
dans les semaines qui viennent c'est de
rester à un niveau qui lui permet dans
les airs dans les intentions de votes
d'être une concurrente qui soit une
concurrente qui met véritablement en
danger emmanuel macron si elle parvient
dans les semaines qui viennent en effet
à occuper cette place de prennent le
principal challengeur javid emmanuel
macron ben ses chansons seront
certainement que sérieux à
droite et est ce qu'il peut gagner sans
cette part des lecteurs à droite il ne
le père pendu mots ce qui me frappe fait
c'est aussi un autre élément de l'année
moins spectaculaires que ceux qui ont
été présentés c'est sa stabilité
parfaite en quête de popularité autour
de 40% en enquêtes d'intentions de vote
25 à 26% ses gammes le président le
premier président depuis françois
mitterrand 88 qui au dessus de son score
originaire de son soft de premier tour
de son élection victorieuse c'est vrai
que l macron garde son qui bouge pas
trois quarts de son électorat qui de
2017 qui le soutient et il ne capacité à
mordre sur 25% à droite et un petit peu
moins gauche mais également
à gauche la crise de la gauche fait que
les maquereaux nice de gauche ne voit
pas de réceptacle crédible a quitté le
président sortant c'est vrai que il a
tout à fait intérêt à garder ces macro
nice de droite ces personnes qui ont été
satisfaits des réformes menées pendant
le quinquennat mais qui vont peut-être
trouver un sentiment de trop peu doux
pendant son allocution son intervention
les journalistes tf1 lci
ça a un long moment un long
développement sur la réforme des
retraites valérie pécresse et sur une
capacité à montrer qu'elle est c'est la
vraie réformatrice elle promet la fin
des 35 heures et la retraite à 65 ans là
aussi c'est d'un un élément de combats
ou des distinctions par rapport au
président sortant et on aura bien sûr
l'occasion un grand plaisir de parler de
cette campagne présidentielle avec vous
évidemment d'abord quand on va continuer
on va pencher de nos bonnes habitudes
quand même même pour cette dernière on
va parler de la presse quotidienne
régionale avec vous
et quand ans et pas une revue de presse
traditionnelle sur la une d'aujourd'hui
mais vous allez vous avez là aussi
balayé l'année 2021 et on commence par
cette campagne de vaccination qui
commençait tout juste un mois de
chantier exactement la toute première
injection elle a eu lieu précisément le
27 décembre rappelez vous c'était
morissette en seine saint denis un café
et thé et qui avait reçu la toute
première dose met donc en janvier la
cession d une du 5 janvier on voit la
presse quotidienne régionale qui compte
la moindre dose qui arrive dans chaque
département parce que les observateurs
espèrent que les livraisons
hebdomadaires vont permettre d'accélérer
la vaccination rappelez vous à ce moment
là on ne vaccine et uniquement que dans
les ehpad et pour les soignants de plus
de 50 ans et on voit déjà la polémique
poindra toujours le 5 janvier la dépêche
du midi à toulouse s'interroge sur
l'accélération de la vaccination car la
france à ce moment là est bien plus
lente à vacciner que les autres pays
développés un retard on sait un cadre
attrapera et donc le début est bien de
cette image d seringue en une des
journaux qui ne quittera plus un de
toute la neige et au fil de l'automne on
a mieux revenir progressivement le coc
vide aucun ballack exactement là
sentiers notamment au mois de novembre
la préoccupation liée à la cinquième
vague c'est aussi cela un autre année
2021 l'éternel recommencement lié aux
chiffres de l'épidémie et aux annonces
gouvernementales qui venait juste après
des mesures à saint avold durcir titrait
ainsi le 25 novembre le courrier picard
et quant à l'est républicain le
lendemain titré sur le rappel et la
troisième dose qui s'est élargie
progressivement à toutes les catégories
d'âge d'ailleurs on apprend ce matin que
le comité consultatif d'éthique s'est
dit favorable à l'ouverture de
vaccination pour les enfants et donc on
en parlera évidemment 2022 on imagine
qu'avec le coc vie de cette année autres
faits marquants vous avez choisi c'est
le gel qui a touché 90 % du territoire
métropolitain absolument rappelez vous
le 8 avril on voyait c'est une dans la
neige et le feu comme titre le journal
de saône et loire avec des viticulteurs
qui avaient allumé des bougies dans les
champs quelques jours plus tôt le beau
temps avait fait éclore les bourgeons
sur les plantes et quelques jours plus
tard ce sont au total 81 sur 96
départements métropolitains qui ont été
touchés par la vague de gel on verra
ensuite les conséquences un baisse de la
production de 40% des pêches par exemple
60% pour les cerises le gouvernement
mettra 1
un d'euros sur la table pour répondre
est ce qu'il restera comme une des pires
catastrophes agronomique de ce début de
siècle dixit le ministre de la culture
en avance dans l'année des joies et des
déceptions avec l'euro de foot oui bon 7
euros déjà prévue en 2020 qui se tient
donc un an plus tard et on voit
l'excitation à gauche la du berry
républicain qui titre avec un heureux
événement nous nous sommes alors que le
11 juin à la veille du démarrage de la
compétition et on voit sur la droite de
une un mois plus tard très vite c'est la
soupe à la grimace la claque
l'incroyable le fiasco des bleus
exactement vous en rappelez thiellement
jedi ans battue par la suisse à l'issue
de la séance de tirs au but en huitième
de finale une frustration aussi car la
france menée 3 à 1 10 minutes avant la
fin du temps réglementaire bref ça et un
été pluvieux ça a failli del moral bon
c'était pas un fiasco tant que ça disney
aller le 3 octobre dernier une
disparition marquante celle de bernard
tapie voilà ça va donner à ces très
belles une en hommage au chef
d'entreprise ministre homme d'affaires à
l'image de la provence et ceux à dieu
bosse on le sait puisque et bien et
bernard tapie était l'actionnaire
principal du quotidien marseillais le
républicain lorrain parler de l'homme
aux mille et une vies bernard tapie
laissera l'image d'un éternel battant
finalement vaincu par le cancer écrivait
le journal basé à metz quand on a
terminé quand même avec un sourire je le
sourire une actu plus légères c'est
quand même votre conseil sortie du
vendredi pour l'occasion
mais c'est avec ce soir parce qu'en fait
c'est la journée mondiale du public de
noël il faut le dire on prétend on
pouvait pas enfilé un pull moche en
pleine émission donc on a choisi le
bonnet de certains exactement mais donc
on termine avec une lecture un peu plus
réjouissante on a vu ces picards très
excité par un film les tuche 4 le
parisien aujourd'hui en france parlait
lui de la french touch face au phénomène
de ce film déjà dix ans est le premier
opus qui est sorti un paradoxe hilarant
selon le parisien jean paul rouve
incarne et bien un français moyen à la
fois chômeurs et manager un personnage
attachant et donc depuis le 8 décembre
ce film doc le box office français alors
pourquoi pas aller au cinéma voir ce
film ou un autre et sortir de la
morosité ambiante gérer le voir arnaud
frédéric tout autre ouais ça donne envie
de sortir de la morosité ambiante au
mans merci beaucoup merci infiniment ça
me paraissait avec nous pour cette
dernière
l'année merci content merci pour le
cadeau il est
évidemment d'excellentes fêtes de fin
d'année à tous les trois excellentes
fêtes de fin d'année à vous qui nous
regarde et on aura le grand plaisir de
vous retrouver à la rentrée le 10
janvier a très vite
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous en présenter le
club des territoires
la mutuelle nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous a présenté le club
des territoires
angie acteurs engagés dans la transition
zéro carbone et région vous a présenté
le club des territoires
[Musique]
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
[Musique]
elle fait partie des quatre petits % de
femmes chefs d'orchestre française elle
a créé son propre orchestre symphonique
elle a installé à stains en
seine-saint-denis le département où elle
a grandi sans combat c'est de mélanger
les mondes l'at-elle gagner ce combat
zahia ziouani est notre invité dans un
monde un regard les entretiens de public
sénat un monde un regard avec zahia
ziouani ce soir à 19h sur public sénat
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur les temps forts de l'actualité à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat avec
steve jourdain nous sommes très heureux
d'accueillir cette semaine claude
malhuret bonjour bonjour et bienvenue
vous êtes président du groupe les
indépendants au sénat et c'est steve qui
dresse votre portrait bonjour claude
malhuret vous êtes en quelque sorte bleu
franc tireur du sénat claude malhuret
vous êtes né en 1950 à strasbourg vous
êtes médecin épidémiologiste vous avez
travaillé pour l'om et puis pour
médecins sans frontières organise une
organisation que vous avez présidé vous
êtes un libéral claude malhuret pour
vous les droits de l'homme ça compte
mais vous détestez l'angélisme d'une
certaine partie de la gauche pour vous
l'économie de marché est l'une des
conditions de la liberté maire de la
ville de vichy pendant 28 ans vous avez
été secrétaire d'état député européen
député puis sénateur et donc vous
présidez aujourd'hui au sénat le groupe
les indépendants mais allez vous
réellement pouvoir conserver cette
indépendance claude malhuret vous venez
de rejoindre le parti horizon créée par
edouard philippe pourquoi expliquez-nous
haut pour des tas de raisons d'abord
parce que c'est une longue histoire
doit en fait vous savez était le bras
droit d'alain juppé moi j'ai soutenu
alain juppé lors de la primaire de 2017
avec edouard philippe donc nous étions
déjà ensemble à l'époque ensuite il a
été premier ministre moi en tant que
président du groupe des indépendants
tant que président de groupe comme de
tout le groupe j'ai beaucoup travaillé
avec lui bien entendu j'ai eu l'occasion
de de la passe et je trouve que ça a été
un très bon premier nice dans une
période difficile
j'ai l'impression de ne pas être le seul
si on en croit les sondages les français
aujourd'hui trouve aussi que ça a été un
très bon premier ministre et aujourd'hui
ils créent ce parti horizon andy
indépendamment de cela c'est un titre
personnel
il a deux qualités que je trouve
exceptionnel d'abord dans ce monde
politique souvent dur et déshumanisée
c'est vraiment un humaniste quelqu'un
qui a qui fait preuve de beaucoup
d'humanité je crois que les gens le
ressentent et 2e 2e qualités qui me
paraît très très important c'est
quelqu'un qui voit loin 2027 voilà il
explique en permanence que les petites
phrases il faut arrêter qu'on va pas se
livrer à sa
2027 et au delà je veux dire je parle je
veux pas dire qu'il prépare l'avenir
il est normal qu'ils éventuellement il y
pense moi je vaux pas de mal à ça mais
aujourd'hui la réflexion d'horizon c'est
sûr la perspective 2030 et
éventuellement la perspective au delà
donc il ya des tas de raisons pour
lesquelles
j'ai rejoint en refusant la principale
étant effectivement de rejoindre
l'équipe d'edouard philippe parce
qu'aujourd'hui la politique et beaucoup
une affaire de personnalité et qui est
lourd philippe est sans doute l'une des
personnes à litière à la fois préféré
des français est pour moi depuis
longtemps que je trouve la plus le plus
susceptible d'être suivie en politique
alors edouard philippe justement a donné
une interview dans la presse cette
semaine nous dit que valérie pécresse
est une adversaire très respectable ils
ont des visions communes que ce soit sur
les finances sur les sur les retraites
elle soutenait d'ailleurs alain juppé en
2016 où il faisait référence il ya
quelques instants qu'est ce qui
différencie véritablement valérie
pécresse d'edouard philippe ben moi j'ai
la même opinion que lui sur valérie
pécresse d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs la plupart la plupart des
candidats à cette élection je dire
n'était pas tout mais la plupart sont
respectables de toute façon mais valérie
pécresse on se connaît bien
on a quitté les républicains en même
temps edouard philippe elle mois et un
certain nombre d'autres la différence
entre nous c'est que nous n'avons pas ne
sont pas retourner aux républicains et
nous n'y sommes pas retournés parce que
nous avons quitté les républicains pour
les mêmes raisons c'était un parti trop
à droite un parti qui se droitise et qui
se radicalise et est ce que vous en
pensez on a vu
les principaux dirigeants
à voter pour mme pour emmanuel macron au
deuxième tour des élections
présidentielles contre marine le pen
nous avons quitté ce parti 12 ans jean à
cause de ça aujourd'hui ce parti c'est
encore droitiser avec les 40% et les
déclarations d'eric ciotti sur le
guantanamo à la française sur le volume
écrit ce qu'est la candidate de la
droite elle est trop à droite pour vous
est ce que ce que je veux dire c'est que
moi je suis resté sur le constat du
départ
et que dans un parti que j'ai guidé mois
ci s'est droitisée qui se droitise
encore aujourd'hui je ne comprends pas
tout respectable qu'elle soit je ne
comprends pas
le retour dans ce parti et la place
donnée à son concurrent qui est arrivé
deuxième et qui aujourd'hui cela m'aide
dans une situation extrêmement délicate
et jeu et l'a poussé à prendre des
orientations que je ne souhaite
absolument pas et que j'espère auquel
j'espère que
oui c'était je crois que même lui n'en
parle le plus utilisé a bien su que
c'était quand même bien claude malhuret
vous allez faire campagne pour emmanuel
macron oui horizon va faire campagne
pour emmanuel macron edouard philippe et
vous personnellement oui vous ne doutez
pas qu'il soit candidat du coup
j'ai oublié de te dire au cas où il
serait candidat mais pour moi ça fait
assez peu de jeu de doute ou non pour
vous aussi sans doute on va passer au
sommaire de cette émission claude
malhuret la commission d' enquête sur
l'hôpital public poursuit ses travaux au
sénat cette semaine les responsables des
services d'urgence tire la sonnette
d'alarmé ils disent devoir faire
toujours plus avec toujours moins on les
entendra dans un instant la présidence
française de l'union européenne en débat
à l'assemblée cette semaine elle doit
démarrer le 1er janvier un calendrier
contesté par les oppositions qui accuse
le président de s'en servir pour faire
campagne
évaluer l'influencé des cabinets de
conseil privé sur les politiques
publiques c'est la mission d'une autre
commission denquête mise en place par le
sénat cette semaine santé publique
france et l' ars d'île de france étaient
auditionnés
c'est un appel au secours nous sommes
tous en train d'y glisser notre peau
c'est ce qu'ont déclaré les médecins
urgentistes cette semaine devant la
commission bancaire du sénat focus sur
un aspect de la crise de l'hôpital
public avec samia dechy regarder un
afflux de passion toujours plus
important avec toujours moins de lits
disponibles
les responsables des services d'urgence
du privé comme du public des villes ou
des campagnes raconte presque tous la
même histoire celle du manque de
personnel découragés par la surcharge de
travail et le manque de reconnaissance
c'est ce quotidien difficile qu'ils sont
venus exposer la commission d' enquête
du sénat sur l'hôpital offert de la
médecine il faut des médecins des
infirmières des aides soignantes des ash
comme à l'hôtel publics ont fait des
vagues démission et pour en avoir
discuté avec quelques sursauts tous les
infirmières elles craquent perd toujours
plus avec toujours moins c'était plus
possible donc 37 infirmière sur notre
hôpital on a perdu 60 lits
en 18 mois on est passés 340 à 280
concernant la prise en charge des
patients
je crois que le mot indigne et le plus
simple et le plus parlant pour tout le
monde on peut attendre plusieurs heures
avant d'être pris en charge cette
semaine jean dame de 95 ans qui restait
36 heures dans le couloir des urgences
pour donner envie aux soignants de
revenir aux urgences plusieurs pistes
sont avancées
harmoniser les rémunérations des
différents services ou faire venir les
médecins de ville dont les hôpitaux ça
permettrait aussi d'améliorer
l'attractivité de la médecine d'urgence
en permettant des activités partagées on
peut imaginer des jeunes générations
travaillant dans une maison de santé la
moitié du temps et l'autre moitié étant
à l'hôpital mais on ne réglera pas le
problème des urgences si l'on implique
pas les autres services prévient un
médecin il faut aussi que
les différentes spécialités dans
l'hôpital aussi prennent conscience de
la nécessité de réorganiser leurs
services bien sûr en tenant compte de
toutes les complexités qu'ils peuvent
avoir et comptait aussi la possibilité
que nos patients qui sont aux urgences
puisse monter lorsque le leem rapidement
dans les étages pas de solution miracle
donc à une crise aussi ancien et aux
racines multiples mais une série de
propositions très concrètes pour les
urgences entendu par une commission
denquête qui rendra ses travaux fin mars
claude malhuret faire toujours plus avec
toujours moins 10 les médecins
urgentistes c'est ce que vous entendez
cette colère
je crois que
on parle de ça depuis des mois et je
pense qu'il faudrait être aveugle pour
ne pas le voir bien entendu qu'il ya une
crise de l'hôpital est bien entendu que
la crise l'une des raisons
conjoncturelles c'est la crise sanitaire
c'est le co vide qui a évidemment dans
une situation déjà défavorable entraîné
comme d'ailleurs tous les autres pays
aujourd'hui c'est une crise d'une
querelle mais pas structure si c'est ce
que j'allais dire je dirais
conjoncturellement il y a comme dans
tous les pays cette crise sanitaire
majeure qui est loin d'être terminée et
qui apporta des dvd des difficultés
mais c'est fait elle n'est pas de n est
pas aujourd'hui et elle est en partie
structurelle pour moi ça fait des années
que ça dure et la première le premier
coup
terrible porté à l'hôpital ça a été les
35 heures les 35 heures ont été un coup
terrible à l'économie française mais
s'il ya un secteur et en tant que maire
j'ai été pendant 28 ans président de
conseil d'administration de l'hôpital de
ma ville je peux vous dire que les 35
heures ont été un coup les imans revenir
sur les 35 heures il m'arrive un jour de
ses 35 jours dhuys effet ces
kits historiquement ça a commencé là
deuxièmement on parlait dans le
reportage du nombre de médecins du
nombre d'infirmières et c'est le numerus
clausus il a été décidé il ya 20 ans 30
ans et par conséquent on paye
aujourd'hui cela et on le payera
longtemps puisqu'il faut dix ans pour
former un médecin et qu'on a commencé
mais on convient juste de commencer et
cetera et cetera les fermetures de lits
c'est un petit peu plus complexe parce
que la médecine et la chirurgie
deviennent de plus en plus ambulatoire
et quand on regarde le nombre de lits
fermés il faut aussi
il faut regarder le nombre de services
assez justifie ses lilas pour faire de
l'anglais la partie qui correspond
au virage vers l'ambulatoire oui elle se
justifie yahoo c'est à dire un mouvement
général en europe est tant mieux je veux
dire les patients préfèrent les soins en
ambulatoire que les soit aujourd'hui
vous garder les gens en géorgie deux ou
trois fois moins selon les pathologies
céline inverse la réanimation vers des
livres on a besoin de lui comme jamais
vous pouvez faire ce que vous voulez que
transformer délit
de soins en lits de réanimation le
problème n'est pas le nom de lui le
problème c'est le personnel le personnel
de réanimation vous pouvez pas le fort
mais comme ça du jour au lendemain et
par conséquent ça ne change en rien ça
veut dire que la solution vous allez
trouver qui est le ségur de la santé n'a
rien réglé depuis deux ans finalement
c'est vital figure de la santé a le
permis quand même d'apporter plus que
depuis des années et des années de
l'argent dans le système hospitalier les
efforts qui ont été faits sont
considérables mais les réformes de
structure vous pouvez pas les faire en
quelques mois et ses réformes de
structures n'ont cessé à mon avis loin
d'être un problème d'argent et l'autre
problème d'organisation c'est ce qu'on
dit est ce que j'avais vu au racing en a
pas répondu l'hymne allemand à la
question de l'hôpital l'autre problème
en dehors de en dehors des délais moyens
c'est un problème effectivement de
management je vous donne un exemple
j'étais donc président du conseil
administration qu'en tant que maire et
un jour j'ai eu une grève du personnel
dans un des services de l'hôpital le
directeur appelle et on discute et il me
dit je le dis pourquoi le personnel est
en grève ils sont en grève contrôleurs
contre le médecin sont pas en grève
parce que l'hôpital va mal et ses
dirigeants en grève contre le plan ce
type est un sale type qui ne prenait pas
ses gardes qui je laissais des gens se
dit oui on lui téléphone à deux jours le
matin dit
il du cas par cas les avez regardés en
dépression nerveuse et cédera c'était
une situation où jacques comme j'ai
rarement vu le directeur me dis
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire mais je dis
ce type là il faut le virer dans
n'importe quelle boîte normal on
entreprendra une procédure 18
réclamé 10 mais bon on ne peut pas vous
ne pouvez pas le mur et je ne peux pas
lui julie pourquoi parce que le seul le
ministre de la santé peu
peut faire cela c'est à dire que je suis
donc allée cd kouchner le 1100 à
l'époque je suis ce que je connaissais
bien je vais digérer effet gazier je
suis d'accord bordas mais je ne peux pas
le virer janvier
vous vous en connaissez bien les taux
dans les aboutissants s'il est ce que je
veux dire je veux dire que quand vous
avez un système où le médecin d'un
hôpital d'une ville moyenne est nommé
juge et direction c'est-à-dire que tous
les médecins de tous les objets de
france le sont par le minsanté vous
voyez bien que ce système soviétique et
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres amis
doute ça peut pas marcher le navire est
vraiment que son faux bond en avant ce
vendredi le comité national d'éthique a
donné son feu vert pour la vaccination
des enfants vous y est favorable
écoutez
si le comité national d'éthique et si le
le conseil scientifique le dit ou si la
haute autorité de santé le dis c'est pas
moi qui vais vous dire si je suis
vraiment pas si lisse que c'est que que
qu'il faut le faire
c'est obligatoire ils ont laissé encore
une fois je veux pas me jeu va pas moi m
certes médecins annoncent
la situation mais je dis si l'on décidé
ça il faut faire il faut faire ce qu'ils
disent et donc ils ont dit il faut le
faire et ils ont dit il faut le laisser
facultatif donc je pense que c'est ce
qu'il faut faire le président n'a pas
exclu la vaccination obligatoire quand
on voit qu'aujourd'hui à peu près 90% de
la population est vaccinée est ce que ce
serait vraiment utile de la rendre
obligatoire je pense que je reviendrai
exactement le système actuel c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui
c'est le pass sanitaire ça n'est pas
obligatoire il y à une atteinte aux
résidus l de la population qui de toute
façon ne se fera pas vacciner par
idéologie par éloignement et par
isolement social
etc etc et vous si vous dites la
vaccination obligatoire qu'est ce que
vous faites vous envoyer les crs pour
pour le cherchez vous mettez des amendes
c'est donc l'obligatoire ça ne peut pas
marcher danser le passé milliards
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui la contrainte
et je pense qu'il faut ce degré de
contrainte qui permet ça a marché le
discours du président au mois de juin
dix ans sur le passé des rémanents faut
y aller quel a été son résultat nous
sommes le pays le mieux vacciner ya de
l'afro zekan
sanitaire 110000 faux-pas sanitaires ont
été détectés sont jaradat maintenant
vous demander des sanctions pour les
férus quand j'entends dire qu'une partie
ses faux-pas sanitaires sont faits par
des médecins par des collègues à moi
je trouve ça mais un caddie
injustifiable faut les sanctionner on
faire un faux non seulement faire un
faux mais en plus il ya défaut de
complaisance sur les arrêts de travail
par exemple on le sait bien je tousse
d'ailleurs
être remédié par exemple mais en
l'occurrence aller jusqu'à ce jour c'est
rien c'est au conseil de l'ordre de le
décider mais le fait qu'il faille des
champions enfin là cette info qui en
plus
et nuisible à la santé de la personne
puisque en eau puisque ont fait en le
conduit en lui le favorise le fait qu'il
ne soit pas avec ce n'est donc qu'ils
puissent être malade dont qu'il puisse
finir en rémission et qu'ils puissent
finir par décider de la part de médecins
c'était et c'est probablement même
pénalement non seulement une fonction à
mon avis au niveau du crochet the world
mais c'est pénalement répréhensible
poursuite c'est un faux et infos qui
nuit à la santé oms va de la barre deux
médecins c'est inconcevable allez on
passe à un autre sujet à présent et on
va parler de la présidence française de
l'union européenne qui a donné lieu à un
débat à l'assemblée cette semaine
emmanuel macron présidera le conseil de
l'union à partir du 1er janvier un
calendrier contesté par les oppositions
qui accuse le président de s'en servir
pour faire campagne à quelques mois de
la présidentielle
on fait le point avec clément perreault
la france aurait-elle dû modifier les
dates de sa présidence du conseil
européen pour l'opposition de droite
comme de gauche la réponse est oui en
2006 l'allemagne avait échangé sa
présidence du conseil de l'union
européenne avec la finlande afin
d'éviter la concurrence entre les
élections et la présidence l'arrogance
macro nien démontre une fois de plus que
jupiter peut rester au dessus des règles
il ya inévitablement un
télescopages de calendriers un mélange
des genres une confusion des rôles entre
présidence de la république française
présidence en exercice du conseil de
l'union européenne est candidat à
l'élection présentielle sue était
possible de remettre cette présidence de
six mois ce qui en outre lui aurait
donné plus de légitimité est plus de
poids mais tout est bon pour faire
campagne sans le dire jusqu'au dernier
quart d'heure pour reprendre
l'expression des manuels macro ces
attaques ont fait réagir vivement la
majorité et le gouvernement
on a pris un engagement nous sommes
capables de l'assumer nous le respectons
mais au nom de quoi devrait on
considérer que la dérogation est la
norme et que la norme est une anomalie
en u dans l'union européenne il n'y a
pas trois 3 mois 6 mois qui se passe
sans qu'un pays soit en élection donc il
faudrait envisager de modifier le
règlement et le tour de présidence en
fonction des échéances électorales de
tel ou tel pays pourquoi pas à tout ça
tout ça est absurde si un autre candidat
qui emmanuel macron remporte l'élection
il lui succédera immédiatement à la
présidence du conseil européen il
exercera alors cette responsabilité pour
deux mois claude malhuret la campagne
présidentielle a déjà démarré enfants
sont secs le président emmanuel macron
est très pro européens on se dit qu'il
peut y avoir d arrière pensée est ce
qu'il aurait dû décaler de six mois la
présidence française de l'union
européenne c'est une blague c'est une
blague
ces gens qui sont en train de de
l'accusé de faire campagne avec la
présidence urbain ils ont oublié une
chose c'est que non pas la dernière fois
mais l'avant dernière fois que la france
a été présidente pour six mois de la du
conseil européen et la présidence
tournante c'était en 1995 pendant la
présidentielle de 1995
en 2006 et c'est à dire exactement la
même jour personne n'a demandé à
mitterrand à l'époque de reculer la
présidence la présidence heure en 2006
l'allemagne avait laissé sa place à la
finlande pour des raisons de calendrier
électoral si l'allemagne décide de le
faire c'est à ccc ce qu'elle vaut mais
vous avez tous les tours en fait tous
les pays d'europe sont successivement
conduit pendant six mois président est
évidemment que dans tous ces pays c'est
ça entre tôt ou tard dans beaucoup de
cas au même moment que des élections
générales législatives présidentielles
ou et cgc si on commence à faire ça et
encore une fois on l'a déjà fait il ya
ici donc c'est absolument rien passé
aujourd'hui brusquement c'est un
scandale à fos pas de problème vous
qu'un
président soit en campagne le président
de qui soit président effectivement delà
de la du conseil européen des ministres
qui seront sans doute en campagne alors
que législatives arrivent ça pose pas de
problème et absolument pas puisque ccc
le prévu dans lequel c'est le calendrier
normal en plus je vous signale que ici
un président ça fait pas démontré s'il
en est fait à chaque fois c'est un trio
c'est à dire que nous sommes avec la
suède j'ai je crois le portugal donc
c'est pas seulement un pays qui est que
tous les six mois ccdp issus de ces
trois pays à la fois successivement même
s'il y en a un qui évidemment qui a le
leadership
sera la fin mais si on commence ça avec
les 27 pays
on y arrivera le calendrier il est quand
même très réduit puisque finalement ça
va réduire cette présidence française à
3 mois si emmanuel macron n'est pas
réélu en avril prochain qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire en trois mois finalement
d'abord dans un cas de figure ça va pas
le réduire le cap il y aurait il est élu
et où il continue deuxièmement dans un
c'est à partir de céder partir du moment
où vous lancer et c'est exactement comme
d'ailleurs en politique nationale veut
dire c'est les trois premiers mois qui
est ses trois premiers mois ils sont
prévenus ils sont prévus ils sont
préparés bien à l'avancé on a déjà
commencé pensé longtemps - il peut
impulser
par la suite les orientations qui ont
été données seront suivies elles sont
faites dans des dents laniel mackenzie
et puis je vais vous dire une dernière
chose sur la grille sur la présidence
européenne
aujourd'hui il ya en france des
européens et des
des anti européens je vois qu'il ya plus
beaucoup du jeu mou heureusement
beaucoup plus d'européens et d'anti
européen mais quand vous voyez qu'une
bonne partie des ddd campagne électorale
se passe à dénigrer l'europe à dire tout
ce qui va mal c'est la faute de rebelles
ou est-ce que vous êtes certains que
c'est une un plus pour un candidat les
jambes résidentiel de près d'être le
président de l'europe et c'est du moins
ce qu'elle écrit et de se juger a tâté
de se confronter à tous les problèmes
qui veillera à commencer par la crise
sanitaire au niveau européen maintenant
avec le voyons au micro nous savons que
sa crise sanitaire va durer qu'elle va
occuper les premiers mois de cette
présidence française avec beaucoup
d'autres problèmes mais et dieu sait que
vous avez assisté aux discussions et aux
bo aux confrontations qui a eu l'heur de
la gestion de la crise sanitaire par
l'europe on a accusé aussi l'europe
vaccin là même si je pense pour en faire
le bilan mais je pense que lui on est
très positif thierry breton l'a expliqué
très positif on nous on a reproché le
rôle des plantes etc qu'est ce qu'elle
est le résultat aujourd'hui premièrement
l'europe est le pays le plus axé le
continent le bleu vacciner au monde
deuxièmement il est celui qui produit le
plus de doses de vaccin au monde et
troisièmement il est celui qui fournit
aux pays pauvres le maximum de deux
doses au monde donc c'est plutôt mais à
l'époque effectivement on a beaucoup
critiqué donc il va y avoir un nouveau
des discussions a su je suis pas sûr que
auto ainsi avancé est un plus pour un
candidat d'être confronté à tous ces
problèmes européens plus le prendre
laurence les problèmes économiques etc
allez vous rester avec mon claude
malhuret on va parler de la commission
d' enquête sur influence des cabinets de
conseil privé sur les politiques
publiques et c'est le plus de la semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évaluer l'influencé croissante des
cabinets de conseil privé sur les
politiques publiques voilà la mission
que s'est fixée une commission d'enquêté
du sénat lancée à l'initiative du groupe
communiste cette semaine la directrice
de la rs ile-de-france était auditionné
écoutez là vous avoue que j'ai trouvé
c'est un petit peu presque vexante nous
dire s'ils avaient pas un recours accru
au cabinet de conseil avec une
désaffection en manque d'attractivité
pour la dans la fonction publique dans
le secteur de la santé on essaye de
rassembler les expertises la plus large
possible sur une mission qui est elle
même assez large
la principale réponse encore une fois
été des renforts humains eux ponctuelles
sur les quatre dernières années
les achats de prestations externes
s'élève à à peu près de 250000 euros par
an les deux domaines dans lesquels on a
appelle de manière plus régulière à des
prestations de conseil sont d'une part
le domaine informatique
et après ce qui a été fait
particulièrement est directement liée à
la crise c'est mettre en place un outil
de prévision des besoins de lits en
soins critiques et donc il a été fait
appel à une un prestataire extérieur
pour un budget important d'un million 2
claude malhuret est il légitime qu'un
gouvernement fasse appel à des cabinets
privés pour gérer la politique sanitaire
de la france que j'ai ça c'est
l'obsession des communistes quand vous
leur dites le mot privé c'est comme si
vous vous agitez une muleta devant un
toro de combat
voilà c'est fait et c'est leur truc
alors ils forment comme ils sont en
quête là dessus évidemment que ça a
toujours existé que ça existera toujours
je vous donne un exemple l'exemple du
maire que j'ai été bon vous faites
n'importe quoi vous construisez et quand
vous construisez vous avez un architecte
qui est privé vous avez une entreprise
qui devait tp qui est privé vous avez un
assistant à maître d ouvrage qui est un
cabinet de conseil c'est ce dont on
parle là et donc tous les jours les
administrations publiques ce je prie
juste mais cela non mais y en a il y en
a des tas du niveau d'une petite mairie
jusqu'au niveau de la deux du
gouvernement il y a heureusement
des échanges les sujets sur
l'installation n'est pas capable de
gérer salle même l'administration elle
est capable de gérer des à 12 et il ya
des tas est liée à des choses dont les
assistantes à maîtrise d'ouvragé tu sais
où les conseils du point de vue
financier ou dans deux domaines où des
communes et du congé privées
spécialisées sont là pour ça c'est pas
parce que l'administration et
d'efficience écueil et il ya une partie
des choses que le public doit faire et
fait mieux et fait bien et puis certains
noms de il faut surtout arrêter de me
démettre des silos de mettre des murs
mais quand même un risque de conflit
d'intérêts on voit qu'il ya des agents
qui passe de ces cabinets de conseil
privé au public on voit que des cabinets
de conseils peuvent à la fois conseiller
l'état sur la crise sanitaire ou un labo
pharmaceutique
assure bien sûr bien sûr c'est pas une
raison pour arrêter il faut qu' il faut
faire respecter la déontologie il faut
sévir s'il ya des conflits d'intérêt
local les gens il faut empêcher et c'est
d'ailleurs le but du comité d anthologie
de dd fonctionner au fonctionnaire
public de passer dans le privé d'une
façon absolument je ne dirais pas
illégal mais d'une façon qui qui qui
propose koffi l'intérêt tout cela comme
dans tous les autres domaines il faut
bien entendu faire respecter les règles
mais il faut continuer cette souplesse
qui amène de l'efficacité il faut pas eu
ce conflit public rit c'est un peu comme
le conflit de l'école de l'église et de
l'état en fayyad y a des trucs comme ça
et là on est typiquement dans lesquels
du parti communiste qui s'attaque à ce
genre de ce genre de choses dont on
connaît la commission denquête elle aura
des conclusions qu'on connaît qu'on
connaît déjà et c'est le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup que le mayo rey merci
d'avoir été avec no mercy brigitte
c'était le dernier numéro de cette année
on vous souhaite d'excellentes fêtes de
fin d'année et on se retrouve en janvier
pour un nouveau numéro de parlement
hebdo
[Musique]
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
[Musique]
les éolien ici temps je serai maire ce
n'est absolument pas question il faut
que ce soit le conseil municipal qui
délibère on a des craintes notamment
département de la somme de voir doubler
le nombre d'éoliennes
sortait soir
ce genre d'amendements mais à terre
toute stratégie énergétique française
généralement ça se passe bien quand ça a
été conçu avec les élus pour le
territoire et pour les habitants alors
vous êtes à montdidier catrall yens
public les seuls public de france le
vent vous voyez bien ici bien à vau
l'eau et nous permet vraiment
d'alimenter de courir 50 % de nos
besoins
celle en action demain à 19h sur public
sénat
la saison de ski n'aurait pas pu
commencer sous de meilleurs auspices à
l'alpe d'huez la neige est bien au
rendez vous et les clients aussi un très
très bon taux remplissage à fin novembre
on était à -3% par rapport à l'année
2019 donc c'est rien du tout sachant
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont un
peu dans la salle d'attenté qui attend
de savoir comment ça allait évoluer on
est ravis on est tous impatients de
démarrer une vraie et belle saison seule
ombre au tableau le manque de
saisonniers dans tous les secteurs
d'activité à cause de la crise sanitaire
les remontées mécaniques sont restés à
l'arrêt l'an dernier sans emploi
beaucoup ont choisi de quitter le métier
pour se reconvertir dans cet hôtel de
luxe le manager général fait le point
avec ses équipes vous avez tous les
alcools toutes les boissons le bar doit
ouvrir ce soir et soulagement ici les
effectifs sont au complet c'est une
belle satisfaction voilà un département
qui est au complet c'est toujours une
satisfaction en ce moment le recrutement
a commencé il ya déjà plusieurs mois il
est toujours en cours et l'incertitude
demeure quant on embauche quelqu'un
c'est peut-être pratiquement un mois
avant pendant ce moment là il faut
suivre au quotidien un petit peu cette
candidature maintenir le contact parce
que la personne peut recevoir d'autres
offres mais également des qui nous
rejoignent on peut avoir de mauvaises
surprises même une semaine après avoir
intégré l'établissement le marché est
tellement entendu qu'il y aurait cinq
offres d'emploi pour un saisonnier la
concurrence est rude entre les
établissements nous nous avons une
grille salariale
donc on peut pas exploser comme ça par
contre c'est vrai que quelquefois sur
certains postes qui sont prétendus on
est obligé de s'aligner parce que sinon
on perd le personnel ou sinon juste on
ne recrute pas autre hôtel de luxe
situation identique on a du mal à
recruter sur sept sont divers chose qui
n'arrive pas d'habitude
les vêtements sont assez facilement pour
l'instant il manque encore une personne
n'ose pas si le problème persiste on
sera obligé de limiter les soins limiter
les accès évidemment en perte de chiffre
d'affaires mais mais c'est surtout le
mécontentement vis-à-vis de nos clients
qui est qui qui qui est à risque pour le
service en salle ou dans les étages le
directeur a trouvé une solution
surprenante c'est de faire appel à des
agences d'intérim étrangères dans le
boulevard et polonaises et a aujourd'hui
g20 bulgare et quatre polonais cette
main d'oeuvre étrangère c'est pas notre
premier choix avec tout le respect qu'on
a pour les autres pays européens ça
coûte plus cher déjà entre les
commissions le transport et les
assurances + 30 % de frais
supplémentaires environ je préférais ce
surcoût soit versé à nos employés de
notre pays mais malheureusement on ne
trouve pas donc au bout d'un moment les
clients sont là il va bien falloir
laisser aller du côté des pistes et des
remontées mécaniques il manque environ 3
% de personnel c'est très peu et c'est
principalement à cause du passé ni terre
pour l'instant il est obligatoire pour
tous les employés en contact avec le
public le 15 janvier il sera généralisé
alors la société d'exploitation
accompagnent ces saisonniers avec des
priorités dans certaines pharmacies et
deux sur les deux domaines tout le monde
joue le jeu et puis aussi on a pris la
décision de prendre en charge 50 % des
tests pour tous ceux qui sont dans le
schéma vaccinal donc comme ça ça fait
beaucoup moins lourd pour chacun de nos
mots nos équipiers sur sur la partie
parce vaccinale le but éviter tout
nouveau désistement pour accueillir au
mieux les vingt mille skieurs attendus
pour les vacances de noël
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition des matins du sénat
poursuivre aujourd'hui les travaux de la
commission denquête créé récemment et
qui travaille sur l' influence
croissante des cabinets de conseil privé
sur les politiques publiques avec
l'audition cette semaine des cabinets de
conseil ayant fourni des prestations à
l'état durant la crise sanitaire vous
allez le voir les questions étaient très
précises les réponses un peu moins cette
émission a été préparé par notre
journaliste alice bardot on est un des
cabinets les plus reconnus dans un
domaine en france qui s'appelle la
supply chain dans la soupe la chaîne
c'est très à la mode en ce moment avec
les crises successives pour faire venir
les produits des usines s'arrêtent parce
que les supply chain ne marche pas donc
on intervient du coup dans le monde de
la logistique des flux
d'approvisionnement des flux de
production on est très reconnue par ceux
qui interviennent dans ce domaine
on a un cabinet français actionnaire
français on paye nos impôts en france on
et voilà on s'est pas le cas de tous les
cabinets jeu je tiens à le souligner
on existe depuis 2004
on est une année environ 70 personnes
actuellement
donc notre
notre histoire vis-à-vis de l'état
puisque c'est la question qui nous est
posée aujourd'hui c'est zéro euro de
chiffre d'affaires avec l'état jusqu'en
nous avons par je pense notre notoriété
et est appelé
au tout début de la crise des masques
par la cellule de crise au ministère de
la santé qui cherche à se renforcer dans
le domaine de la logistique comme un des
cabinets notoire sur la place on est
venu un rendez vous on a fait une
proposition commerciale de 50000 euros
qui a convenu tout de suite et ils nous
ont demandé de l'ampl un confinement
de démarrer la mission le plus vite
possible parce qu'il s'agissait de
savoir comment le flux d'un pro des
masques qu'ils allaient débarquer très
vite d'asie on ne savait pas où les
stocker on ne savait pas comment opérer
le flux on sale et penserait pas comment
on allait le distribuer vers l'ensemble
des établissements de soin comment le
répartir donc en fait on nous a confié
une mission qui ne correspond à une
mission de schémas directeurs exactement
comme nos clients privés nous les
demandent sauf que c'était dans un délai
extrêmement court et en plein
confinement
alors on avait une chance c'est que
beaucoup de nos autres clients avait
tout arrêté donc on avait du personnel
disponible beaucoup de personnel
disponible on a fait appel sur nos trois
bureaux de paris lyon et nantes à qui
voulait monter à paris et venir
quotidiennement au ministère de la santé
à la cellule de crise dans la salle
bibliothèque simone veil si je me
rappelle bien pour travailler de longues
heures et est monté l'ensemble des
outils des processus aider à passer les
commandes en appui à la cellule de crise
sous l'autorité du général le chat sac à
cette époque là
et
ma mission la mission donnant
satisfaction s'est enchaîné ensuite avec
les médicaments les médicaments de
réanimation les équipements de
protection
après l'été nous sommes passés à une
phase de transmission de notre savoir
faire donc il ya toute une phase qui
s'est appelée consortium pour pour
pérenniser finalement ce qui avait été
fait les outils les tableaux de bord etc
auprès des agents de l'état et on
pensait avoir fini d'ailleurs on a on a
fini à peu près au mois de novembre 2020
et nous nos clients habituels ayant
repris leurs activités nous étions
plutôt content de pouvoir retourner
travailler pour nous pour nos clients je
vous le cache pas nos équipes je tiens à
nouveau aller saluer elle était assez
épuisé
plusieurs ont dû attraper le coc vide
durant la période puisque effectivement
et prenez les transports en plein
confinement et c'est avec avec des
autorisations de déplacement
il se trouve que à peu près il ya un an
jour pour jour la cellule de crise
accent nous appellent à nouveau en
disant écoutez vous allez donner des
effets entièrement satisfaction donné
satisfaction dans la période des masques
des équipements de protection et des
médicaments il se trouve qu'on va
déclencher maintenant la partie vaccin
il ya tout à faire toute la logistique
est à construire on ne sait pas où
commandes et les congélateurs dans
lesquelles va pas remettre à yzeure on
sait pas où est ce qu'on va cet accent
sait pas quand est ce qui vous arrive et
il va y avoir les ehpad à livrer il faut
construire n'a pas de base de données
des ehpad on connaît pas leur adresse on
n'a pas la liaison entre les officines
et les ehpad donc
tout ça il ya des équipes très limitée
chez spf il faut apporter des outils des
méthodes construire sa et constitue
constituer les schémas les schémas
logistiques voilà quelles ont été nos
missions qui ont donc représenté un
chiffre d'affaires significatif pour
nous en 2020 d'autant plus qu'il était
plus bas que d'habitude donc j'ai qui
représentait 25% notre chiffre
d'affaires et on a dépassé on dépassera
cette année largement les 10 millions
alors deux raisons
effectivement les 10 millions d'euros on
les dépasse largement parce que je pense
qu'il ya 30 35 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires qui représentait par le
travail qui est fait autour des vaccins
et comme nos équipes étaient très
tendues et qu'on était pas capable de
répondre à toute la demande et on est
toujours tendue est toujours en
difficulté aujourd'hui pour répondre à
la demande on a été chercher des sous
traitants ou cotraitants
pour pour nous renforcer et renforcer
nos équipes vu l'intensité de la
sollicitation
ça vous dit après je peux rentrer plus
dans le détail de toutes les activités
mais je vous ai donné je pense brossé un
premier tableau et je me tiens à
disposition censée monde à dos tu as
d'autres questions merci
on va terminer avec monsieur vous êtes
pour j2l france
donc j ll france madame la reporter
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
donc j ll france est un groupe de
conseil spécialisée dans l'immobilier
d'entreprise avec une palette très large
de métier environ un millier de
collaborateurs en france on fait
d'ailleurs cette année nos 50 ans en
france
je ferai exprès pour ça que vous me
demandiez de venir au début mais
finalement pas
et donc nous avons des métiers de la
transaction des métiers du conseil des
métiers de ce qu'on appelle design and
bill c'est à dire une activité de
contracteurs général pour l'aménagement
des bureaux donc une palette large de
métiers autour de l'immobilier qui
touche aussi des fonctions de conseil
dans les différentes classes d'actifs y
compris dans la logistique
nous avons un chiffre d'affaires en
france de l'ordre de 400 millions
d'euros jeudi de l'ordre parce que c'est
425 en 2019 s'est un peu moins de 2 c
autour de 350 en 2020 avec une
proportion assez faible et maintenant
nos interactions avec l'état
puisqu'elles représentent 2 8% en 2010 9
et 2 % de notre chiffre d'affaires
seulement 2020
dans le cadre de la crise sanitaire nous
avons été sollicités pour quatre
missions bien précises
toutes sont aujourd'hui terminés nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui deux missions en
cours avec l'état la première
se
remonte à
c'est mars
à mars à avril 2020 où nous avons
apporté un support opérationnel pour la
distribution des masques
donc on se situe en période de
confinement et nous avons dépêché une
équipe pour
donc il y avait sept
lieues de consignation nous avons
dépêché une personne dans chacun de ces
lieux deux personnes en centrale et
quatre personnes auprès de la cellule de
crise l'idée était de fiabiliser les
stocks 1 vous souvenez évidemment qu'on
était en pénurie à ce moment là et donc
une gestion précise dans un système peu
rodé était importante pour
envoyer les stocks là au sein des
établissements de santé qui en avaient
le plus besoin pour que cette
distribution se fasse de la manière la
plus efficace possible et nous avons
apporté un support très opérationnelles
dans ce cadre là pendant deux mois pour
assurer la bonne remontée d'informations
entre les consignataires et la cellule
de crise pour que la cellule de crise
puissent prendre les bonnes décisions
à l'issue de cette période nous avons
été mandatés pour une deuxième mission
puisque le ministère de la santé et des
solidarités a
souhaité à raison passer d'un chef de
schémas logistiques qui était
essentiellement lié à
ce qu'on appelle un fin qui était lié
par la disponibilité finalement des
stocks un schéma logistique plus
classique qui va dépendre de la demande
des différentes entités de santé qui en
exprimeront le besoin et dans ce cadre
là il ya plusieurs schémas logistiques
qui ont été désignés par le ministère et
sur lequel on nous a demandé de vérifier
la
technicité et la faisabilité
opérationnelle de chacun de ces schémas
c'est une petite mission qui a duré un
mois avec seulement deux personnes et
pour un montant de 60 mille euros ttc si
je reprends le
à la suite de cela certaines de nos
recommandations
touché au tour de l'ain segmentation en
fait des clients pour avoir un schéma
logistique optimale et dans ce cadre-là
a été décidé de mettre en oeuvre
finalement trois
types je dirais de schémas logistiques
pour les équipements de protection
individuelle dont font partie les
masques 1 destinée alors il ya pas mal
d'acronymes et je suis pas toujours
exactement le fait mais 1 1 qui était
géré par les répartiteurs
essentiellement pour les clients comme
les pharmacies ça c'était quelque chose
qui était déjà en place et qui a
continué
quelque chose d'irréel gérés directement
par spf pour les j'ai acheté donc les
gros hôpitaux et puis un consortium qui
a été mis en place pour avec rza unis
achat et la poste pour gérer les
approvisionnements de ce qu'on appelle
les em les oeufs sms donc les
établissements
voilà merci qui demandait une autre un
autre type de logistique et
là nous avons été sollicités pour la
mise en oeuvre opérationnelle
voilà 2 2 ce troisième schéma et puis
ensuite à l'issue de cette donc là on a
insisté notamment sur le déplacement
d'une partie du stock stratégique de spf
vers le consortium pour justement
réussir à fournir cette troisième
catégorie de clients et donc là il faut
bien gérer les quantités le type de
prise de commandes le type de livraison
en fonction c'est différent en
logistique quand vous commandez par
palettes ou quand comme vous commandez
avec des quantités un peu plus peu plus
petit et tout ça ça s'étudie et enfin
nous avons été sollicités dans le cadre
de la distribution des vaccins pour
comme le disait mon collègue mettre en
place la logistique sous contrainte à la
fois par le le délai qu'elle représente
est évidemment des contraintes
logistiques très fort puisque à l'époque
c'était pfizer - 72 degrés est
de la même manière qu'on avait fait pour
les masquer on a dépêché dans certains
des des consignataires un certain nombre
de personnes pour assurer une remontée
d'informations
fiables et donc une distribution
efficace et à propos dans un moment de
crise donc voilà les quatre missions sur
lesquels nous sommes intervenus les
chiffres qui ont été remontés
au correspondent à peu près on peut en
parler il ya il ya quelques voilà je
terminerai en faisant écho à ce que
disait voilà mes collègues
le
[Musique]
donc d'une part il y avait une grande
fierté comme vous l'avez compris l'état
n'est pas un client j'irai structurels
en tout cas significatif
je veux redire ici la fierté que les
équipes ont eu d'avoir eu l'opportunité
finalement de pouvoir travailler sur ces
dossiers là à un moment où tout le monde
était à la maison on découvrait ce que
c'était qu'un confinement avoir le
courage de lever la main et de dire ok
moi j'ai envie d'y aller parce que je me
sens investi d'une mission c'était
quelque chose de fort chez nous en tout
cas en interne et je veux redire aussi
ici que dans nos valeurs l'éthique est
une des valeurs clés est primordial que
nous
que nous développons jll chaque employé
chez jll signe à son arrivée un code
d'éthique d'accord qui a pour but de
d'éviter les conflits d'intérêts qui a
pour but aussi d'éviter l'utilisation de
l'argent issu du terrorisme ou d'aidé
qu'est ce qu'on appelle les cas ici et
que chacun de nos personnels et formés
chaque année pour s'assurer qu'il se
souvient ce qu'il a signé à l'arrivée
quand donc ça c'est que c'est quelque
chose je dirais d'important et dans le
cadre de la préparation de ce rendez
vous c'est pas quelque chose qu'on a
institutionnalisé
mais nous avons aussi vérifier que nous
n'avons pas d'aix fonctionnaires parmi
nos minots 1000 collaborateurs
c'est peut-être une idée on le fera
peut-être de manière systématique mais
puisque c'était une des questions c'est
quelque chose qu'on a vérifié pour les
besoins d'aujourd'hui
merci on va passer maintenant aux
questions donc madame la rapporteure
tout d'abord et vous répondrais selon
votre niveau de auquel vous êtes
concerné puis ensuite on passera à nos
collègues
merci monsieur le président je sais pas
comment on va procéder parce
qu'effectivement trois intervenants sont
intervenus les uns derrière les autres
d'en voir jouer c'est d'abord de d'abord
bienvenue au sénat si c'est votre
première fois au sénat donc bienvenue
j'ai d'abord des questions concernant
jll et accenture
puisque l'un comme l'autre vous êtes
enfin gl elle est basée aux états unis
accenture est basé en irlande et j'ai
deux questions
est-ce que cela a des conséquences sur
le droit applicable aux traitements et
aux données au traitement et la
conservation des données par exemple on
regarde au regard des plats cloud
américain ça c'est la première question
avec la deuxième question est ce que
cela a des conséquences sur les impôts
payés en france par vos sociétés
accenture et jdl
accenture france est une société
française depuis 45 ans on paye nos
impôts ici fait partie d'un réseau et
d'un groupe international mais accenture
france est une société française qui
paye ses impôts sur le territoire
français tous les tous les dossiers tous
les dossiers qu'on traite avec le
service public passe dans le code des
marchés publics et donc respecte tout à
fait les règles qui sont qui viennent de
ces marchés là
je fais là une réponse similaire ah
pardon vous enlevez le micro donc nous
ça fait cinquante ans que nous sommes en
france que nous payons nos impôts en
france que nos employés sont tous
exclusivement de soumis au droit
français et la question que vous posez
très justement sur le le l'âge et la gr
et la gestion des données est une
question que l'on a de tous nos clients
privés aussi et nous sommes évidemment
organisé pour enfin toutes les données
européennes sont stockés en europe et
est en france en l'occurrence donc il ya
il ya enfin voilà le la question de la
gestion des données que se pose le
l'état est tout aussi sensible pour
l'ensemble des autres et donc nous avons
dû mettre en place évidemment les
procédures pour que la gestion des
données soit je sois localisés dans les
pays où nous les traitons
d'écouté on va continuer à vous poser
des questions je vais commencer par
monsieur olivier girard d'accenture
c'est donc vous nous avait expliqué que
la plupart de vos prestations porte sur
l'accompagnement informatique si j'ai
bien compris donc d'accord donc est ce
que l'on pourrait savoir sur combien de
systèmes d'information êtes vous
intervenu
donc qu'est-ce que vous pouvez les
nommés à la commission devant la
commission denquête
s'agissant de l'application tous antique
au lied et elle dans votre champ
d'intervention est ce qu'il est possible
que vous nous présenter votre
intervention sur les autres dispositifs
informatiques notamment sur l'est sipa
sanitaires les fichiers de vaccination
est un système d'information appeler sii
logistique
et donc le dernière qu'elles susciteront
quelles sont vos relations avec la
direction interministérielle du
numérique de la d8
pour le pardon décidément pour le pour
la première question il convient de
système on vous répondra précisément
dans la note écrite parce qu'il peut y
en avoir un certain nom dans le temps le
cadre de la gestion de la crise nous
n'avons pas construit de systèmes nous
avons participé c'est une équipe qui
étaient entre cinq et dix personnes
depuis le début jusqu'à aujourd'hui et
participe à des travaux qui sont en
amont de la construction du système
c'est-à-dire des spécifications des
plantes thèse et plan d'interfaçage donc
on n'a pas touché on n'a pas développé
aux applications que vous citez voyez
tous sentis covin notamment et celle du
pass annie terre non plus en revanche on
a construit des spécifications qui
permet de faire parler des systèmes ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure dans le
propos liminaire de les faire parler
avec des systèmes européens donc on n'a
pas touché à ce qu'on appelle du code
dans le jargon dans le cadre de cette de
cette mission là hélas d'inhumer est
aussi un
organisme de l'état avec lequel nous
travaillons également bien sûr
écoutez je vais continuer sauf s'ils
n'ont pas les jets ont continué par par
par
monsieur laurent pénard sitwell donc
donc nous on a bien compris que vous
étiez vous spécialiser dans la chaîne
logistique notamment pour les masques et
les vaccins litige je me trompe tout à
fait moi j'ai une question tout ça avec
les choses reposait à tout le monde vous
comme d'autres personnes ou structures
que nous allons auditionner emploi et
vous plus performant que l'état dans
l'organisation logistique
c'est une question on est plus
performant
en fait toute entreprise aujourd'hui
toute organisation fait appel à du
conseil pas que l'état aujourd'hui des
spécialistes
industrie des spécialistes industriels
je pense qu amazon fait appel à du
conseil
pas un site web mais décathlon
fait appel à des consultants comme nous
je veux dire c'est des spéciales et on
parle de politique publique monsieur oui
non mais je donc ils ont des
spécialistes de la logistique en tout
cas je ne sais pas moi je ne sais pas
répondre pourquoi l'état n'a pas de
spécialiste de la logistique sais pas
c'est pas dans mon rôle de juger quoi
que ce soit sur les décisions de l'état
de fait
ce qu'on a constaté c'est que les agents
de l'état qui étaient affectés aux
missions on a travaillé avec des agents
de l'état qui était compétent qui
étaient peu nombreux sur ces sujets là
et qu'ils étaient ravis d'avoir autour
d'eux des collègues de travail durant
toute cette période qui leur disaient
comment comme on faire au mieux comment
améliorer les solutions comment les
dépanner
à certains moments où il s'agissait de
trouver comment l'avion d'air france qui
va décoller de la chine pourra décoller
c'est des choses ça me paraît pas
irréaliste que l'état français ne sache
pas opérer des soc la chaîne mondiale
voilà
que s'il y avait des spécialistes comme
ça à faire en permanence dans l'état et
dans les services de l'état je me dirais
mais à quoi sert-il
tout simplement
en tout cas nous on a dû on a bien droit
on a beaucoup de mal à aller recruter à
les former noah nos spécialistes je peux
vous le dire je crois que était été
aussi abordé la question de comment
recruter comment garder des compétences
de ce type là oui ces cdd - des jeunes
et des moins jeunes collaborateurs qui
veulent des projets attrayant qui sont
sur des systèmes complexes qui ont des
connaissances de méthode et
effectivement c'est parce qu'ils vont
travailler dans beaucoup d'environnement
qui vont être complètement fait
et voilà je après je ne peux pas vous en
dire plus sur les les missions de l'état
dans ce domaine merci monsieur stéphane
sautarel pour la première question nos
collègues oui merci monsieur le
président moi j'avais une question
essentiellement pour monsieur hainard
est boudée parce que je m'interroge en
fait sur la manière dont la commande a
été passée
puisque pour l'un vous avez évoqué en
fait ce que j'appellerais des commandes
en cascade c'est à dire suite à une
première commande d'autres commandes au
regard d'une satisfaction ou d'un besoin
qui existaient mais du coup quel a été
le vecteur de la commande publique et
pour l'autre vous avez souvent évoqué le
fait on a été sollicités et et or
normalement dans la commande publique il
ya une appel d'offres et une
consultation il ya une réponse qui est
apportée et donc je voulais juste
m'assurer de la manière dans
le contrat public avait été produit
[Musique]
alors vous allez répondre le tour de
rôle autour de la tour de robert
simplement de gauche à droite ça vous
gêne je veux bien un jeu bien commencé
effectivement comme si j'avais décrit
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur la
première commande
je pense que c'est le contexte d'urgence
et de crise qui a fait cette cascade de
commandes et santé publique france en
2000 en 2021 est passé après en appel
d'offres et nous verrons après pondu à
cet appel d'offres au mois d'avril mai
et nous avons remporté cet appel d'offre
conjointement avec bearingpoint et jll
en sous traitant
mais ceci s'adresse en fait à nos
prestations à partir depuis l'été
dernier depuis le 15 juillet nous sommes
dans le cadre de cet appel d'offres pas
de démission que couvrait cet appel
d'offres d'appui à santé publique france
est-ce que
ça couvre ma réponse couvre de répondre
à votre question
oui oui ça ça signifie donc que jusqu
alors il n'y avait pas de marchés
publics et où on peut l'expliquer par
l'urgence mais c'est un élément qui est
important pour notre commission de
connaître ces étapes là et essayer
divers tente d'autres mondes ça peut
s'expliquer par le montant des marchés
aussi face à peut être aussi
la concurrence soutenant qu'il peut peut
être passé sous sap candidat qui est pas
formalisée de la même manière tout à
fait
bon monsieur girard quand vous nous avez
dit que vous aviez vous recours aux
moeurs à l'accord cadre des hits épais
et puis à lui ap est ce qu'il ya
d'autres éléments non séparent ces deux
véhicules contractuels la con on est
intervenu
en ce qui nous concerne c'est parce que
nous avons fait l'acquisition en 2019
donc conseil en supply chain qui est
très réputé dans le domaine que nous
avons émergé lors de la première mission
en tant que sous traitant sur la
première mission de masques et à partir
de là nous avons été identifiées donc
qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya eu un besoin
tels que décrits dans chacune des quatre
missions c'est là que nous avons été
sollicités systématiquement comme sous
traitants
je reviendrai vers vous pour être sûr je
si vous l'avez été comme sous traitant
les pensées complète si vous l'avez été
en tant qu'entité de votre entreprise
vous avez nécessairement répondu à un
appel d'offres
de ce que je dans l'état de mes
connaissances il me semble qu'il ya donc
il ya interne
urgence impérieuse ou donc sur ses
missions la de mémoire en tout cas dans
l'état je reviendrai vers vous pour être
sûr y'a pas il n'y a pas eu d'appel de
récits serez tous à paris voilà
exactement touquet nathalie goulet
oui monsieur le président je remercie
monsieur gérard j'allais vous pose
évidemment la même question que la
présidente à celle ci compte tenu du
siège de votre entreprise est en
situation et du fait que vous soyez
président pour la france et le
luxembourg ce qui attire chez certains
d'entre nous au nombre de réflexes
voilà donc bon j'ai bien compris que
vous payez vos impôts en france
c'est très très bien j'allais vous
demandez est-ce que c'est ce sont tous
les impôts est ce que est ce que par
exemple politique de dividende est aussi
nationale comment est-ce qu'elle
fonctionne est ce qu'il ya une est-ce
que vous reverser une partie
des revenus à une à une société mère qui
serait par exemple au luxembourg ou
ailleurs donc la totalité de la phase
que vous pourriez nous donner un peu la
structure fiscale de l'entreprise ou est
ce qu'elle est simplement
franco-française la deuxième chose vous
avez une partie d'activités qui s'exerce
dans le lobby si j'ai bien lu non alors
j'ai mal lu donc en revanche je crois
que c'est monsieur boudet qui a parlé de
segmentation des clients ou est ce que
c'est vous monsieur ferrat c'est vous
est ce que vous pouvez me dire ce que ça
veut dire parce que j'ai absolument pas
compris
je vais répondre en premier monsieur
girard je voudrais répondre ah oui alors
la question de la question très simple
un accenture france paye des impôts en
france il ya aussi les belges à pâques
et luxembourgeois dans le périmètre que
j'ai le privilège de 2,10 g de diriger
pardon donc on vous fera des compléments
par écrit si nécessaire mais c'est tout
à fait simple et voilà accenture france
fait des revenus en france à des
contrats français avec des clients
français et des ressources française et
puis et paye ses impôts ici
et madame pour répondre à votre question
sur la segmentation des clients un
schéma logistique dépend de la fréquence
de vos commandes détail moyenne que vous
commandez et de vos capacités de
stockage avoue encore quand vous prenez
un amazon vous passer une commande
aujourd'hui et vous est livré dans deux
heures dans d'autres schémas vous aller
par exemple dans un magasin est donc un
autre schéma logistique qui s'applique
dans le cadre ici il a été identifié que
certains clients dans la dèche 2 2
qui participait dans le chaînage des
équipements de protection individuelle
avait des schémas logistiques différents
les pharmacies par exemple qui en
général commande le matin je crois est
en quelque chose l'après midi les j'ai
acheté les gros hôpitaux qui elles
peuvent commander par exemple par
palettes ou des petits hôpitaux qui vont
avoir des besoins de quelques cartons
par exemple et donc les besoins de
logistique étant différent pour chacun
de ces acteurs pour de manière à avoir
une qualité de service et un coup
adéquat qui correspondent aux besoins
des clients il vaut mieux les dix vols
et diversifiée car si vous appliquez un
schéma logistique unique à tout le monde
soit vous n'aurez pas la bonne qualité
de service soit vous aurez des coûts
trop élevés donc c'est ça un peu le but
des recommandations si vous voulez
qu'ils ont contribué à avoir un schéma
logistique différenciées en fonction des
différents segments de clients
voilà je ne sais pas si ça non
merci pour ces précisions nicole dumont
temps
merci monsieur le président où merci
messieurs pour vos différentes
interventions donc j'aurai deux
questions auprès de monsieur bénard et
une nous prennent goût des donc les
projets de transformation que vous avez
menées sur les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
les différents groupes grands groupes
industriels sont ils différents des
projets de transformation de l'action
publique de l'état et si oui quelles
sont les principales différences et
l'autre question c'est donc un cabinet
de conseil est il plus influent lors de
la phase de conception d'une politique
publique comme ici donc au parlement ou
lors de sa phase de mise en oeuvre
déploiement exécution contrôle donc
auprès du gouvernement et des services
de l'état
et je dirais c'est la temporalité des
choses qui peut faire d une entreprise
qui va nous consulter parce qu elle l
euro réfléchit à sa manière d'adresser
ses marchés ses clients comme comme dit
précédemment
va se donner un peu de temps va
travailler avec ces directions
commerciales son marketing va prendre le
temps de d'exprimer un besoin ce qui
peut amener peut-être à changer la
manière de décider de ses transports par
exemple à changer des modalités pour
passer de transport routier ou maritime
plutôt qu'avion enfin moi il peut y
avoir ce genre de choses décidé d'ouvrir
des nouveaux entrepôts ou d'enfermer de
se redéployer en général cdd schéma qui
sont dans une certaine longueur
il ya forcément des sites des sites et
des pots des effectifs à redéployer et
c'est donc la phase de réflexion prend
du temps en général il faut que tout le
monde soit bien d'accord et puis qu'on
déclenche une transformation après il
faut opérer cette transformation est là
faut accompagner les équipes
ça peut être des ménages et d'aménager
des sites changer la manière dont on
planifie l'activité
cédée projet qui se déroule sur
plusieurs années très souvent ce qu'on a
constaté même avec les entreprises
privées ces derniers temps c'est que ce
temps dans cet intervalle de temps
considérablement fondu parce qu'ils ont
été obligés de redéployer des logistique
extrêmement rapidement parce que des
marchés s'était fermé des
approvisionnements c'était fermé et donc
une grande partie des sollicitations
qu'on a en ce moment sont totalement
liés à sa son jeu doit redéployer mes
ressources pour essayer de servir un
certain nombre de marchés il ya beaucoup
de similitudes finalement avec ce qu'on
a vécu là durant la crise puisque en
quelques semaines on apprenait que
astrazeneca qui devait arriver de
manière très massives finalement
n'arrivent pas du tout de manière
massive donc on avait fait un premier
schéma visant à dire toutes les
officines pourront avoir tant de flacons
tout le monde pourra commander deux ou
trois flacons par semaine et puis y
compris les médecins etc en fait on
apprend une semaine avant que c'est
peut-être un tiers ou un quart des
volumes qui arrive que fait-on et donc
là il ya plusieurs scénarios qui ont été
proposées
à la cellule la cellule de crise pour
dire va soit on dit à tous les médecins
vous commandez pas plus d'un flacon soit
on laisse toutes les commandes pas voilà
donc là il ya une adaptation sur un
délai très court par rapport à une
pénurie qui nécessitent des calculs
savoir combien de personnes on va servir
on était en liaison avec les ars leur
demandant d'opérer aussi des décisions
complexes avec les différents
établissements de santé donc en fait des
raisonnements qu'on a l'habitude de
faire sur plusieurs mois là il fallait
les faire quelques fois en quelques
jours c'est pour ça que des comités de
pilotage quotidien qu'on avait
s'éternisait bien plus tard
qu'habituellement on finissait des fois
à 22 heures pour sortir un nouveau
scénario qui serait soumis à la cellule
le lendemain
j'ai pas répondu à toutes vos questions
mais peut-être sur un sur cet aspect là
de poser ma question monsieur bd oui
monsieur donc vous vous avez une
expérience professionnelle à l'étranger
notamment en allemagne et en russie donc
quel ce quelle est selon vous donc les
principales différences en fait
d'interaction entre le public et le
privé en matière de politiques publiques
en fonction des pays
je suis vraiment incapable de répondre à
cette question puisque comme je vous le
dis nos interactions en france sont
assez limitées et en allemagne là où
vous faites référence j'étais dans une
autre fonction le le hasard veut que
j'étais patron de la supply chain de
danone à l'époque d'accord donc rien à
voir avec l'immobilier et en russie
j'étais pour jl elle ne travaillait pas
avec l'êta donc je suis vraiment
incapable de vous répondre par contre je
veux bien rebondir sur le point
précédent et peut être complétée je
pense que vous allez demander
où est ce qu'un cabinet de conseil a
plus d'influencé sur la partie
conception sur la partie mise en oeuvre
c'est sans aucun doute sur la partie
conception encore et toutes les missions
en tout cas que j'ai décrite et je crois
mes collègues aussi sont uniquement des
de la mise en oeuvre opérationnelle au
jour là dans tous ces cas là il y avait
une cellule de crise qui prenait des
décisions et il y avait des exécutants
et donc l'apport des conseils en tout
cas de jll dans ce cadre là c'était
vraiment d'apporter de l'exercent de l'
expertise et des besoins humains sur des
décisions qui étaient prises par l'état
nathalie goulet voulez un petit
complément minuscule sur est ce qu est
ce qu est ce parce que quand vous êtes
arrivé vous avez vous avez vous nous
avez dit d'ailleurs qu'il y avait des
failles dans les dispositifs et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a eu recours à
ces cabinets est-ce que vous avez
suscité des vocations à l'intérieur des
administrations dans lesquels vous avez
travaillé
est ce que par hasard on a créé un
département de façon non pas à absorber
vos connaissances mais en tous les cas à
former des gens à l'intérieur des
administrations ce qui permettrait
éventuellement de prévenir un certain
nombre de difficultés à l'avenir ou es
ce que vous avez le sentiment que le
rôle à
leurs cours le recours à des cabinets
extérieurs a constitué un tel
soulagement qui va être une procédure
qui va perdurer dans le temps ce que
c'est quand même important quand il ya
des failles comme ça qu'on essaye de
zéro est ce que quand on attendait des
fonctionnaires formidable d
administration que le monde entier nous
envie est-ce que vous avez suscité des
vocations pour combler les trous dans le
dispositif alors dans la mesure où nous
sommes en fort recrutement j'espère
qu'on a suscité des vocations et on sera
ravis d'accueillir les talents fille s'y
fait rare c'est pas ça la question ouais
c'est exactement le contraire
la seule chose que je rajouterais c'est
que
puisque là on parle de missions qui sont
passés en temps de crise et je suis
aussi chef d'entreprise je n'essaye pas
d'être équipé pour faire face à toutes
les crises possible ça me donnerait une
base de coûts qui seraient tout
simplement inacceptable par rapport à
mon activité et donc pour répondre à
votre question il ya certainement enfin
des éléments à prendre en compte
conseiller le gouvernement de s'équiper
pour faire face à toutes les crises y
compris celle d'une ampleur du coc vide
dans tous les cas de figure c'est pas
certainement quelque chose qui qui qui
qui serait économiquement viable à mon
avis
merci je le peux je peux compléter si
vous voulez parce qu'il ya un lumignon
3g une expérience positive de ça
effectivement dans la dans la période
j'ai évoqué un moment donné que on a
commencé à transférer du savoir faire
mais il n'y a pas eu que ça en fait il y
aller aujourd'hui vous avez des
centrales d'achat qui
interviennent au carrefour justement des
besoins hospitaliers je pense à unis
achat ou
aux raisins et
c'était plutôt des centrales d'achat qui
consolidait des besoins mais n'avait pas
réellement de logistique la logistique
était laissée aux établissements de
soins je pense que la crise à leur a
fait prendre conscience du rôle
particulier que pouvait jouer c'est ces
établissements et qui ont commencé à se
structurer donc aujourd'hui ils sont
effectivement en train d'évoluer je
pense vers beaucoup plus une capacité à
adresser comment je peux être un tiers
intermédiaire entre les différents
établissements de soins et les
fournisseurs les laboratoires etc et
avoir cette capacité et du coup on
monter en compétences on
recherchait à accroître leurs
compétences dans ce domaine
ce qui ce qui sera certainement pas à
l'avenir un quelque chose de très
positif pour la capacité de réaction
parce que je pense par exemple si la
crise des masques se reproduisait demain
illustré il sera tout à fait en
situation réagi
merci
nicole durand ton art demandé la parole
pour un petit complément rapide et on
prendra tout de suite derrière la
question de patrice joly merci monsieur
le président donc qu'est ce qui pourrait
faire qu'un cabinet de conseil
s'intéresse mois à la gestion de la des
politiques publiques
merci j'aimerais dire merci messieurs
pour vos interventions ma question sera
relativement simple
l'intervention de cabinet conseil est
d'autant plus pertinente qu au sein de
l'institution d'administration de
l'organisme qui a recours il y a déjà un
minimum d'expertisé qui me conduit à ce
que les cahiers des charges
quand même défini de manière la plus
pertinente possible et de manière à ce
qu ensuite pendant de la mission et
et comment se déroule on est
effectivement un véritable
accompagnement est ce que vous avez eu
le sentiment de disposer en face de vous
d'interlocuteurs suffisamment comment
compétent sur les matières sur
lesquelles vous êtes intervenu merci ces
deux questions messieurs qui répond
je veux dire je vais bien prendre la
question merci oui la réponse est oui je
pense que pour que les choses
s'enchaînent parce que ça a été très
bien décrit à ma droite la gauche le
temps réel était le temps de cette crise
et donc il y avait bien eu un une
conjugaison des expertises l' expertise
de l'environnement de là santé en france
et d expertise vous disais à ma droite à
ma gauche logistique et dans mon cas
plus technologique c'est cette addition
là qui a fait que on a pu fonctionner
dans ce temps réel là donc oui je pense
qu'il ya eut bien une addition des
expertises civiles et mon expertise pour
écouter les expertises
j'ai bien compris qu'elle avait
complémentarité s'était pas tout à fait
le sens de ma question c'est est ce que
vous avez trouvé à l'intérieur
effectivement des interlocuteurs qui
avaient un minimum de connaissances sur
votre expertise pour pouvoir en tirer le
meilleur parti
oui je vais peut-être pas bien répondu
mais c'est ce que je voulais dire oui
tout à fait oui
vous souhaitez compléter messieurs
je voudrais
non enfin bon le gt pas moi en contact
évidemment direct mais le retour et
finalement les résultats font vraiment
pencher là mais je trouve que vous
soulevez un point qui est très très
juste un conseil il faut aussi le gérer
le manager d'accord et pour ça il faut
avoir
voilà effectivement ce niveau de
compétences en interne pour donc c'était
tout à fait voilà à propos - le retour
des équipes étaient très encore une fois
beaucoup découvrez les interactions avec
la sphère publique était vraiment
impressionné à la fois par le deal le
niveau des gens est ce que c'est un
niveau de compétence exact je sais pas
vous dire parce que j'étais pas en
contact direct mais des retours très
positifs
sur la question de m duranton pour
seniors oui effectivement j'ai noté le
terme influence alors je me sens très
mal à l'aise avec ce terme
puisque je vois pas que en dehors d'une
la seule influence qui était notée de
notre part tous les soirs c'était dans
vous dites l'influencent des cabinets
sur la sphère publique c'était votre
question
je sais pas répondre à cette question
on s'intéresse moins non quand on répond
quand on répond à des sollicitations
cherche pas forcément
influencé je dirais que mais ça c'est
moi ma posture de cabinet plus
opérationnels jours revenus ou pas
vraiment sur une question assez
intéressante qui avait posé également
madame de rang tant sur la question de
l' influence développer un peu ce que
vous avez commencé à dire oui oui nos
mesures effectivement j'avais j'avais
noté ce mot clé parce que effectivement
s'il ya effectivement un regret qu'on
pourra conserver nous peut-être au-delà
de cette crise c'est de se dire est ce
que on a essaimé des savoir-faire et
effectivement c'est un retour
d'expérience très important à avoir nous
jeu je sais qu'il ya un certain nombre
de permanents dans les différentes
instances qu'on a pu conseiller avec
lesquels on a opéré qui sont toujours là
il y en a un certain nombre qui ont
changé de poste
des fois je dirais un peu
malheureusement parce que il ya une
autre une nouvelle personne qui est
arrivé et on a on l'a formé à nouveau on
l'accompagné et c est ça en pleine crise
c'est vrai que ça c'était ce n'était pas
forcément simple
merci alors messieurs moi j'ai trois
questions pour vous je vous demanderais
s'il vous plaît d'y répondre
successivement un première c'est avez
vous effectué des prestations gratuites
pendant la crise sanitaire si c'est le
cas mais pour quelles missions et
combien de consultants avez vous
mobiliser toujours si c'est le cas c'est
mission se sont-elles prolongée par la
facturation de prestations
complémentaires à titre onéreux
voilà pour le premier bloc de questions
il a deux la dernière question c'est
[Musique]
je souhaite que vous ne puissiez nous
décrire un peu précisément les
conditions dans lesquelles vous avez pu
accéder à la cellule interministérielle
de crise
on commence par le pro bono monsieur
bénard
pas de promo nos je dirais que
on a en a constitué des équipes avec des
niveaux de séniorité très différents et
on a
toujours tâché d'appliquer un taux
journalier moyen qu'ils soient de 20%
inférieurs à ce qu'on fait les
entreprises privées voilà ce qui fait
qu'on s'est retrouvé à un peu plus de
1000 euros alors que notre taux habituel
est plutôt à 1300 à 1400 au niveau des
entreprises privées
après on a fait beaucoup d'heures
supplémentaires est bon ça
c'était
voilà ça faisait partie du don du don
que les collaborateurs étaient tout à
fait amené à fermer définitivement
toutes les toutes nos prestations fait
l'objet de bons de commande successifs
comme on l'a dit et côté effectivement
en fonction du du temple du temps passé
par les équipes votre accès à la cellule
interministérielle de crise 1 un coup de
fil un coup de fil comme je vous le
disais
des procédures de sécurité particulières
pardon c'est ce qu'il y avait des
procédures de sécurité particulières
dans quel cadre pour accéder à la
cellule de crise à vous lire pour aller
dans les locaux
je vérifie parce que moi j'ai été
personnellement chez santé publique
france donc plutôt dans la deuxième
partie nos interventions au ministère de
la santé je ne faut que je demande elle
c'est elle et
monsieur girard
sur votre première question précisément
sur l'enchaînement prestations gratuites
puis prestations payantes non puisque
ici encore une fois on a été invités à
répondre à des demandes et on a fait des
devis dans le cadet des objets dont je
parlais tout à l'heure accenture fait du
pro bono par ailleurs quasi
essentiellement pour le monde associatif
et je vous répondrai plus précisément
par écrit sur sa sur la question de la
cellule dont vous parlez j'avoue que je
ne sais pas je prendrai le temps de me
répondre par écrit sur cette question
très précise je vous ai un peu pareil
pas de pro bono chez nous et
comme je voulais dire nous avions des
personnes dépêchées pour assurer la
bonne fluidité des informations
mais je sais pas exactement dans quelles
conditions ça c'est fait puisque moi j
étais pas donc je vous répondrai pas
écrit là-dessus
je me reporte
oui merci monsieur le président une
question à vous trois si vous permettez
monsieur la première c'est une seule
question d'ailleurs est-ce que vous
utilisez les données transmises par
l'état français pour répondre aux
commandes d'autres clients notamment
pour réaliser un benchmark avec d'autres
pays ça c'est ma première question à
chacun d'entre vous et si je peux me
permettre de poursuivre
particulièrement à monsieur girard
accenture est ce que l'état pourrait
continuer d'utiliser le pas salutaire si
aujourd'hui vous dit s'il y est de vous
retirer du système
d'information correspondant
voilà je pense que c'est une question
qui peut intéresser beaucoup de nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens au delà de
cette commission denquête et puis une
dernière question aussi un
bout d'essai la dernière commande qui a
été passée par l'état votre entreprise
elle date de décembre 2020
donc est ce qu on pourrait savoir
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas intervenu
depuis
et puis
historiquement vous êtes spécialisé dans
le conseil en immobilier si j'ai bien
compris et de quelle manière et doux
devenu avec fierté ce dénoter un cabinet
généraliste capable d'accompagner l'état
dans la gestion de la crise sanitaire
sur merci
on sait par monsieur bénard
l'utilisation des données c'est tessa
votre question tous nos contrats sont
dans des cadres confidentialité totale
je sais que dans le cadre de du
ministère de la santé la et de spf tous
les documents etc et sur les serveurs de
l'administration
on a systématiquement laisser toutes les
données dans le dans le cadre dans le
cadre public donc après voilà je je
dirais si c'est pour utiliser de faire
du benchmark
interpays nous on n'est pas très
concernés parce qu'on est très français
et je vois pas bien je vois pas bien ce
que ça donne ça signifie que vous
n'utilisez pas les données que vous avez
recueillis dans le cas des commandes de
l'état pour nourrir des bases de données
qui permettent de construire après une
réflexion aussi interdit clair non non
c'est interdit
ah oui par notre le prix et les contrats
puis de toute façon tous nos clients
[Musique]